qui veut prendre la parole d'emblée tout
de suite
vous souhaitez maintenant ou après la
discussion de la motion
merci merci je pensais prendre la parole
après la motion mais je peux prendre la
parole avant la motion comme vous le
souhaitez monsieur le Président c'est
vous qui êtes maître indiqué que vous
souhaitiez la prendre avant mais si
c'est après on fait tout de suite la
motion de renvoi et ensuite je vous
donne la parole pas de problème alors on
fait d'abord la motion de renvoi
d'accord
donc Madame Emilienne pouillerol et les
membres du groupe socialiste écologistes
et républicains ont déposé une motion
tendance on renvoie à la Commission de
l'article de cette motion porte le
numéro 47 40 la parole est donc à Madame
Emilienne Poumirol pour la motion
le ministre cher collègue
pour les personnes
âgées de plus de 55 ans cet article
introduit un indicateur relatif à
l'emploi des salariés pour les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
l'index senior
cette réforme des retraites voulues par
le gouvernement et donc bien non
seulement une réforme budgétaire mais
bien aussi une réforme du marché du
travail qui ne dit pas son nom la
création de index seniors en est un
exemple et si nous obtenions la fameuse
note du Conseil d'État dont nous parlons
depuis deux jours peut-être il
virions-nous évoqué le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité de cet article 2
l'index senior n'a en effet aucune
incidence financière et n'a donc rien à
faire dans un plfs SS rectificatif
alors oui la situation des seniors sur
le marché du travail en France n'est pas
bonne cela va d'ailleurs était pointé
dans un rapport de nos collègues René
Paul Savary et Monique Lubin en 2019
selon la Dares 56% seulement des seniors
sont dans l'emploi comme 65 % 60,5 % en
Europe et les chiffres du ministère du
Travail parlent de 53,8% contre 70% en
Allemagne ou en Suède par ailleurs nous
savons que le recul de l'âge de départ
de 60 à 62 ans de la réforme verse en
2010 a provoqué 100000 chômeurs de plus
combien pour le passage de 62 à 64 ans
90 000 selon la Dares 300 000 selon le
FCE et uneédique dans un rapport récent
du 1er mars 2023 vient de confirmer que
l'approche de l'âge de la retraite
entraîne un pic de rupture
conventionnelle monsieur le ministre
avez-vous évalué le coût de de ces
données supplémentaires par ailleurs nos
collègues LR ont déposé des propositions
sur l'emploi des seniors et donc nous
avons besoin d'étudier en profondeur ce
dossier en commission on ne peut pas
régler par un simple article
rectificatif du PLFSS sans qu'il y ait
un débat de fond au sein de la Haute
Assemblée nous présentons donc cette
motion de renvoi à commission que nous
vous demandons d'adopter
merci Madame Poumirol donc nous avons la
possibilité d'avoir un contre je donne
la parole à la présidente de roche
si monsieur le Président je suis à la
fois donner
en donnant la vie contre je donnerai
également la vie de la commission
puisque elle ne sait pas réuni sur cette
motion spécifique qui vient de tomber
mais on a donné déjà deux fois des avis
défavorables sur des renvois en
commission d'abord il y a une motion d'y
recevabilité que nous avons rejeté on
est un peu dans la même veine et dans le
même esprit donc voilà pourquoi je donne
un avis contre et puis je voulais aussi
préciser que le renvoi en commission moi
je veux bien mais lorsqu'on a fait la
commission mardi dernier on a passé deux
heures en commission et il y a eu très
peu de prise de parole mais ce que je ne
vous reproche pas nous disons on se
réserve pour le débat alors si on se
réserve pour le débat et on a vu en
effet que vous réserviez pour le débat
ça c'est indéniable on a bien remarqué
je vois pas l'intérêt tu as renvoi en
commission c'est donc un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
mais ma vie pour le gouvernement donc il
y a la possibilité d'une explication de
votre part groupe est-ce que certains
souhaitent
madame poncemonge allez-y
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
pour mon groupe moi je vais je vais
soutenir cette demande de renvoi et pour
une raison bien précise parce que je
souhaite qu'on rediscute des amendements
que la commission a jugé y recevable sur
l'index des seniors alors qu'on est en
plein paradoxe parce que le gouvernement
laisse l'index cela tout en te tenant
compte lui qui a pris connaissance de la
vie je dis bien de la vie du Conseil
d'État qu'il risque d'être supprimé donc
il le maintient c'est normal parce que
c'est censé atténuer non pas atténué
mais là avoir une obligation une petite
demande une petite contrainte envers les
employeurs alors il aimerait bien
laisser cette illusion qui demande
quelque chose aux employeurs bien
pourquoi pas mais moi ce que je vois
c'est que beaucoup d'amendements ayant
très à l'index ont été non pas refusé
c'était des demandes de rapport sous
prétexte que c'était l'article 40 tout
ça mais quand
[Musique]
rien de surprenant à ce que je vous
disais qu'effectivement nous soutenons
cette demande de renvoi en commission
puisque c'est la nôtre
mais parce que nous estimons bon alors
on aura l'occasion on a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur cette index des
seniors et sur la forme et sur le fond
mais nous estimons effectivement que
cette réforme des retraites ne prend
absolument pas en compte la situation
des seniors qu'elle n'a que nous n'avons
aucune étude chiffrée qui nous permet à
part quelques approximations de temps en
temps qui nous permet de savoir quelle
sera la situation des seniors après
c'est ces deux années supplémentaires
de de travail de chômage pour certains
enfin bref donc nous nous considérons
que même si nous avons eu une réunion de
commission effectivement mais à la
limite ça n'est ça n'est presque pas ça
que nous remettons en question c'est les
éléments dont la commission aux
républiciers travailler nous estimons
que que nous n'en avez pas eu
suffisamment dans ce projet de réforme
des retraites et puis bon même en
arrêtant de gamberger sur cette fameuse
note dont nous aimerions avoir
connaissance
il nous en a été parlé à l'Assemblée
nationale nous savons à peu près ce
qu'il y a dedans et nous savons que ce
cet article 2 va certainement être
activement est un cavalier législatif et
donc nous allons y passer beaucoup de
temps dessus pourquoi au final et
peut-être juste pour le vote d'un projet
de loi qui abîme rat considérablement la
situation des seniors
merci Monsieur Savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mais mes chers collègues
nous soutenons la motion en renvoie en
commission de l'article 2 relatif à
l'index senior qui est déposé par le
groupe socialiste en effet le
gouvernement met en place un index pour
les entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
avec pour seul obligation j'irai dire
l'unique obligation c'est la publication
de ce dernier et une sanction pouvant
aller jusqu'à 1% de la masse salariale
le cas échéant faut savoir que cette
rédaction là je vais retrouver texto
dans les affirmations et les volontés ça
va étonner personne du hop des grandes
entreprises et pour pas le nommer c'est
le Medef
donc sans contrainte c'est index n'aura
aucun pouvoir de contrainte alors que
les trajectoires entre l'emploi et la
retraite ne sont pas linéaires tout le
monde le sait ici en effet nous pouvons
ignorer qu'à 60 ans près d'une personne
sur trois nez ni en emploi ni en
retraite
et que la majorité d'entre elles sont en
situation des fois malheureusement
d'invalidité de RSA ou de chômage les
tous dans une grande précarité ainsi
nous dénonçons cet allongement du ce
qu'on peut appeler le sas de précurité
des seniors qui aura des conséquences
des astruses pour trop de personnes et
puis je voudrais faire aussi un petit
revenir un petit peu en arrière j'espère
que ça nous rassemblera unean ici parce
que l'expérience la preuve du pudding
c'est qu'on le mange c'est qu'à l'instar
il y a eu un index égalité homme-femme
rappelez-vous il a été créé en 2018 et
bah c'est index il n'a pas favorisé
l'application de la loi sur l'égalité
salariale donc on a aussi l'expérience
pour nous
et si on pouvait l'avoir communément ça
serait bien d'avoir cette expérience
pour nous un index ne fait pas les
changements que la société doit opérer
donc ça a été vrai pour l'égalité
salariale homme-femme il faut que ça
soit pareil pour les seniors c'est pour
ça tout le bon sens de cette de cette
renvoi en la motion en commission et
puis tout le travail d'amendement de
l'ensemble des parlementaires que nous
sommes merci merci il n'y a pas d'autre
groupes qui ont demandé la parole donc
nous allons passer au vote sur cette
notion de renvoi donc qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
elle n'est pas adoptée
donc nous allons attaquer la discussion
et les paroles sur article à propos de
l'article 2 et donc je vais d'abord
donner la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci puisque nous abordons là le
cœur de la réforme est notamment
l'emploi l'emploi des des seniors on
voit bien compte tenu de
la longévité qui de plus en plus et tant
mieux fait que nous vivons plus
longtemps il nous faut revoir sur le
plan sociétal la prise en compte des
seniors et on a une tranche de vie une
tranche de vie intermédiaire que jusqu'à
sur laquelle jusqu'à présent nous
n'avons pas légiférer entre la fin d'une
carrière active et le début d'une
sédentarité et cette sédimentarité dure
de plus en plus longtemps donc il faut
la préparer c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons toujours dit qu'il
manquait un volet de prise en compte de
l'employabilité des seniors et qu'il ait
été plus judicieux de prendre en compte
cette tranche de vie avant de passer à
un projet définitif de retraite c'est ce
qui nous a animé à travers nos
réflexions pour vous faire des
propositions d'ailleurs ça a déjà été
pris en compte par des gouvernements
précédents puisque nous sommes face à
une augmentation de la durée nécessaire
de cotisations 43 ans qui a été voté il
y a quelques années sous le gouvernement
Hollande et qui fait que on est amené
effectivement à travailler beaucoup plus
longtemps donc il faut prendre en compte
ceux qui peuvent être
usés à travers cette longévité que l'on
admet bien volontiers dans l'emploi
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous a
semblé important de bâtir dès à présent
bien que ce soit une loi retraite une
politique vis-à-vis de l'emploi des
seniors qu'on pourrait appeler monsieur
le ministre
un seigneur une solution il y avait le
plan un jeune une solution car monqué
marqué une ambition justement de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une une dimension
collective pour la prise en compte des
emplois des jeunes et bien là nous
souhaitons une dimension collective pour
la prise en compte des seniors trois
volets il y a les seigneurs qui sont au
chômage les seigneurs qui sont en emploi
et puis ceux qui voudraient un peu une
période transitoire en ce qui concerne
les seniors au chômage nous proposons un
nouveau CDI le CDI senior nous aurons
l'occasion d'un article un article
suivant d'en parler en ce qui concerne
les seniors en emploi nous proposons des
dispositifs qui permettent à la fois
d'être plus généreux sur les pensions
notamment pour ces maires de familles
dont vous nous avez dit toutes les
difficultés rencontrées autour de leur
carrière c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous proposons une surcote et nous
proposons aussi d'autres dispositifs la
retraite progressive des 60 ans et puis
également que le temps partiel dans le
cadre du C2P qui donne cette possibilité
nous le réservions pour la fin de
carrière de façon à aménager prendre en
compte les difficultés des seniors et
pour que l'on du côté des employeurs il
y a aussi une certaine attractivité et
bien nous avons
développé les positions de mutualisation
de la prise en compte sur les
cotisations ATMP pour que ce soit pas le
dernier employeur qui paye la note pour
l'usure de notre salarié qui aurait
connu différentes
emplois et d'autre part nous avons pensé
qu'il fallait dissuader cette rupture
conventionnelle de deux trois ans avant
le départ à la retraite qui est un
consensus social où tout le monde s'y
retrouve ma foi le salarié on lui dit
voilà peut y avoir une fin de carrière
en passant par la case chômage avant la
retraite et puis l'employeur qui y voit
effectivement quelques indemnités sans
qu'il y ait une taxation suffisante donc
nous avons souhaité augmenter la
taxation 30% de la rupture
conventionnelle ça ne réflexion
d'ailleurs qui qui venait de l'Assemblée
nationale qui nous a
qui nous a paru pertinente voilà un
petit peu le dispositif qui va être
décliné lors des différents articles en
ce qui concerne l'index aussi Niort
l'index le Seigneur s'est effectivement
quelque chose je dois vous le dire je
suis pas un grand fan de l'index au
senior il s'agit de faire une une
photographie a publié un certain moment
ça veut dire que une entreprise qui a
beaucoup de seniors c'est pas pour
autant qu'elle aime les seniors c'est
parce que au fil du temps il en est
ainsi et elle a des seniors elle aura un
très bon index puis quand il s'a pas de
remplacer ces personnes on va embaucher
des jeunes l'index va se dégrader à
contrario une entreprise qui a beaucoup
de jeunes parce que c'est une entreprise
de technologie de biotechnologie madame
la Présidente et bien ces entreprises là
elles ont que des jeunes pourquoi parce
que les compétences ne sont pas
retrouvées forcément à travers des
seniors sont plus volontiers des
compétences plus récentes et qu'il n'y a
que des jeunes qu'il les possèdent donc
elle va avoir un mauvais index senior
néanmoins néanmoins nous avons convenu
que il fallait effectivement lancer ce
plan senior et convaincre les
entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons accepté de reprendre
ce dispositif index senior mais en le
mettant à 300 salariés et non pas des 50
salariés pourquoi parce que 300 salariés
c'est le seuil où il y a ces discussions
au niveau de l'entreprise pour la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
c'est là que l'on peut définir une
politique des seniors et faire en sorte
qu'elle soit clairement déclinée pour
être éventuellement reprises dans le
cadre des index voilà ce qui nous a
animé dans notre réflexion et que je
souhaitais vous présenter
bien merci monsieur le rapporteur donc
nous allons passer aux paroles sur
article puis nous examinerons d'abord
tous les amendements de suppression puis
ensuite le reste des amendements sur cet
article 2 donc les paroles sur article
et je passe tout de suite la parole à
Cathy
monsieur le Président nous n'avons pas
proposé de supprimer cet article
bienvenue que l'index des seniors tels
qui nous est proposé est à l'heure c'est
une facétie du gouvernement pour faire
croire que vous parlez du travail et du
cyanais des seniors nous aurions voté
plutôt contre deux fois qu'une mais
voyez-vous nous avions l'espoir d'en
faire un outil réellement contraignant
au service de l'emploi des seniors nous
proposions une réécriture intégrale de
cet article cet amendement est
irrecevable écoutez le motif c'est assez
drôle cet amendement qui concerne le
droit du travail et l'emploi des seniors
et ne prévoit pas d'affectation de la
pénibilité à la sécurité sociale n'a pas
d'effet sur les recettes des régimes
obligatoires de base de la sécurité pour
2023 il est donc irrecevable en
application de l'article L au
111-3-12 du code de la sécurité sociale
donc nous créons
nous créons une
pénalité financière de 10% des
rémunérations et gains pour les
entreprises de plus de 5000 salariés qui
ne respectent pas les critères de
l'index que nous fixons nous ajoutons
des
pénabilisés moins importantes pour les
entreprises moins avec moins de salariés
nous en faisons un véritable outil au
service des seniors dont l'impact
budgétaire je veux vous dire que c'était
autre chose que la maigre sanction
facultative si enfin peut-être les
entreprises ne daignent même pas publier
le fameux index senior et ça aurait été
une incidence financière si c'est même
entreprise ne le respectent pas c'est le
régime 0 sanction il est impératif d'en
faire un outil au service des
entreprises incitatives nous reviendrons
sur le dévoiement du sens de ce terme
dans le débat public pardonnez-moi mais
le Conseil d'État dont nous attendons
toujours la note qui vous a été
transmise monsieur Savary et que vous
allez vous faire un plaisir de nous
remettre disez l'index Seigneur était un
cavalier social quand sans incidence
budgétaire
merci Madame pour ce poly la parole est
à notre collègue Monique Lubin
cet article va nous permettre
un débat sur
l'index emploi des seniors mais avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet il faut
parler de la forme mais il faut parler
du fond
sur la forme
sur la forme le gouvernement s'est
pertinemment que dans une loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale rectificative on
ne peut pas parler d'autre chose que de
mesures budgétaires et donc on ne peut
pas
valablement discuter de la situation des
seniors et surtout mettre en place de
véritables mesures en faveur des seniors
ce qui est proposé
dans cette dans cet article relève du
gadget et encore le mot est modéré
sur le fond le gouvernement
ignore-t-il la situation des 10 seniors
alors on va en discuter on aura le temps
Seigneur c'est à quel âge 50 ans 55 ans
pour certaines entreprises c'est même 45
ans mais allez on va dire que la
situation écrite à partir de 55 ans et
très tendu à partir de 50 ans donc
gouvernement
ignore-t-il cela le gouvernement
s'est-il que de très nombreux seniors
après 55 ans ne retrouve pas d'emploi et
se retrouve après une vie de labeur dans
la spirale du chômage des fins de droit
des minima sociaux et attend la retraite
avec impatience pour pouvoir enfin avoir
une un revenu qui leur assure un minimum
de dignité et ça n'est certainement pas
à travers de ce projet de loi que les
choses vont s'améliorer alors nous nous
proposerons la suppression non pas je
vais terminer Monsieur le Président que
nous n'ayons pas confiance aux
rapporteur parce que je le dis je le
connais la volonté du rapporteur de
traiter ces sujets là et son attachement
à ces sujets là mais nous ne pouvons pas
cautionner ce que le gouvernement nous
propose
madame Lubin et la parole est à notre
collègue Fabien gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Richard collègue pour ma part
je considère que l'index est aussi utile
qu'un numéro vert pour lutter contre la
canicule l'été dernier c'est à dire nul
et non avenu
d'ailleurs
cette index il la redit mon collègue
Pascal ça vole Delhi il sera pas
contraignant
on ne sait pas ce qu'il y aura parce
qu'il y aura par décret seulement
peut-être le nombre de seniors dans
l'entreprise et sur les questions de
formation même l'index
d'égalité salariale femme homme qui est
déjà pas assez contraignant il propose
qui est quand même une sanction si des
mesures correctives ne sont pas faits là
vous allez même pas vers là seul les
entreprises
qui ne l'auront pas publié se verront
infligés une amende qui sera évidemment
extrêmement faible moi je pense qu'on
devrait se poser deux questions la
première c'est comment conserver les
seniors au-delà de 55 ans en âge de
partir à l'entraide qui sont au travail
parce que plus de 40 % n'atteint déjà
pas les 62 ans et les entreprises
au-delà de 55 ans les pousses dehors
donc quelle mesure concrète vous nous
proposez pour conserver des seniors
au travail il va falloir bien qu'on
débattre de ça parce que c'est pas
l'index qui poussera les entreprises à
les conserver puis la deuxième c'est un
chiffre c'est l'adresse qui nous le
donne
1,4 millions de personnes
âgées de 53 69 ans ne perçoivent ni
pension de retraite ni revenus
d'activité oui c'est dans l'humanité
spéciale retraite
un très bon numéro d'ailleurs si vous
l'avez pas vous pouvez le prendre là et
là le recul de 62 à 64 ans
n'agira pas sur ces 1,4 millions ces
personnes là continueront à être sans
ressource et sans emploi donc qu'est-ce
que concrètement vous allez faire sur
ces questions là je vous remercie merci
Monsieur la parole à la présidente
Eliane assassin
oui merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
lors de la discussion générale vous avez
affirmé que cette réforme allait
mécaniquement augmenter le taux d'emploi
des personnes en fin de carrière alors
pourtant France stratégie et j'ai les
documents ici France stratégie nous
rappelle que je cite l'effet des règles
du système de retraite sur l'emploi des
seniors et loin d'être mécanique même
des règles coercitifs tels que le
relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits se heurte à l'hétérogénéité des
situations de fin de carrière fin de
citation
l'index seniors ne permettra pas et nous
le savons tous de remédier aux
représentations négatives qui sont liées
à l'âge l'âge constitue je dirais avec
le sexe avec les origines des individus
parmi les premiers motifs déclarés des
expériences de discrimination liées au
travail
l'autre fait que vous n'y est c'est
quand même assez important c'est l'état
de santé toujours selon France stratégie
plus de la moitié des personnes
prématurément sorties de l'emploi impute
leur décision à des problèmes de santé
un chiffre à prendre je crois 13 au
sérieux dans un contexte de quasi
stagnation de l'espérance de vie sans
incapacité à 50 ans depuis le début des
années 2000 concrètement la taxe senior
ne remettra pas en cause des pratiques
délétères par exemple ce qu'on appelle
le harcèlement moral démissionnaire qui
consiste à dégrader les conditions de
travail d'un salarié pour provoquer son
départ à moindre coût la mise au placard
dans les entreprises concernerait 200
000 salariés écouteraient écoutez-moi
bien 10 milliards d'euros par an bref
vous avez la prétention je vous cite de
poser les bases d'une nouvelle société
du travail rien de moins mais je crois
que c'est surtout une société du travail
qui ressemble plus à un grand retour en
arrière plus qu'à une véritable
nouveauté
merci notre collègue maintenant Laurence
Cohen
oui merci monsieur le président
confirmant largement les éléments qui
sont fournis par le démographe Hervé Le
Bras avec la survenue de la période
covid l'espérance de vie dans notre pays
aurait tendance à stagner voir à
décliner c'est ce que nous indique le
bilan démographique 2023 récemment
publiée par les services de l'INSEE en
2022 667 000 personnes sont décédées en
France soit 5000 de plus qu'en 2021 ce
nombre élevé de décès est dû au
vieillissement de la population mais
aussi alors conditions de vie et de
travail le changement climatique y est
aussi pour quelque chose avec des
périodes de canicule qui comme chacun et
chacune le sait ont une incidence et des
conséquences sur les corps des
travailleurs
âgés
seule une retraite anticipée pour toutes
et tous serait une solution on est en
2023 mes chers collègues on pourrait
s'appuyer sur les formidables progrès
technologiques informatiques et donc
travailler beaucoup moins longtemps d'où
l'absurdité de votre réforme allongez la
vie active sans prendre en compte les
conditions effectives de l'emploi et
source de beaucoup beaucoup de
souffrance et de peu d'efficacité
économique puisque vous faites primer
l'équilibre comptable et financier
fallacieux pour justifier votre réforme
et non le bien-être de chacune et chacun
vous faites fausse route la Cour des
comptes souligne une croissance notable
des dépenses pour le risque maladie dans
les années qui ont suivi le passage de
60 à 62 ans le coût des indemnités
journalières liées à l'absence pour
maladie à augmenter en moyenne chaque
année de 4,2 en jeu financier pour les
organismes publics mais aussi pour les
entreprises qui doivent pallier les
absences plus fréquentes de salariés
alors évidemment pour faire passer la
pilule si j'ose m'exprimer de manière
familière vous sortez cette index et
comme mes collègues l'ont dit avant moi
c'est un index qui est en vérité un
écran de fumée parce qu'il n'y a aucune
contrainte la seule contrainte qui est
demandé aux entreprises c'est la
publication on voit bien que vous êtes
extrêmement loin des enjeux et que c'est
un recul terrible que votre réforme pour
la plupart des salariés si chers
collègues et la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Raymond Poncet Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors
l'article dont nous allons discuter ici
et le premier d'une maigre série
d'atténuation de la brutalité de cette
réforme je rappelle que ça concerne 3
milliards seulement sur 18 milliards de
gains enfin ou plutôt ici une prétendue
contrepartie demandée aux employés
contrepartie sans sans contrainte bien
sûr car il n'est pas question de
sanctionner le comportement des
employeurs qui est pourtant à l'origine
et le principal responsable de
l'effondrement du taux d'emploi des 60
ans à travers cette index le
gouvernement en fait fait le lien
effectivement avec les effets délétères
de son projet de loi pour tous les
seniors et notamment du sas de précarité
de pauvreté qui va s'allonger je
rappelle que à 61 ans plus d'un tiers
des femmes ne sont ni en emploi ni en
retraite plus d'un tiers elles sont sur
représentées par rapport aux hommes
effectivement c'est une loi contre les
femmes nous y reviendrons le 8 mars
prochain donc ces personnes ne vont pas
retrouver un emploi on le sait entre 61
et 64 et ils iront grossir justement les
rangs est mis en poids ni en retraite
c'est index a pu par ailleurs sur des
prémices non documentées celui que le
taux d'emploi des seniors serait faible
comparativement à d'autres pays
européens mais c'est normal nous avons
nous partons à la retraite à 62 ans je
le rappelle nous nous souhaiterions 60
chez les écologistes donc du coup c'est
pas étonnant que les statistiques de
restaat en s'appuyant sur la tranche
d'âge des 55 64 ans trouve que sur la
tranche à partir de 60 nous n'avons pas
un bon taupe comparatif
c'est important parce que on y reviendra
dans les sur le plan
national ou là notre âge qu'on
conjoncturel n'est pas si mauvais que ça
donc c'est l'effet essentiellement du
comportement des employeurs à partir de
60 ans d'ailleurs sous l'effet des
ruptures conventionnelles que vous avez
voulu et qui est dû effectivement
souvent à des mises en placard
merci
la parole à Marie-Noël linman
indice des seniors ou pas
la réalité il y a pas besoin d'attendre
l'indice des seniors
c'est que c'est l'allongement pourra
vous voir partir en retraite à 64 ans va
augmenter considérablement la précarité
des seniors est le nombre est le grand
nombre d'entre eux qu'on appelle en zone
grise c'est à dire qu'ils sont ni en
emploi ni en retraite
premièrement il faut se rappeler que le
départ réel en retraite aujourd'hui déjà
deux ans avant la date légale de départ
en retraite
et par ailleurs il faut savoir que dès à
présent la zone grise des salariés
seniors qui sont mis en employés en
retraite et considérable
16,7% des personnes de 62 ans en 2021
était dans cette zone
3% étaient au chômage
13,7 en acné une activité ou au RSA
si la réforme de 2010 ce que nous dit en
allongeant la durée de pour pouvoir
passer légalement en retraite ça va
inciter ça va allonger et améliorer
l'emploi du seniors alors on a déjà le
bilan de la réforme de 2010
la réforme 2010 qui a fixé à 62 ans le
départ n'a fait gagner que 20 points
d'activité pour le Seigneur 20 points et
par contre à augmenter considérablement
la fameuse zone grise des salariés en
question
ça n'a pas été une amélioration de
l'emploi du seniors ça a été une
détérioration de la situation massive
des seniors qui sont dans cette zone
grise évidemment c'est très inégalitaire
c'est très inégalitaire parce que le
nombre d'ouvriers en zone grise a
pendant ce temps là lui augmentait de
16%
et en 2019 à 61 ans il y a plus de
seniors qui sont dans la zone grise que
de seniors qui sont en emploi
c'est donc on voit bien qu'on est en
train de changer structurellement les
dernières années de la vie des seniors
avant d'avoir droit à la retraite alors
on aura le temps de poursuivre
l'argumentaire mais l'indicegnera à côté
de tout ça mais évidemment absolument
l'impuissance merci la parole à notre
collègue Daniel Bruyer merci monsieur le
Président une fois de plus je vais
revenir sur ce véhicule législatif
choisi qui est proprement scandaleux et
dont je regrette que les protestations
dans la majorité sénatoriale sur ce
véhicule ne soit pas plus nombreuse nous
allons donc discuter d'un indice d'un
index senior dont l'avis du Conseil
d'État que nous n'avons pas dit qu'il
est manifestement inconstitutionnel moi
je fais une totale confiance aux
rapporteur Savary qui sur ce sujet a un
désir de travailler et d'amélioration de
la situation je suis surpris parfois par
les propos puisqu'il dit nous avons
accepté comme si au fond la loi avait
été dilée et déjà négocié avant de venir
dans l'hémicycle mais je suis certain
que c'est exactement le genre de sujet
qui mérite un débat dans notre assemblée
et qui mérite de trouver des solutions
parce que garder l'expertise des seniors
dans l'entreprise est un enjeu pour
notre pays et parce que garder des
conditions de rémunération d'emplois de
qualité de travail et de santé au
travail est un enjeu pour tous les
salariés concernés donc voilà un beau
sujet manque de chance nous sommes dans
un projet de loi rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale et donc ce débat qui
mériterait d'être mené nous allons le
mener à partir de cet article 2 mais
vous avez évacué les amendements que qui
a très bien présenté Cathy a pourchaud
notre collègue et qui traitait justement
de cette question des seniors au travail
avec une vision alternative c'est dire à
quel point le détournement de procédure
auquel vous vous livrez malmène la
possibilité d'un véritable débat sur le
fond du travail et je le redis ça n'est
pas acceptable enfin puisqu'il me reste
plus que trois secondes et que je veux
pas dépasser je vais vous dire que cet
indique senior ça a été dit par d'autres
il y a déjà un indice de l'égalité femme
homme qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a 8%
des cas de rémunération entre les femmes
et les sommes mais cet indice senior moi
je vais vous le dire pour moi c'est
l'indique l'indice qu'est 9-3/4 d'Harry
Potter à King Cross il suffit de
traverser le mur vous arrivez et puis
d'un seul coup ça va aller mieux non il
y a beaucoup d'illusions je pense qu'il
faut travailler avec les partenaires
sociaux pour améliorer le travail des
seniors merci chers collègues la parole
à Jean-Yves Leconte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord je
remercie notre rapporteur pour les
explications et l'importance qu'il a
donné au sujet même si je souhaiterais
d'abord lui poser la question de savoir
si selon l'expression de notre collègue
à un million cet article n'est pas un
cavalier social comme tenu de ce qui a
pu être dit sur finalement
la pénalité qui
ne semble pas aller au financement de la
sécurité sociale donc j'aimerais une
précision sur ce sujet il est vrai que
le taux d'emploi des seigneurs plus que
tout autre chose et l'outil le plus
puissant pour essayer de rééquilibrer ou
de mieux financer le système de retraite
et que lorsque l'on constate le faible
taux d'emploi des 55 64 ans qui est bien
plus faible en France que dans le reste
de l'OCDE on voit qu'il y a des marges
de progression importante toutefois il
est vrai et il est particulièrement
inquiétant de constater quand repoussant
de 62 à 6 l'écran là je légale la zone
grise comme l'indiquait Marie-Noël
linman va conduire plus longtemps et
plus de personnes dans une situation de
précarité le nombre de personnes au RSA
le nombre de le chômage les maladies et
les allocations d'invalidité tout cela
certaines estimations les montent après
de 5 milliards d'euros donc plus du
quart des économies entre guillemets
envisagées par la réforme alors Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous donner une
estimation sérieuse de la situation à
taux d'emploi des seniors constants du
coup de ce report de 62 à 64 ans pour
l'ensemble des autres prestations
sociales enfin bien entendu cette
publication c'est juste une publication
c'est à dire que finalement cet article
ne prévoit rien pour répondre aux
problèmes simplement une obligation
d'information qui finalement ne changera
rien s'il n'y a pas d'autres politiques
qui sont développées et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voulais saluer les
l'intervention préalable de notre
rapporteur merci
la parole à Corinne ferait
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en matière
d'emploi des seniors les statistiques
nationales officielles sont là pour un
attester le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans
et seulement de
35,5%. en repoussant de en repoussant de
2 ans l'âge légal de départ en retraite
on va augmenter d'autant la durée de
chômage d'une grande partie des
travailleurs âgés qui sont à la
recherche d'emploi tout en réduisant
encore davantage leurs droits à retraite
quand ils seront en âge du prétendre le
gouvernement se garde bien aussi
d'évoquer les coûts cachés de sa réforme
paramétrique une étude de l'inédit était
publiée cette semaine portant sur les
liens entre assurance chômage et système
de retraite depuis la réforme de 2010
confirme un pic de rupture
conventionnelle trois ans avant l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite se faisant
les dépenses d'indemnisation chômage des
plus de 55 ans ont augmenté de 38%
depuis 2010 et sont passés de 4,8
milliards d'euros au moment de la
Réforme à 6,7 milliards en 2022
des montants qui devraient nous éclairer
sur les stratégies des entreprises pour
se préparer à leur pour se séparer
pardon de leur salarié les plus âgés et
sur l'impact de la prochaine réforme
tentent en recette qu'en dépense dans ce
contexte on voit mal comment créer un
index au senior pour valoriser je cite
les bonnes pratiques en matière d'emploi
des seniors comment donc c'est un Dex
senior pourrait avoir le moindre impact
sans sanction c'est index n'aura aucun
pouvoir de contraintes sur pour les
entreprises au final le seniors sans
emploi non encore à la retraite n'auront
pas d'autre choix que de sonner de se
tourner vers d'autres filets de sécurité
revenus de solidarité active allocations
chômage ou invalidité
merci la parole à Marie Harley de
Carlotti merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues le
gouvernement jure qu'il veut prendre à
bras le corps le problème du chômage des
seniors mais nous constatons une fois de
plus que vous nous faites encore de
fausses promesses monsieur le ministre
la moitié des salariés ont déjà perdu
leur emploi lorsqu'ils prennent leur
retraite sans salaire sans retraite les
conséquences sont désastreuses pour
beaucoup certains sont pris en charge
par d'autres filets de sécurité RSA
location chômage ou invalidité mais pour
tous absolument tous c'est la précarité
face cela à votre réponse est
extrêmement décevante vous proposez de
créer un index senior fin de carrière
pour valoriser les bonnes pratiques une
mesure qui se limite pour les
entreprises à publier des indicateurs
sans prévoir de sanctions mais vous
pensez vraiment monsieur le ministre que
les chefs d'entreprise vont être
sensibles à tout ce qui touche à leur
bonne réputation nous le savons vous
avez reculé sous la pression du Medef
encore en revanche vous restez sourd par
rapport aux manifestants qui tous les
mois vous disent et le 7 encore ça va
être le cas que de votre de retraite ils
n'en veulent pas en fait vous faites un
pari le pari qu'un recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite va augmenter
automatiquement l'emploi des seniors
mais vous le savez il y a un vrai risque
que le prolongement de l'âge légal
provoque justement un pic de rupture de
contrat aucune de vos mesures ne nous
donne satisfaction
et de là je parle encore que des seniors
actifs ceux qui sont encore sur le
marché de l'emploi mais que fait-on des
plus éloignés de l'emploi il serait 1,4
millions d'hommes et de femmes surtout
de femmes d'ailleurs de 53 65 ans à ne
pas avoir suffisamment cotisé pour
pouvoir partir à la retraite et qui
survivent comme ils peuvent en attendant
le taux de pauvreté des seniors n'ayant
ni emploi ni retraite atteint le chiffre
de 32% mais c'est énorme c'est 5 fois
plus que pour les seniors en emploi ou à
la retraite et monsieur le ministre il y
a fort à penser que votre votre réforme
prolonge malheureusement leur calvaire
merci Madame Mélanie Vogel
merci monsieur le Président sur cet
article de tout d'abord moi je vais vous
dire que je ne comprends même pas
pourquoi on discute de l'article 2 pour
deux raisons la première ça a été dit à
de nombreuses reprises ce que l'on sait
dans la presse de la vie du Conseil
d'État c'est qu'il est probablement
anticonstitutionnel et pourquoi parce
que dans un projet de loi rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale va être finance
pour être constitutionnel il faut que
les mesures est un impact financier
direct sur les finances de la sécurité
sociale sur l'année en cours or
apparemment il est fort probable que ça
ne soit pas le cas ce qui veut dire que
ça ne sert à rien puisque si ça servait
à quelque chose on aurait un meilleur
emploi des seigneurs plus de cotisations
sociales et donc ça aurait un impact si
ça n'en a pas c'est bien que cette
mesure ne sert strictement à rien la
deuxième raison c'est que l'article a
été rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale
alors le gouvernement c'est beaucoup
plein de latitude de l'opposition de
l'obstruction qu'on n'avait pas pu voter
discuter de tous les articles et quand
il y a un article qui est voté et qui
les RE jeté
et je passe la parole à Jacques fernik
oui merci monsieur le Président
l'examen de ce cavalier social pardon je
reprends l'examen de cet article sur
l'index senior ça nous apporte une
illustration assez claire de la façon
dont le gouvernement considère la
démocratie parlementaire ce fameux index
a été son nom libre prédestinait mis à
l'index puisque cet article a été rejeté
ça vient d'être dit par les députés et
il sera peut-être sans doute
probablement censurer par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le gouvernement
renvoie cet article devant le Sénat sans
doute pour espérer atténuer si c'était
possible
l'impopularité lourde de cette réforme
brutale en Alsace les adeptes du vélo
ont une expression pour appeler ça ils
appellent ça pédaler dans la choucroute
passez-moi l'expression
alors que que l'unedique estime que le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 60 à 62 ans a entraîné entre 2010 et
22 une hausse de 100 000 bénéficiaires
de l'assurance chômage de plus de 60 ans
le gouvernement s'obstine à vouloir
détériorer encore un peu plus le taux
d'emploi des seniors en France et ne
pouvant plus donc nier que leur réforme
aura logiquement un impact négatif sur
l'emploi du seniors le gouvernement est
prêt à toutes les manœuvres pour tenter
de de cacher les conséquences
catastrophiques de cette réforme et pour
laisser penser qu'ils œuvrent en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors cependant
personne n'est dupe c'est index
obligeant seulement les entreprises à
publier chaque année les indicateurs de
suivi relatifs à l'emploi du seigneurs
dans l'entreprise n'est qu'un écran de
fumée qui n'améliorera en rien l'emploi
du seniors puisqu'il oblige pas les
entreprises à présenter des résultats
satisfaisants alors c'est ça a été dit
inspiré de l'index d'égalité
professionnelle alors que même que
celui-ci n'a pas montré d'impact
particulier dans la lutte contre les
inégalités hommes-femmes comment le
gouvernement hostile exiger des Français
qui travaillent jusqu'à l'âge de 64 ans
alors même que nous savons qu'en 2021
seulement 56% des plus de 55 ans
occupaient un emploi merci la parole à
Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre on a lu ce matin que cette
réforme a été une réforme de gauche
on répond que c'est une réforme qui
résulte d'une initiative du PLFSS de la
majorité sénatoriale pour partir
d'autres pour être tenté de dire que
c'est le en même temps finalement peu
importe ce qu'on recherche c'est
l'intérêt commun et le bien général et
je pense que cette index senior il
participe et nous sommes au groupe Ussé
favorable à cette index senior sur la
question de la forme et du droit le
Conseil d'État rend un avis mais enfin
le Conseil constitutionnel on verra bien
ce qu'il rendra comme comme avis
lui-même il sera bien toujours temps de
voir si c'est un cavalier et donc il est
intéressant d'aborder cette question
parce que l'emploi des seniors et est
indispensable si on veut équilibrer
cette réforme et plus largement le
système de répartition et là il y a du
travail disons-le il y a du travail 57%
des des 55 64 ans sont en emploi dans
notre pays contre 75% en Allemagne et
nous pensons nous que le seuil de 300
est raisonnable pourquoi parce que c'est
à partir de ce seuil que nous abordons
que les entreprises abordent des
questions comme le bilan social mais il
y a une différence mes chers collègues
avec ce que vous venez de dire nous on
désespère pas du tout de l'emploi des
seniors nous pensons que les seniors
peuvent être très utiles dans les années
à venir dans l'entreprise on nous
pensons aussi que cette index senior et
cette question de l'emploi des seniors
c'est une question qui concerne le
paritarisme qui demande du grain à mood
sans nez du grain à moudre à l'image de
ce qui se passe dans le modèle drainant
et enfin on désespère pas non plus à la
différence de ce qu'on entend de la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
sociales et sociétales des entreprises
et des entrepreneurs et c'est tout le
sens de cette index senior je vous
remercie merci la parole est maintenant
à
Monsieur Jacquin
merci bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ce matin j'ai
évoqué le rêve ou plutôt le cauchemar
que j'avais fait d'une flopée de livreur
à vélo de plus de 65 ans qui pédaler
trop doucement et qui vous livrer des
repas froids déclenchant votre courroux
j'ai évoqué cela parce que je souhaitais
parler de la sous-déclaration massive de
leurs revenus un article précédent je
souhaite poursuivre lors de cet article
2 de vous décrire une réalité
contemporaine d'une catégorie de
travailleurs pauvres soumis à une forte
pénibilité et qui gagne très peu vous
conviendrez qu'ils ne sont pas des
fainéants
j'insiste lourdement selon la sociologue
Laetitia d'ablanc spécialiste de la
question il gagne en moyenne beaucoup
moins que le seuil de pauvreté aux
alentours de 590 euros par mois le
revenu pas le seuil de pauvreté le seuil
de pauvreté presque au double par
ailleurs la proportion des travailleurs
irréguliers est en forte croissance sans
que vous ne mettiez monsieur le ministre
les moyens de contrôle nécessaires pour
fixer des limites j'ai eu lors de la
défaite de la Saint-Nicolas à Nancy un
échange avec un groupe de travailleurs
pauvres livreurs à vélo dans un français
tout à fait approximatif en même temps
qu'il parle de leur situation
extrêmement pénible il nous demande de
les laisser travailler parce qu'ils
n'ont véritablement rien donc quand on
parle de faire travailler au-delà d'un
certain âge dans certains métiers sans
prendre en compte véritablement la
pénibilité ce n'est absolument pas
acceptable je vous remercie
merci Monsieur dessus merci monsieur le
Président alors ça a beaucoup de choses
ont été dites mais on attaque vraiment
la partie la plus gadget de ce projet de
loi avec ce cet article 2 sur la
création d'index senior la publication
pour certaines entreprises dans un
certain nombre d'indicateurs relatifs à
l'emploi des salariés les plus âgés mais
alors au-delà de la fragilité les
législative de la présence de cet
article dans ce PLF de la sécurité
sociale c'est un cycle il existe parce
que vous êtes bien conscient que c'est
de votre réforme arrive dans un contexte
extrêmement dur concernant l'emploi des
seniors et vous allez aggraver
évidemment tout ça en recurant l'âge de
62 à 64 ans vous allez voler aux
Français deux ans de vie pour beaucoup
les meilleures années de la retraite
vont être transformées en les pires de
travail pour ceux qui travaillent parce
qu'en fait vous peignez d'ignorer les
informations relatives vous en demandez
aux entreprises mais les données on les
connaît ça a été dit je suis sur plonger
dans les rapports de la DARES ou de
l'adresse 35% des 60 64 ans
occupent un emploi la DARES comptabilise
1,4 millions de chômeurs de plus de 50
ans au dernier trimestre 2022 dans
865000 depuis plus d'un an 20% des
ruptures conventionnelles individuelles
ont concerné les plus de 50 ans en 2020
un tiers des seniors sans emploi ni
retraite vivant sous du seuil de
pauvreté alors votre ex Il va rien
corriger il va juste contraster ce qu'on
constater ce que l'on sait déjà et sans
contrepartie ou contrainte liées à la
publication des données et donc sans
impact sur les Français dans le budget
de la sans impact dans les finances
pardon de la sécurité sociale donc vous
avez déclaré que vous allez peut-être
mettre des dispositifs concernant
l'employabilité des seniors dans un
futur projet de loi sur le travail c'est
pas anodin comme annonce puisque vous
êtes bien conscient de la brutalité de
cette réforme même et de la faiblesse de
vos mesures d'atténuation de cette
brutalité donc vous l'annoncez
d'hypothétique mesure à venir mais alors
n'attendez pas de nous un chèque en
blanc nous combattrons en bloc votre
projet de report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et votre gadget senior
monsieur Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président
on a effectivement un souci quand même
avec cet article puisque comme cela a
été très bien rappelé avec par mes
collègues c'est quand même un article
qui a été rejeté par par l'Assemblée
nationale que vous avez décidé de
représenter devant le Sénat ça montre
quelque part le pet fait que vous faites
vous faites du Parlement
en nous le proposant à nouveau c'est un
irrespect par rapport à l'autre
assemblée mais Paso je vais en 2019
Emmanuel Macron faisait lui-même constat
que les gens avaient du mal à rester en
emploi après l'âge de 55 ans il
déclarait alors je cite on doit d'abord
gagner ce combat avant d'aller expliquer
aux gens mais bons amis allez travailler
plus longtemps voilà des propos frappés
au coin du bon sens le taux d'emploi des
60 64 ans en France est inférieur à la
moyenne européenne deux seniors sur 3
sont au chômage en invalidité ou
bénéficiaire du RSA en plus d'être
socialement insupportable c'est
situation et la première cause du
déséquilibre de notre système de
retraite et au lieu d'améliorer la
situation votre mesure d'âge va aggraver
la précarité des seniors plutôt que
découper les arguments à la limite de la
schizophrénie de ceux qui veulent se
débarrasser des plus de 55 ans tout en
demandant le report de l'âge de légal de
départ en retraite écoutons les manuels
Macron de 2019 écoutons aussi Hervé
Lorenzi titulaire de la chair transition
démographique transition économique de
la fondation du risque il explique
qu'une hausse de 10 points du taux
d'emploi des seniors permettrait au
système retraite d'être à l'équilibre il
faudra évidemment plus que cette index
senior qui est plutôt un cash sexe
senior
scar sans contrainte significative
l'effet sur la réputation de
l'entreprise ne suffira pas à lui faire
changer bien évidemment son approche de
l'emploi des seniors surtout s'il ne
s'adresse qu'aux entreprises de plus de
300 salariés vous citez souvent l'index
de l'égalité professionnelle alors que
justement cela n'a aucun effet en tout
cas sur l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
merci la parole à Madame gréaume
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez bien compris je
suis pas d'accord avec cette index
senior et cela vous vous en doutez car
en plus de tout ce qui a été dit cela va
occasionner de nombreux emplois
précaires mais j'aurais besoin de
connaître à partir de quand on est
senior parce que selon la définition de
l'Insee on est seigneur à partir de 55
64 ans il y a sur le site du
gouvernement c'est CDD seniors à partir
de 57 ans sur cadran poids on est
seigneur à partir de 45 à 50 ans et
selon certaines entreprises on est
seniors à 49,6 oh donc je voudrais bien
connaître vous comprenez monsieur le
ministre c'est important pour la bonne
raison c'est que plus qu'on est âgé plus
qu'on a des accidents notamment ça va
avoir un effet sur l'assurance maladie
vous comprenez bien et je suis sûr que
demain il y aura encore des exonérations
qu'on va donner aux employeurs pour
prendre ces seniors donc on asséchant la
sécurité sociale comment on va pouvoir
payer ses arrêts maladie et notamment
Sarah aussi une répercussion sur toutes
les aides sociales parce que si on a des
personnes qui sont en invalidité il
faudra aussi forcer les rémunérer et
avec la réforme chômage ces personnes
âgées vont aussi arriver à un moment ou
un autre sur le RSA donc je me pose
sincèrement toutes ces questions là et
en plus de celle là des nombreux
critères qu'on n'a pas abordés comme les
critères de salaire les tourneurs qui
risquent d'arriver dans les entreprises
parce que j'ai du mal à voir un senior
qui va travailler à la chaîne chez
Renault par exemple les taux de mobilité
professionnelle en interne et la part
des sonores dans l'embauche et la
formation donc j'espère que j'aurai
réponse à toutes ces questions et
notamment comment on va régler ces
problèmes financiers merci
merci Madame lehouérou
merci monsieur le Président alors vous
avez l'ambition d'améliorer l'emploi des
seniors pour cela vous rendez
obligatoire pour les entreprises la
publication d'indicateurs la publication
d'un index et une faible sanction
associée puisque les entreprises seront
pénalisées uniquement en cas de non
publicité pourquoi les projets de
sanction ont été abandonnés alors qu'il
semble que c'est sanctions étaient
initialement envisagées celle-ci aurait
pu avoir un impact sur les comptes de la
Sécurité sociale et aurait peut-être
justifié la place de cet index à
l'article de du PLFSS rectifie catif
mais c'est un axe n'est pas un totem à
61 ans déjà
61,3% des personnes ne sont plus en
activité à 62 ans
73,6% ne sont plus en activité le
constat nous le faisons déjà pas besoin
d'un index ce que nous voulons c'est une
véritable politique de valorisation du
travail des seniors et dans laquelle les
seniors auraient toutes leurs places
dans l'entreprise
que ce que ces personnes d'un certain
âge donc à 50 ans à 55 ans à 60 ans à 62
ans ne soit pas poussé hors de
l'entreprise en attendant l'âge de
départ que vous repoussez à 64 ans avec
l'obligation mais je dirais surtout
parfois l'humiliation de terminer leur
vie professionnelle au RSA on sait que
l'index égalité famome ne fonctionne pas
et n'est pas à la hauteur de l'Ambigu de
l'ambition pour aboutir à faire changer
les choses à faire que les salaires des
femmes soient à l'égal de ceux des
hommes et qu'elles puissent accéder au
poste de responsabilité la situation des
seniors sur le marché du travail en
France est très mauvaise donc quelle
politique d'emploi des seniors prévoyez
vous
la parole
à David Assouline
merci monsieur le Président je
réfléchissais je me disais je cherchais
un mot pour qualifier cette article là
et puis j'ai trouvé cette citation mars
ou plus 2019 franchement ce serait assez
hypocrite de décaler l'âge légal de
départ en retraite quand on est soi-même
en difficulté
il faut du courage pour arriver à 62 ans
Emmanuel Macron donc lui il dit
hypocrite c'est l'article hypocrite dans
l'hypocrisie de cette loi parce que vous
le savez l'unique vient de donner une
étude au 1er mars de cette année
qui se penche sur le moment où on est
passé de 60 à 62 ans et
son évaluation c'est que il y a eu 100
000 de
bénéficiaires des allocations
d'indemnisation du chômage en plus 100
000 mécaniquement et si on regarde la
période 2010 aujourd'hui
l'augmentation du chômage des plus de 55
ans a été de 38%. donc ça c'est
la réalité et vous le savez très bien et
le président de la République quand il
disait ça en 2019 savait très bien que
mécaniquement dans un pays où le chômage
des seniors et massifs augmentaient de
deux ans c'est prolonger ce chômage et
bien sûr la croître et et créer une
situation de fragilité parce que là
c'est les bénéficiaires d'indemnisation
chômage mais tous ceux qui sortent des
circuits d'indemnisation à ce moment-là
il y en a beaucoup et ils sont dans une
situation de précarité bien plus grave
bien plus difficile et donc très
franchement venir nous dire parce que
vous avez conscience de ça donc le seul
sujet je le répète de cette loi c'est de
faire de 62 à 64 ans le reste c'est de
l'habillage c'est de l'hypocrisie totale
et je pense que là dessus on le
démontrera à travers les nombreuses
discussions qu'il aura encore sur cet
article
merci
Monsieur Assouline donc nous en avons
terminé avec les prises de parole sur
article et je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président quelques
mois à mon tour sur la question de
l'index senior et au-delà sur la
question de l'emploi des seniors quelle
est l'intention du gouvernement et
quelle est la démarche dans laquelle
nous sommes l'intention du gouvernement
c'est ce que portait le projet de loi
tel qu'initialement proposé devant
l'Assemblée nationale et créer un outil
de mesure de l'implication des
entreprises pour l'emploi des seniors de
faire en sorte que cet outil s'applique
aux entreprises depuis 300 salariés et
de la sortir finalement de deux
conditions ou de deux outils de
contraintes ou d'encouragement premier
outil l'obligation de publicité de
l'index de l'emploi des seniors pour les
entreprises depuis 300 salariés dès 2023
pour les entreprises de plus de 1000
salariés et j'insiste sur le fait que
ces deux 2023 pour les entreprises de
plus de 1000 salariés puisque dans la
mesure où nous avons prévu et que nous
proposons au Parlement d'adopter ces
dispositions que les pénalités versées
par les entreprises qui se soustraient à
cette obligation de publicité soit
versée directement à la caisse nationale
assurance vieilles c'est ce mécanisme
qui a un effet direct sur les comptes
sociaux de l'année 2023 puisque les
entreprises qui se soustraient à cette
obligation de publicité permettront
devront pardon verser une pénalité qui
permettra d'augmenter les cotisations
les recettes de l'assurance vieillesse
dès 2023 nous avons un deuxième outil
que nous avons prévu qui est de
réintégrer la question de l'emploi des
seniors dans les items de négociation
obligatoire tous les trois ans pour les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés au
titre de la gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois et des parcours professionnels
c'est ce que monsieur le rapporteur
Savary a mentionné il y a un instant et
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
nous avions prévu dans le texte initial
que cette obligation de publicité
s'applique aux entreprises depuis 300
salariés puisque l'obligation de
négociation triennale en matière de
gestion des emplois et des parcours
professionnels pour tous les autres
items auxquels nous ajoutons l'item de
l'emploi des seniors concerne les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
toutes ces raisons j'aurai l'occasion
mais j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure si
les amendements de suppression ne sont
pas adoptés mais à l'occasion de
l'examen des autres amendements de
donner un avis de sagesse à l'amendement
de la commission qui est propose de
ramener le seuil d'application de 50 à
300 la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner concernant l'index c'est que
la majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale proposait un amendement qui
prévoyait d'ajouter un troisième outil
d'encouragement ou de contraintes selon
le point de vue que l'on a cet outil
consiste à dire que après avoir rempli
l'index après que les résultats étaient
publiés et au bout de la première
période d'observation puisque dans tous
les index il y a une période
d'observation il y a un durcissement des
conditions pour faire en sorte que les
entreprises qui ayant respecté
l'obligation de publicité ayant de droit
et parfois de manière formelle mais
ayant été contraintes à cette obligation
de négociation tribunal sur l'emploi des
seniors mais n'ayant rien fait ayant
refusé d'agir n'ayant pas amélioré la
situation nous voit rayon laissez la
situation se dégrader soit obligé de
mettre en place un plan d'action
volontaire un plan d'action obligatoire
pardonnez-moi sous peine d'épopée d'une
sanction financière supplémentaire cet
amendement qui est finalement à durcir
et à rendre effectif les résultats de
l'index senior pour les entreprises ne
jouant pas le jeu a été repoussé et dans
la mesure où ces et ceux qui présentant
une position à l'occasion de cette
discussion de l'article celles et ceux
qui nous ont reprochés de ne pas avoir
un outil assez incitatif sont sur les
bancs de la gauche il faut souligner que
l'intégralité des députés de gauche ont
repoussé cet amendement qui prévoyait de
durcir des conditions de mise en oeuvre
et donc de rendre l'index plus efficace
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire et
de nature plus technique mais certains
d'entre vous au travers de leurs
interrogations sur la recevabilité
ont interrogé le gouvernement
directement
sur les effets financiers je l'ai dit
l'absence de publicité et le refus de
cette applications de publicité sera
durable par une sanction dès 2023
affecté directement la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et pour plus de
précision vous me permettrait de
renvoyer à l'annexe 2 dans ces pages 22
et 23 qui précise justement les effets
attendus en la matière je voudrais
profiter de cette occasion du renvoi à
l'annexe pour dire que oui nous sommes
aussi inspirés de l'index en matière
d'égalité professionnelle que cette
index en matière d'égalité
professionnelle dont les résultats pour
la dernière période d'observation on se
rendus public dans la semaine qui vient
présente des particularités et les
premiers résultats dont je dispose font
que ces particularités sont
intéressantes d'abord parce que la note
moyenne et la note est déterminée par
des critères qui n'ont pas évolué et
donc on peut garantir la stabilité de la
méthodologie la note moyenne des
entreprises qui sont assujetti à
l'obligation de publication ne fait que
croître et tant mieux et par ailleurs
nous sommes entrés depuis l'année
dernière dans la période de mise en
oeuvre des pénalités pour les
entreprises qui voient leur mode se
dégrader ou rester substantiellement
inférieur à la moyenne de le secteur son
plusieurs dizaines d'entreprises depuis
1000 salariés qui sont assujettis à
sanction depuis 2022 et 2023 bah a
priori mais j'attends les résultats
consolidés marquez le même mouvement
vous avez certainement vu ou lu que la
première ministre souhaite aussi que
nous puissions regarder si le maintien
durable avec une note inférieure à 75
points ce qui est véritablement le bas
du classement ne pourrait pas être ne
pourrait pas être pardon une condition
ou un motif pour écarter ces entreprises
d'un certain nombre d'appels publics
mais c'est un sujet qui est en cours
d'instruction
sur et pour revenir la question de
l'index et de l'emploi des seniors
peut-être pour élargir le sujet au-delà
du sol index si je me présentais devant
le Sénat en indiquant que la politique
en matière d'emploi des seniors du
gouvernement se réduit se réduit à
l'index ça serait évidemment très
insuffisant c'est une première pierre et
nous voulons aller vite la raison pour
laquelle c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons que défunt 2023 il y est
cette possibilité de sanctionner les
entreprises qui se soustraient à cette
obligation de publicité pourquoi afin
2023 et pas plus tôt si nous sommes dans
l'hypothèse ou la loi est adoptée par le
Parlement tel que nous le proposons
parce que nous devons avoir un peu de
temps pour permettre aux différentes
branches de négocier sur cette index
négocier deux choses la première
concerne les critères les indicateurs
que nous voulons soumettre à négociation
une concertation pardon
interprofessionnelle au titre de
l'article L1 du code du travail et puis
il y a une deuxième chose que nous
devons laisser pour laquelle nous devons
laisser un peu de temps de discussion
c'est que nous avons indiqué notre
volonté que les branches
professionnelles puissent procéder à
quelques adaptations si elles le
souhaitent aux critères de l'index parce
que nous savons que d'une branche à
l'autre le nombre de seniors la
possibilité d'employer des seniors peut
varier et il nous paraît utile de
confier aux branches le soin de négocier
quelques adaptations mais au-delà il
faut évidemment aller plus loin aller
plus loin avec des dispositions qui sont
dans ce texte notamment le fait de
faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive pour les salariés affiliés
au régime général et de l'ouvrir pour
les agents de la fonction publique le
fait mais cela renvoie à une disposition
que nous prendrons par voie
réglementaire si les critères
d'assouplissement
du contre du compte professionnel
prévention sont adoptés le fait que nous
facilitons l'accès au temps partiel pour
les salariés titulaires d'un C2P
actuellement pour bénéficier de trois
mois de temps partiel avant le départ à
la retraite il faut disposer de 10
points nous souhaitons qu'avec 10 points
la période de temps partiel soit portée
de 3 mois à 4 mois et donc ainsi
permettre pour des salariés titulaires
d'un C2P d'avoir accès à plus de temps
partiels pour le même nombre de points
c'est une des pistes de renforcement
nous poursuivons et puis enfin mais cela
a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises je ne
le cite que pour mémoire le fait de
maintenir la plupart de des âges de
départ anticipé tel que nous l'avons
prévu pour les questions liées au
handicap pour les questions liées à
l'amiante permet aussi d'accompagner et
cela un coût en termes de perte de
rendement mais c'est un coût utile
permet d'accompagner la mise en place de
cette politique je sais Monsieur le
Rapporteur parce que vous l'avez dit que
votre commission est plutôt favorable si
j'ai bien entendu cela à deux
dispositions adoptées par l'Assemblée
nationale la première conc la
mutualisation du toit TPMP pour les
salariés plus de 55 ans puisque nous
savons que ça peut être un frein à
l'emploi pour les entreprises que de qui
souhaitent recruter un salarié de plus
de 55 ans en matière de maladie
professionnelle les maladies
professionnelles généralement se
déclenchent après une période
d'exposition et si un chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui recrute un sénior de plus de
55 ans en l'occurrence et que ce
seigneur déclenche une maladie
professionnelle c'est la dernière
entreprise qui a recruté qui connaît la
majoration du taux ATMP le fait de
mutualiser ce taux permet de réduire le
risque si on peut dire lié à l'embauche
d'un seigneur exposé précédemment à des
critères pouvant déclencher une maladie
professionnelle la deuxième disposition
qui est me semble de recueillir votre
approbation et celle qui permet
d'aligner le régime fiscal et social des
ruptures conventionnelles pour celles
qui sont passées avant ou après l'âge
d'ouverture des droits jusqu'à présent
une rupture conventionnelle décidé avant
l'âge d'ouverture des droits avait un
régime fiscal et social à 20% alors
qu'une rupture conventionnelle décidait
après l'âge des droits et dans
l'hypothèse ou le salarié continue
notamment pour atteindre la durée
d'affiliation requise au régime de
retraite et avait un taux de un taux
fiscal et social un régime fiscal et
social de
30%. mettre tout le monde à 30%, c'est
casser cet effet de Ben et c'est éviter
d'encourager à des ruptures
conventionnelles avant l'ouverture des
droits je crois que ça va dans le bon
sens en plus de générer quelques
recettes pour nous permettre de tenir
notre objectif partagé d'équilibre je
sais vous avez enfin travaillé et j'en
terminais par ces deux points sur la
question d'un CDI réservé au Seigneur
dans des conditions particulières et
vous savez monsieur rapporteur notre
volonté de continuer à avancer discuter
avec vous pour faire en sorte que les
effets d'aubaine soient les plus minimes
possibles nous le savons et que ce soit
le plus efficace possible aussi je
terminerai par un dernier point pour
dire que comme je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises ce projet de loi de financement
la sécurité sociale n'est qu'une étape
et nous aurons effectivement un projet
de loi sur le travail l'emploi
l'insertion dans les prochaines semaines
et qui sera présenté à votre assemblée
au cours de l'année 2023 je l'espère
avant l'été 2023
ce projet de loi permettra de porter
d'autres dispositions en matière de
formation pour les seniors c'est un
enjeu aujourd'hui les salariés plus de
50 ans ont un accès à la formation
continue moitié inférieur aux salariés
de moins de 50 ans soit parce que
eux-mêmes considèrent que
l'investissement en temps en énergie et
moins utile soit parce que leur
employeur considère cette investissement
est moins utile nous travaillerons aussi
sur des questions relatives à
l'articulation entre les règles
d'assurance chômage et la reprise
d'emploi nous savons par définition que
reprendre un emploi lorsqu'on est un
locataire d'un minima social et est
toujours une opération gagnante si je
puis dire par contre nous savons aussi
qu'il y a quelques semaines quelques
mois quand on passe d'un système à
l'autre quand on là je ne parle pas des
seniors mais c'est un exemple quand on
assure soi-même la garde de ses enfants
mais que la reprise d'activité impose de
trouver un système de garde le temps de
voix de voir arriver pardon cette
expression les aides à la garde d'enfant
peut créer quelques décalages et
empêcher la reprise d'A un phénomène
qu'on retrouve aussi chez les seniors
parce que souvent des seigneurs qui ont
perdu un emploi
ont lorsqu'il perd cet emploi une
rémunération qui tient quant à la fois
de leurs compétences mais aussi de leur
ancienneté dans l'entreprise et
lorsqu'il trouve une entreprise qui
accepte de les réemployer le chef
d'entreprise accepte évidemment de payer
les compétences mais pas nécessairement
de reprendre à son compte l'ancienneté
qui n'était pas dans son entreprise et
donc il faut qu'on voit comment trouver
des systèmes d'incitation pour les
seniors à la reprise d'emploi tout en
tenant compte de ces différences de
revenus et enfin mais vous l'avez
compris je souligne à plusieurs reprises
la complexité de ce que nous faisons
madame greom a posé la question de de
l'âge à partir duquel on est senior
c'est une des raisons parmi celles que
j'ai évoquées qui nous amène à
privilégier la concertation et notamment
le renvoi de branche parce
qu'effectivement il vous l'avez dit
Madame dans votre intervention là
j'appartiens duquel on est seniors et
est assez variable cela peut être 55 ans
il y a des CDI des CDD pardon à 57 ans
il y a des indices statistiques des 50
ans et je pense qu'il y a même des
secteurs d'activité qui considèrent qu'à
45 ans ce qui me terrorise on est aussi
on est déjà un seigneur et donc nous
préférons renvoyer à cet âge là parce
qu'en réalité dire à partir de quel âge
on est seniors c'est quelque chose qui
est finalement assez différent d'un
secteur à l'autre et parfois même d'une
personne à l'autre raison pour laquelle
vous ne trouverez aucun moment dans le
texte sur l'index des seniors en tout
cas dans ce qui en fait des dispositions
législatives un renvoi explicite à l'âge
pour ne pas gêner et ne pas figer le
débat que nous attendons des branches
professionnelles voilà monsieur le
Président j'irai un peu plus vite je
vous en fais la promesse sur les
explications de vote des explications de
position du gouvernement pardonnez-moi
sur les différents amendements mais je
pensais utile de rappeler l'état
d'esprit qui est le nôtre pour cette
question de l'emploi des seigneurs
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc nous
allons commencer à examiner les
amendements et commencer par 49
amendements de suppression et le premier
de ses amendements est présenté par
Monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues après les
interventions sur article des différents
collègues de gauche mais aussi après
l'intervention du ministre à l'instant
finalement
assez longue et assez précis sur cette
question de l'emploi des seniors je vous
propose le premier amendement de
suppression de l'article et y compris
l'intervention du ministre me renforce
dans la conviction qu'il faut le
supprimer non pas parce que nous
n'aimons pas les gadgets après tout cet
article pourrait ne servir pas rien mais
à pas grand chose et ce n'est pas grave
sauf qu'on ne résout pas un problème
aussi grave que celui des chômages des
chômage des seniors dans notre pays par
un gadget et peut-être que le seul
caractère financier de cette article
enfin
si ce conseil de la note du Conseil
d'État est exact et bien peut-être que
son sol caractère financier c'est que
cet article soit pour solde de tout
compte en matière d'emploi des seniors
or c'est un sujet absolument dramatique
dans notre pays et la réforme des
retraites que vous proposez va bien plus
l'aggraver que vous ne vous ne le dites
dans les différents éléments ces
dernières semaines qui se sont révélées
et qui montrent les approximations les
contre-vérités les erreurs aussi du
gouvernement dans la présentation de sa
réforme et bien il y a l'étude de
lunédique qui indique que votre réforme
pourrait augmenter de 100 000 personnes
le nombre de seniors au chômage dans
notre pays pour quel coût pour les
finances publiques dans leur ensemble
d'ailleurs nous ne le savons pas et pour
combien de difficultés sociales accrues
prolongées aggravé là nous ne le savons
pas non plus et nous aurions évidemment
besoin de le savoir alors nous proposons
cet amendement de suppression de
l'article pour que vous ne puissiez pas
mettre comme ça la charrue avant les
boeufs vous proposez beaucoup de
concertation et beaucoup de reports à la
fin 2023 pour travailler sur l'emploi
des seniors commencez par faire de même
avec votre réforme des retraites
merci Monsieur plan n'est pas là donc je
passe la parole pour l'amendement
suivant madame briquet merci à monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues un monde suppression de
cet article là aussi puisque avec cet
article le gouvernement donc met en
place un index senior fin de carrière
pour valoriser les bonnes pratiques dans
les entreprises pour ce faire il rend
obligatoire pour les entreprises la
publication d'indicateurs
c'est index senior aurait du sens à la
limite s'il s'inscrivait dans une
véritable loi en faveur de l'emploi des
salariés âgés j'ai bien entendu monsieur
le ministre vos propositions tout à
l'heure et nous attendrons bien entendu
cette ces dispositions en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors avec impatience
dans le cas d'une vraie loi travail en
l'espèce un index sans objectif ni
sanction du non-respect de l'objectif
n'aura aucun effet sur les entreprises
qui ont plutôt tendance à pousser les
plus âgées vers la sortie nous le savons
les deux tiers des licenciements et des
plans sociaux sont en effet subis par
ces salariés la situation des seigneurs
sur le marché du travail en France n'est
pas bonne et ce n'est pas un index
senior qui va échanger quoi que ce soit
à ce titre les chiffres de la DARES
parlent de même en 2021 le taux d'emploi
des seniors en France et nettement
inférieur à celui de l'Union européenne
par ailleurs la part de temps partiel
augmente agréablement avec l'âge pour
ceux qui sont en emploi
car pour les autres la réforme des
retraites du gouvernement conjugué à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage va faire
basculer dans la précarité les
demandeurs d'emploi proche de la jungle
légal de départ à la retraite
aujourd'hui fixé à 62 ans ceux-ci vont
voir leur durée d'indemnisation chômage
amputée de 6 mois la seule perspective
sera alors le RSA lui-même conditionné à
15 heures d'activité par semaine il est
sûr qu'à la fin d'une vie de labeur ça
fait rêver
merci cher collègue et la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Corinne
Ferret
merci monsieur le Président mes
collègues Lubin et Savary dans leur
rapport sur l'emploi des seniors publiés
en 2019 indiquée j'ouvre les guillemets
qui n'existe aucun dispositif miracle ni
incitatif ni punitif qui puisse régler à
lui seul à lui seul le problème de
l'emploi des seniors ainsi avec cette
index senior le Gouvernement fixe une
obligation de publication d'indicateurs
aux entreprises et non une obligation de
résultats notre nuance est là elle est
importante cette index senior risque
donc d'être
inefficace dans l'amélioration de
l'emploi des seniors pourtant l'emploi
des seniors est un paramètre clé du
système de retraite sans même toucher à
l'âge de départ une augmentation du taux
d'emploi des 55 64 ans de 10 points
équilibrerait le système des retraites
d'ici à 2032 en tenant compte des 30
milliards d'euros de surcoût compensant
compensés par l'État employeur notamment
pour les fonctionnaires un régime
spéciaux des entreprises publiques à
l'inverse l'adresse a ainsi estimé qu'un
report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite engendrerait un
surcoût pour l'ensemble des prestations
oragement assurance chômage de l'ordre
de 3,6 milliards d'euros soit 30% des
économies recherchées d'ici 2027 par la
réforme du gouvernement d'autres mesures
ont été plus efficaces pour améliorer
l'emploi des seniors mais démonstrations
est faite que cette proposition de
mettre en place une un index n'importe
rien de plus
merci maintenant l'amendement 456
monsieur Fichet oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est une un drôle de
raisonnement ça qu'on dit ben voilà on
va reporter le départ de l'âge à la
retraite à 64 ans donc on met deux ans
de plus de travail au Seigneur en
question et puis on dit aux entreprises
vous allez nous à travers un index nous
donner des indications sur le niveau
d'emploi des des seniors c'est à dire
que on va leur donner une charge
administrative en plus alors qu'elle se
plaignent déjà d'en avoir beaucoup pour
donner des informations qui sommes
toutes de serviront à rien les seniors
qui sont du coup mis à l'index ne sont
pas des feignants je sais pas des gens
qui ne veulent pas aller travailler
c'est des gens qui malheureusement pour
une grande majorité passer 60 ans se
retrouve soit au chômage soit on arrêt
longue maladie soit à la recherche du
travail il leur faut des dispositifs
d'accompagnement qui sont de la
formation professionnelle mais aussi des
offres d'emploi qui chantent à constater
à leur situation d'hommes ou de femmes
de 60 ans ça veut dire que si je prends
un exemple qui me touche de près
l'industrie agroalimentaire en Bretagne
on sait aujourd'hui qu'une personne qui
a travaillé pendant 25 30 ans à la
chaîne et totalement épuisée a souvent
fait l'objet d'ailleurs d'intervention
chirurgicale pour des troubles que l'eau
musculo-squelettique et donc cette
personne là est en difficulté pour
retrouver un travail donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre des mesures
d'accompagnement il faut lui trouver des
postes adaptés et croyez moi elles
seront vraiment très heureuses de
pouvoir s'épanouir dans des nouveaux
dans des nouveaux boulots donc le sens
de cet amendement c'est de dire que
l'index n'est pas signifiant et donc on
demande le retrait de l'article je vous
remercie merci l'amendement 511 monsieur
chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre réforme est injuste et
l'article 2 sera
inefficace pour maintenir les seniors en
emploi jusqu'à 64 ans il suffit de
consulter les études de la DARES et de
l'adresse pour mesurer l'ampleur de
l'enjeu seul 35% des 60 64 ans occupent
un emploi et 20% des 427 000 ruptures
conventionnelles individuelles concerner
les plus de 50 ans en 2020
selon l'adresse
1,4 millions de personnes âgées entre 53
et 69 ans ne perçoivent ni revenus
d'activités ni pension de retraite
prolongée de deux gens l'âge du départ
légal de la retraite sans avoir obtenu
au préalable des résultats tangibles en
matière d'emploi des seniors n'est pas
responsable compte tenu des conséquences
d'une telle mesure cela se traduira par
une aggravation de la précarité des
seniors après avoir épuisé leurs droits
au chômage que vous avez déjà renié
réduit par votre précédent très fort ils
seront poussés vers les minimas sociaux
et devront recourir à d'autres filets de
sécurité en attendant d'accéder à leur
pension de retraite maladie incapacité
préjugés négative des employeurs manque
d'accès à la formation quelles sont les
principales raisons qui expliquent le
faible taux d'emploi des seniors ce
n'est donc pas un index aux modalités
inconnues qui permettra d'y remédier
mais l'instau véritable plan pour les
seniors passant par l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et
l'investissement dans la formation Vous
avez déclaré que les dispositifs
consacrés à l'employabilité des seniors
sera annoncé dans un futur projet de loi
sur le travail n'attendez pas de nous à
chaque en blanc des mesures
hypothétiques et longues à se
concrétiser contre la présente réforme
des retraites qui aura un impact
immédiat sur les individus fragilisant
davantage une tranche en grande
difficulté d'accès à l'emploi
merci Monsieur gilet n'est pas là donc
on passe au 574 madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président je défends
donc comme mes collègues Ann amendement
de suppression et je voudrais simplement
dire au gouvernement et et à la majorité
sénatoriale que ici le problème est pris
à l'envers parce que ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure une étude montre que 10%
d'augmentation de du taux d'emploi des
seniors permettrait de résoudre le
problème financier qui est évoqué par le
gouvernement et donc il lui fallut
présenter d'abord un projet de loi sur
la réforme du travail des seniors avant
de faire cette réforme des retraites le
deuxième point c'est pour répondre aux
répondre aux commentaires en tout cas
une une intervention du ministre tout à
l'heure qui a détaillé de manière très
précise l'ensemble du dispositif et qui
a évoqué le fait que la sanction
financière hypothétique mais néanmoins
prévue par le texte serait reversé à la
caisse et on voit peut-être point de là
une forme d'habileté habileté parce que
de ce fait peut-être le gouvernement
imagine pouvoir contourner la difficulté
de la recevabilité constitutionnelle de
ce dispositif dans un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif et à cela je dis au
ministre et à ceux qui pourraient être
convaincus éventuellement par cet
argument qu'il n'en est rien pourquoi
parce que les sanctions n'arriveraient
qu'après l'échéance d'un an qui
constaterait l'éventuelle non-respect de
la publication du dit du dit papier
ensuite du dis indicateur ensuite
rappeler Michael Zemmour qui a fait une
célébrité depuis qu'il a débusqué la
tartufferie de la pension à 1200 euros
que on peut estimer que la réforme des
retraites augmentera le nombre
d'allocataires des mini-massos sur RSA
et ass de 60 000 le nombre de personnes
au chômage indemnités de 84000 et que de
ce fait on aura environ 150 000 à 200
000 personnes dans le sas de précarité
entre l'emploi et la retraite c'est pour
cela que nous n'en voulons pas et nous
aurons l'occasion de dire pourquoi
est-ce que ce qui est proposé par la
droite du Sénat est encore pire que ce
qui est proposé dans cet article
merci Monsieur renonçais n'est pas là
donc le 673 madame le héros
par cet amendement donc 673 je demande
la suppression de l'article 2
oui c'est ça sans contrainte pour les
entreprises ce dispositif n'aura aucun
impact concret sur l'emploi des seniors
je rappelle à 60 ans près d'une personne
sur trois n'est ni en emploi ni à la
retraite la majorité d'entre elles en
situation d'invalidité de RSA ou de
chômage et donc dans une grande
précarité et insécurité en fin de
carrière selon le ministère du Travail
en 2020 le taux d'emploi des 55 64 ans
était de
53,8% sous la moyenne européenne bien
sûr et très loin de la Suède et de
l'Allemagne qui dépasse les 70 % deux
tiers des licenciements et des plans
sociaux sont subis par ces salariés
seniors alors plutôt que de repousser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
permettons au Seigneur une meilleure
insertion dans l'emploi déjà jusqu'à
l'âge légal aujourd'hui fixé à 62 ans
pour
les politiques
anti-seniors de certaines entreprises
travaillant sur la pénibilité au travail
sur l'amélioration des conditions de
travail or les quatre critères ne
pénibilité qui vous ont que vous avez
supprimés en 2018 explique les
difficultés d'emploi des seniors qui
sont cassés à 50 ans et même avant elle
souffre de troubles musculaires
musculoosquelettiques c'est-à-dire de
douleurs intenses pour avoir travaillé
dans le froid dans des postures pénibles
avec des vibrations mécaniques ou
exposées à des risques chimiques ces
conditions de travail empêchent le
travail proposé par certaines de nos
entreprises employeuses de main d'oeuvre
et notamment je pense aux industries
agroalimentaires qui se trouvent dans
cette situation dans ma région et donc
en l'absence de demande de contrepartie
aux entreprises pour améliorer les
conditions de travail je crains qu'à
l'image de l'index femme homme égalité
famome ce dispositif ne soit ni utile ni
efficace
merci maintenant le 7002 madame
blatrix-contin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendements vise également
à supprimer l'article de qui prévoit la
création d'un index senior en effet la
réforme qui nous est proposée obligerait
à travailler plus longtemps alors même
que les seniors connaissent des
difficultés à trouver un emploi
notamment en particulier dans les
grandes entreprises donc c'est index
senior
vise à valoriser les bonnes pratiques en
imposant dès 2023 c'est un des seniors
aux entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés
puis ensuite de 300 salariés en recul
par rapport à ce qui avait été proposé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est-à-dire
jusqu'à 50 salariés et la seule
obligation finalement c'est de publier
un indicateur avec une sanction quand
même relativement faible en cas de non
publication
objectif de l'index pour être trouver un
intérêt à condition que les entreprises
subissent les conséquences de l'index
dégradé et donc à condition qu'il y ait
une obligation de résultats mais nous
n'y sommes pas et en réalité le
gouvernement a reculé face aux Medef en
refusant d'associer l'index senior à des
sanctions initialement envisagées donc
sans sanction c'est index n'aura aucun
pouvoir de contrainte et aucune
efficacité mes collègues l'ont évoqué un
les chiffres sont parlant à 60% il y a
le tiers des seniors qui sont déjà sans
emploi et au-delà ça se dégrade très
rapidement chaque année supplémentaire
donc cette réforme ne fera qu'allonger
le sas de précarité aura des
conséquences désastreuses pour de
nombreuses personnes qui seront au
chômage puis au RSA et c'est ind ex ne
va pas vraiment améliorer la situation
de l'emploi merci Monsieur Michael
Valley n'est pas là donc je passe la
parole à Monsieur Jacquin pour le 815
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il s'agit de supprimer cet
article en effet l'article 2 instaurant
un index du Seigneur constitue un
véritable cavalier social une relève pas
du financement de la sécurité sociale
mais d'une loi travail en faveur de
l'emploi des salariés âgés le
gouvernement confirme ainsi que cette
réforme des retraites n'aurait jamais dû
passer par un plfssr ce n'est que de la
petite manœuvre politique de surcroît
par une procédure d'urgence dont la
constitutionnalité interroge d'où
l'intérêt de disposer des éléments du
fameux rapport du Conseil d'État en
outre un index sans de jeu sans objectif
ni sanction du non-respect de l'objectif
n'aura aucun effet sur la culture des
entreprises qui considèrent les salariés
de plus de 55 ans voire de plus de 50
ans comme une variable d'ajustement les
deux tiers des licenciements des plans
sociaux sont en effet subis par ces
salariés c'est pourquoi cet amendement
entend de nouveaux supprimer cet article
2 et confirmer ainsi le vote de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a quelques
jours le fait que le gouvernement par le
truchement de la procédure de l'article
47.1 de la Constitution présente ces
articles devant le Sénat est une
nouvelle preuve du pays considération
qu'il donne à la représentation
nationale alors retirer cet article et
c'est très forme et au-delà de cette
hémicycle soyez soyons nombreux mardi
lors des manifestations merci merci
Monsieur Lauzac n'est pas là monsieur
Durand non plus monsieur Lurel non plus
madame Artigalas
plus monsieur Cardon donc je passe la
parole au président rénal pour le 986
[Musique]
mais tout de même
tout de même on peut s'interroger
toujours sur ce qu'on fait quoi cette
index senior ça ressemble vraiment un
cache misère c'est comment dire on se
rend compte que par une réforme purement
financière finalement on répond pas du
tout
à la question que les questions comme
souvent d'ailleurs malheureusement sont
traités dans le mauvais ordre mais ça je
crois que tout le monde dans cette
hémicycle finalement l'a dit on aurait
dû travailler évidemment d'abord sur la
question du travail sur la question
évidemment de comment faire en sorte que
le taux de seniors au travail augmente
c'est d'ailleurs ce que disent de tous
les économistes on peut régler on peut
régler assez facilement la question de
financement de la retraite si on
améliore sensiblement le taux de
travailleurs
âgé bon voilà et bien nous n'y arrivons
pas nous n'arrivons pas à faire les
choses dans le bon ordre et si je
[Musique]
bien la majorité ou demain la majorité
sénatoriale nous proposera elle aussi
des mesures qui auraient bien mieux
trouver leur place dans les années
précédentes
merci
Monsieur Stanzione n'est pas là je passe
la parole à Gisèle journal pour le 1034
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
je suis toujours surprise qu'on aborde
la question du recul de la jelégale de
départ à la retraite sans prendre des
mesures d'envergure pour résoudre
résoudre la question de l'emploi des
seniors
et ce n'est pas la lecture de cet
article 2 qui va donc m'inviter à ne pas
donc m'inscrire donc dans ce cheminement
de pensée ce devrait être pourtant la
clé de voûte d'une réforme ambitieuse
des retraites parce qu'elle répond à
l'urgence sociale du travail et de
l'emploi mais qu'elle répond également
aux enjeux budgétaires qui vous inquiète
tant chers collègues une réforme
ambitieuse passe par des mesures
d'envergure des mesures d'envergure pour
mettre un terme à ce chiffre cruel à 60
61 ans une personne sur quatre est
inactive ou au chômage des mesures
d'envergure pour mettre un terme à cette
injustice car dans ces données les
femmes sont particulièrement sur
représentés des mesures d'envergure pas
à la création d'un index comment
pouvez-vous croire une seule seconde que
la solution passera simplement par la
responsabilisation des entreprises pas
d'obligation pas de sanction rien mais
regardez les études et les chiffres de
monsieur le ministre déjà votre Paris du
retour mécanique à l'emploi il concerne
le plus souvent les seniors les mieux
insérés tels que les cadres ou les
professions intermédiaires ensuite les
répercussions de la réforme de 2010 qui
décalait l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 60 à 62 ans sont terribles ce sont
100 000 locataires supplémentaires
âgés de 60 ans et plus entre 2010 et
2022 alors quelles conséquences pour
l'assurance chômage au total les
dépenses d'indemnisation des plus de 55
ans ont augmenté de 38% depuis 2010 et
comme la réforme de l'assurance chômage
est venue modifier les règles
d'indemnisation des seigneurs des
seniors pardon la seule chose finalement
que vous avez à leur offrir ce n'est pas
le maintien dans l'emploi c'est la
précarité avec pour seul filet de
sécurité le RSA et ce serait là une
réforme de gauche telle que vous
l’affirmiez ce matin votre argumentation
de l'agitation budgétaire
du Nord mais
c'est pour vous dire
mais ça va bien se passer ne vous
énervez pas alors
donc monsieur Houlgate n'est pas là et
je passe la parole à Monsieur Eblé pour
le 11 03
c'est le président Laurent
mes chers collègues l'article 2
instaurant un index 10 senior constitue
bien sûr un cavalier social une relève
pas du financement de la sécurité
sociale mais d'une loi travail en faveur
de l'emploi des salariés âgés
l'affectation des pénalités relatives à
la non production du dit index senior
affectation au financement de
l'équilibre de la branche vieillesse de
la sécurité sociale
outre qu'il soit extrêmement choquant
que plus la loi est respectée moins on
dispose de moyens pour équilibrer une
branche essentielle de notre système de
sécurité sociale c'est quand même un
paradoxe je vous en conviendrez mais
surtout mais surtout en droit il
contrevient gravement au principe
d'universalité budgétaire qui est l'un
des cinq grands principes budgétaires
des finances publiques en France
principe d'annualité principe d'unités
budgétaire principe de spécialités
budgétaire principe de sincérité
budgétaire et donc principe
d'universalité il s'agit d'une règle
fondamentale du droit budgétaire
universalité implique le rassemblement
dans un document unique en une seule
masse de l'ensemble des recettes brutes
sur laquelle doit s'imputer l'ensemble
des dépenses brutes c'est donc un motif
juridique totalement suffisant pour
refuser cet article 2 et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous invite à voter la
suppression de cet article
merci Madame Lubin merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
entendu votre intervention tout à
l'heure et à la fin j'ai entendu que
nous allions débattre prochainement
d'une loi travail
j'ai entendu que vous lanciez quelques
pistes qui peuvent être intéressantes
et notamment des des choses qui ont
existé moi je me souviens nous avons
tous connu une époque où un senior
pouvait reprendre un emploi avec un
complément de d'allocation de Pôle
emploi
des choses voilà des choses
intéressantes qui ont été abandonnées
les pré-êtes progressives qui ont été
abandonnés petit à petit donc tout ça ça
peut franchement être intéressant et bon
moi j'attends cette loi travail en
espérant que il y aura vraiment des
choses que l'on pourra discuter mais la
seule question que j'ai et qui m'amène
effectivement à vouloir supprimer cet
article c'est pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
mis cette loi travail avant la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour allonger la durée de
cotisation enfin ça paraît d'une logique
absolue
et nous sommes quand même un petit peu
inquiets moi je suis toujours beaucoup
d'espoir
dans la parole publique et donc je
compte sur le gouvernement pour que
cette loi travail et du contenu mais
quand je vois ce qui s'est fait sur
l'assurance chômage et le fait que vous
avez trouvé le moyen de réduire et
l'indemnisation des chômeurs de longue
durée âgées de plus de 57 ans je crois
alors qu'on sait très bien un castajola
la possibilité de retrouver un emploi de
manière pérenne et quasiment nulle enfin
il faut se dire les choses alors
aujourd'hui ça se passe un peu mieux
parce que les entreprises manquent de
personnel bref voilà nous avons quand
même quelques doutes sur la sincérité
merci pour le 1212 monsieur meryou
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues n'est pas
Houdini qui veut alors vous dit pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas c'est le
magicien le plus célèbre de l'Histoire
c'était un grand illusionniste et la
création de cette indice senior est
finalement tour de passe-passe un écran
de fumée dans le seul but est de donner
l'illusion que vous vous souciez un
temps soit peu du devenir et de la
situation des salariés seniors qui vont
bâtir du report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite car c'est un fait votre réforme
aux objectifs purement comptables ne
prend pas en compte une triste réalité
on a déjà dit à 60 ans près d'une
personne sur 3 n'est ni en emploi ni à
la retraite la majorité d'entre elles
sont en situation d'invalidité
allocataire du RSA ou du chômage souvent
elles vivent dans la précarité et avec
l'âge rien ne s'avance rien ne s'arrange
puisque à 62 ans c'est plus de 73% des
salariés qui n'existent qui n'exerce
plus d'activité cette réforme constitue
donc un sas de précarité inacceptable
face à cela votre solution un index
senior qui rend obligatoire pour les
entreprises d'une certaine taille la
publication d'indicateurs tel que le
recrutement ou le maintien d'emploi une
véritable révolution quand on sait que
la non publication
n'entraînera pas ou peu de sanctions en
d'autres termes cette situation ne
changera rien car les entreprises ne
seront pas contraintes d'embaucher
davantage de seniors cette mesure est
une preuve de plus que cette réforme
ménage et les entreprises au détriment
des salariés vous cédez en effet à la
loi des marchés vous succombez à la
fascination d'un capitalisme financier
qui broie les femmes et les hommes au
service de l'intérêt les plus cupides
vous confondez valeur travail et
exploitation justice sociale et
servilité face aux grandes actionnaires
à qui vous ne cessez de donner des gages
votre réforme n'est ni juste ni
progressiste
et maintenant le 1242 madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président c'est
l'opacité monsieur le ministre c'est
l'opacité l'index senior c'est une forme
de maltraitance maltraitance
institutionnelle sur les personnes âgées
moi je demande de supprimer cet article
parce que ce n'est pas normal que vous
puissiez proposer de telle mesure au
moment même où on a des absences
d'analyses d'ergonomie dans les
différentes entreprises
les conditions de travail sont de plus
en plus déplorables absence de contrôle
des documents uniques et d'amélioration
des conditions de travail absence du
nombre d'inspecteurs du travail absence
du nombre de médecins du travail défaut
d'évaluation des différents risques dans
les entreprises et concernant la
pénibilité et bien vous en avez réduit
absence de transparence sur les revenus
et les indicateurs de bien-être au
travail alors à cet âge beaucoup de
personnes ne sont pas capacité de
répondre à tout ce que vous vous voulez
leur proposer le nombre de congés de
maladies dans cette tranche d'achat a
été évoquée par d'autres collègues avant
moi et particulièrement en outre-mer
il a urgent de prendre des mesures mais
pour les jeunes pour les jeunes parce
que ce sont les jeunes qui sont chômage
beaucoup de personnes de l'âge que vous
souhaitez mettre au travail et bien sont
déjà cassés ils sont malades sont en
longue maladie alors moi je veux
vraiment qu'on passe du temps mais du
temps pour les jeunes parce qu'ils ont
besoin de travailler il est nécessaire
de supprimer cet Asie qui de revoir
l'ensemble de votre copie merci
Monsieur Montauger pour le 1285 merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues je
dois avouer que l'installation d'un
index senior moi me questionne sur ces
effets bénéfiques réels indéniablement
l'emploi des personnes de plus de 50 et
60 ans est un véritable enjeu de société
mais moi il me semble c'est partager sur
les bandes de mon groupe que cela
devrait faire l'objet d'une loi
ordinaire spécifique
une loi travail sur l'emploi des
salariés depuis de 55 ans ces personnes
ne peuvent être considérées comme la
simple variable d'ajustement de l'index
leur emploi nécessite des mesures à la
hauteur surtout s'ils doivent travailler
dans un de plus donc c'est un traitant
d'abord de sujets comme celui-là un
sujet de société d'une certaine manière
que vous auriez dû construire votre
démarche au bénéfice de tous les
Français là aussi comme sur l'énergie on
met la charrue avant les bœufs voilà on
traite des mesures budgétaires avant de
traiter les questions de fond politique
qui intéresse le contrat social dans son
ensemble c'est tout à fait regrettable
et inefficace merci Monsieur montoger
pour le 1321 madame Préville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Michel collègue d'abord sur la
forme l'article 2 instaurant un index di
seniors ne relève pas du financement de
la sécurité sociale mais d'une loi
travail en faveur de l'emploi des
salariés agis ensuite sur le fond dans
cet article 2 la seule obligation c'est
la publication de chiffre soit le taux
des salariés argés dans une entreprise
et les seules sanctions concerneraient
la non publication de ces chiffres de
ces taux autrement dit il n'y a pas
d'objectif réel ni de levier pour faire
notablement évoluer l'emploi des seniors
cela s'apparente à ce qu'on appelle les
engagements volontaires et on sait très
bien le peu d'efficacité
ces engagements volontaires je voulais
attirer aussi votre attention sur une
donnée les deux tiers des licenciements
sont subis par des salariés de plus de
55 ans voilà une réalité
particulièrement cruelle et rude deux
tiers c'est colossal conséquences 1,
millions de personnes âgées de 53 à 69
ans ne perçoivent ni revenu ni pension
de retraite certains d'ailleurs
ne demanderont même pas le RSA par
dignité voyez-vous tout simplement et ce
qui explique très certainement le non
recours au droit résultat à une
précarité grandissante aggravée par les
nouvelles dispositions de votre réforme
récente de l'indemnisation au chômage
vous n'avez très clairement pas la bonne
solution peut-être faudrait-il commencer
par valoriser toute la richesse
d'expérience de savoir de savoir-faire
de savoir être des seniors oui de
remettre à l'honneur l'expérience tant
de gâchis ont été faits dans la matière
mais nous vivons dans un monde qui place
l'innovation comme valeur cardinale mot
magique qui écrase tout pour améliorer
la situation des seniors il faudrait
penser différemment
merci Monsieur Marie Bourgi monsieur
sueurs ne sont pas là donc je passe au
1441 monsieur Kerrouche
merci monsieur le Président cette
article et l'exemple même de l'article
Potter on sait très bien que cette index
Seigneur n'a aucune raison de figurer
dans le PLFSS et que il relève bien
entendu de la loi ordinaire on sait
aussi que le taux d'emploi en France des
seniors est moins élevé que dans le
reste de l'Europe s'est fait également
avéré
vous avez dans cette loi monsieur le
ministre fait un objectif de publication
avec cet indicateur et absolument pas un
objectif de absolument pas un objectif
de résultat
par ailleurs on sait également que le
seuil qui est retenu n'est pas le bon
parce qu'il ne concerne pas non plus
assez de salariés je vous rappelle par
ailleurs que la création d'un index sur
l'égalité femme homme au sein de
l'entreprise par la loi de 2019 sur
l'avenir professionnel n'a eu aucun
impact sur l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes parce que justement
cet indicateur était lui aussi dépourvu
d'obligation de résultats comment croire
donc une mesure qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans le passé pourrait désormais le
faire par le simple fait de votre
affirmation
pourtant
nous sommes au coeur de cette réforme
puisque on sait très bien que une
augmentation du taux d'activité du taux
d'emploi des 55 64 ans permettrait
justement d'équilibrer l'ensemble du
système mais ce n'est pas ce que vous
recherchez à vrai dire vous êtes
toujours dans la contrainte et non dans
la proposition d'autres mesures sont
possibles d'autres mesures sont
pensables le déplafonnement du compte
personnel de formation des travailleurs
la création d'un droit à rendez-vous
professionnel à 45 ans par exemple pour
prévoir un conseil dans l'évolution
professionnelle un bilan de compétences
la formation continue autant de mesures
que vous n'envisagez pas d'où cet
amendement de suppression
merci Martine Fillol n'est pas là donc
je passe la parole à Joël Bigot pour le
1597 merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet article 2 instaure une obligation de
publication d'un index senior pour les
entreprises de plus de 55 salariés une
nouvelle fois le gouvernement mise sur
la bonne volonté des entreprises les
codes de bonne conduite le name and
shame sont des illusions auxquelles seul
le gouvernement croit encore pour
améliorer la situation des travailleurs
seniors en effet cet article ne prévoit
aucun moyen de contraindre les
entreprises à un seuil minimum d'emploi
des seniors pas même une contrepartie
permettant d'inciter réellement les
employeurs monsieur le ministre vous
vous devez de proposer des mesures
efficaces et non des mesures cosmétiques
alors que vous vous apprêtez à
précariser encore un peu plus cette
catégorie de travailleurs déjà
fragilisés la question est fondamentale
une augmentation de 10 points du taux
d'emploi des seniors augmenterait de
près de milliards les recettes cette
question ne peut être abordée sur un
coin de table sans concertation avec les
syndicats la réflexion doit s'inscrire
dans un prochain dans un projet global
sur le travail enfin cet article comme
d'autres dans votre projet méritent
mieux qu'une procédure accélérée mérite
mieux qu'un raccourci démocratique en
aucun cas cette question ne touche au
financement de la sécurité sociale et
justifie l'utilisation de la procédure
du PLFSS r comme cela déjà été dit par
mes collègues c'est la vie du Conseil
d'État que vous avez choisi d'ignorer ce
sera sans doute la vie du Conseil
constitutionnel monsieur le ministre non
content de détourner une procédure de
rééquilibrage du financement de la
sécurité sociale pour une réforme
d'ampleur vous manifestez votre
désintérêt pour la situation précaire
des travailleurs seniors pour toutes ces
réseaux je vous propose mes chers
collègues de supprimer cette index aussi
inefficient
inefficace
merci maintenant pour le 1627 madame
Poumirol
merci monsieur le Président
l'index senior créé par cet article 2
n'a aucune valeur de contrainte aucune
pénalité financière si l'on ne respecte
pas ce fameux index l'emploi des seniors
et certes insuffisant 53% en France
contre 110% en Allemagne ou en Suède et
si on regarde de près les 60 64 ans
c'est à peine 36% des gens qui sont
employés en reculant l'âge de départ de
60 à 62 ans par la réforme verte de 2010
on a créé 100000 chômeurs de plus quand
sera-t-il en la regardant à 64 ans 90
000 îles d'Arès et si on compte ce que
marie-noëlmann appelle la zone grise
c'est à dire les seniors qui sont au
chômage anald
un invalidité ou au RSA alors le FCE
parle de 300 000 personnes quel sera le
coût social monsieur le ministre
dites-nous le et comment vivront ces
personnes ce qui est encore plus
important le rapport de ludique Paris le
premier mars 2023 montre un pic de
rupture conventionnel quand on approche
de l'âge légal de la retraite l'arme de
la rupture conventionnelle collective a
été parfaitement comprise par les
grandes entreprises qui en font un mode
banal de gestion précarisant les
salariés durcissant les conditions de
travail et sacrifiant la santé et la
sécurité des travailleurs c'est donc un
index inutile qui n'oblige en réalisant
les entreprises tout comme est inutile
l'index de l'égalité homme-femme qui n'a
pas lui non plus de sanctions
financières et qui n'a rien changé
l'index senior ne changera rien non plus
il faut donc supprimer cet article
merci Madame meunier n'est pas là madame
Bonnefoy non plus donc je passe
maintenant la parole à Monsieur locomte
le 1698
je suis le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues un chiffre
un chiffre assez terrible 55% des
Français valides un trimestre l'année de
la liquidation de de leur retraite
alors bien entendu si
ils ne peuvent la liquider que deux ans
après la situation sera encore pire
pourtant
nous n'avons eu aucune réponse monsieur
le ministre aux questions posées sur le
coup
en matière
d'allocations chômage de RSA que cette
situation allait faire peser sur des
personnes qui seront encore plus
précarisées qu'aujourd'hui
des estimations sont de 5 milliards
d'euros à quoi bon faire des prétendus
économiques si c'est pour précariser et
engendrer de telles dépenses enfin nous
avons entendu les arguments de Vincent
et blé et j'aurais souhaité que notre
rapporteur nous dise puisque finalement
allouer à la CNAV le bénéfice des
amendes liés à la non publication de
l'index seniors relève d'une d'un
détournement complet de de de des lois
relatives aux financement de la sécurité
sociale puisque c'est ce qui permet de
prétendre aujourd'hui qu'on peut
l'intégrer dans le dans cette loi alors
parce que ce dispositif
absolument pas efficace parce qu'il n'a
pas sa place dans une loi nous proposons
de supprimer cet article qui n'a aucune
aucune aucune efficacité par rapport au
but poursuivi
merci
monsieur taudéchini je viens de ne sont
pas là le président canner
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
tout à l'heure j'évoquais l'article un
bis en l'appelant article Macron là
c'est plutôt l'amendement ou l'article
en l'occurrence l'article route des yeux
nous sommes finalement face à une
démarche qui est celle je crois que
c'est notre collègue Joël Bigot qui
l'évoquait la démarche d'une même chaîne
c'est-à-dire on nomme les gens et on
crée une honte autour de leur pratique
je vous cache pas que en tant que
ministre de la Ville fin 2016 ou début
2017 je crois j'avais porté cette idée
avec ma collègue mini du travail de
l'époque en disant mais il faut que en
matière de diversité sociale
les entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu
puissent être repérés et mise non pas
l'index son jeu de mots mais mise devant
le responsabilité chers collègues ça n'a
pas marché je le dis ça n'a pas marché
parce que c'est pas comme ça que nous
fonctionnons dans notre pays dans les
pays anglo-saxons ça peut marcher mais
pas dans un pays comme la France
moralité j'ai regardé le l'exposé les
motifs monsieur le ministre notamment la
première phrase les criminifs issus du
texte initial afin de faire de l'emploi
des seniors une priorité des entreprises
le présente article prévoit la création
d'un index senior qui a pour objectif
d'objectiver la place des seigneurs en
entreprise d'assurer la transparence en
matière de gestion des âges et de
valoriser les bonnes pratiques en la
matière très honnêtement
c'est du violon quoi disons-le entre
nous c'est de la bonne intention qui
n'est pas la hauteur de l'enjeu l'emploi
des seigneurs dans notre pays est très
faible trop faible et ce n'est pas votre
index monsieur le ministre qui permettra
de régler la situation
merci la parole à Monsieur Assouline
pour le 1851
oui quel dommage ça a été souligné par
plusieurs de nos collègues quel dommage
parce que c'est un vrai grand sujet qui
est jamais abordé à la hauteur de
l'enjeu de l'enjeu y compris de
prospective parce que là il y a il y a
du débat à voir on est dans une société
où effectivement
l'espérance de vie augmente et de
l'autre côté
le marché du travail rétrécit en classe
d'âge
aujourd'hui les entreprises
à partir de 50 ans considère qu'on est
plus du tout à ces productif puisque
c'est maintenant le seul étalon sur
lequel on fonctionne pour toujours faire
plus de bénéfices quelle que soit les
vies-combois ou
les dégâts que l'on cause sur le plan
social mais c'est un fait c'est pas la
peine je sais bien la droite elle a ses
atavismes mais ouvrez les yeux sur ce
qui est une réalité
or aujourd'hui nous dire qu'un index de
ce type va faire quelque chose alors que
s'il y a un domaine où nous avons essayé
d'avancer parce que il y a des sanctions
à la clé
des personnes en situation de handicap
seulement 30% des entreprises respectent
les obligations de 6% de la masse
salariale dire que malgré le fait que on
peut dire qu'il y a eu des avancées en
termes de conviction de l'opinion en
termes de sanctions malgré cela même pas
un tiers des entreprises respectent et
là on nous ferait croire que parce que
il y aurait une publicité
qui ne sert qu'à justifier effectivement
le fait de d'éviter qu'on dise que c'est
un cavalier mais c'est un cavalier et je
veux redire ici que Monsieur le Ministre
on vous lâchera pas car il n'y a aucune
raison pour la transparence de nos
débats de ne pas nous fournir la note du
Conseil d'État qui dit que c'est un
cavalier il faut conclure merci alors
Monsieur kozic monsieur Joly ne sont pas
là je passe la parole à présidente
rossignol
merci monsieur le Président alors moi
j'aime beaucoup les index je suis pas
une spécialiste de l'emploi des seniors
mais
en ce qui concerne l'emploi des femmes
je j'ai la mode des style de penser que
ça fait quelques années que que je m'y
penche et que je travaille dessus et je
sais que les index c'est ce qui permet
d'objectiver des réalités souvent
invisibles dissimulées ou masquer par
des argusies des explications
relativistes relativisant les données
objectives donc je suis plutôt a priori
favorable à ce qu'on mette des index
partout à chaque fois qu'on peut mesurer
ce qui doit être mesuré parce que ce
n'est pas suffisamment visible pour
autant je ne considère pas que les index
sont un outil de politique publique les
index sont ce sur quoi on va pouvoir
fonder des politiques publiques des
politiques de l'emploi des sanctions ou
éventuellement des incitations or dans
l'index que vous avez choisi il n'y a en
fait que l'index et la publication de
l'index et puis il y a toute beaucoup
est renvoyé au décret
c'est c'est bien normal la Constitution
le veut ainsi mais ça pose quand même
une série de sujets comment va être pris
comment va être appréhendé le temps
partiel des seniors dans la l'index sur
l'emploi des seniors c'est pas de faire
une histoire que pour les femmes on va
pas qualifier exactement l'index égalité
femme homme pour le faire sur l'index
senior c'est d'autres paramètres et en
plus sur l'index égalité femme homme on
connaît les biais et les insuffisances
de l'index comment vous allez croiser
les deux par exemple pour le choix pour
les femmes
seniors on sait qu'il y a une prévalence
du temps partiel est-ce que le dos
partiel des femmes va être considéré
comme étant de l'emploi de seniors et
est-ce qu'on va ainsi renforcer le temps
partiel il y a toute une série
d'interrogations qui auraient mérité si
nous avions eu un projet de loi normale
en fait pas un pfss avec un raccord un
rapprochement une extrémiste de cet
article dans la loi retraite que on
puisse travailler finement pour que
l'index égalité femme homme on en tire
le pardon président excusez-moi j'avais
pas vu je regardais le ministre en
espérant qu'il me regarde et donc j'ai
oublié de regarder le compteur je
reviendrai
merci donc
j'en étasse madame espagnol ne sont pas
là madame ponce
oui merci puisque Laurence Rossignol n'a
pas pu finir ben moi je vais un petit
peu reprendre un petit peu pareil
un index si vous voulez un index et les
indicateurs qu'on va choisir dans
l'index seront pertinents et donc
efficaces que si il le commence par un
diagnostic partagé de ce qui fait les
discriminations on prend les femmes
effectivement quand vous partez de plus
de 20% de discrimination
la pare prise par le temps partiel
souvent subi quelques quelques fois je
mets entre guillemets choisis
effectivement et la première cause de
l'écart la deuxième cause c'est ce sont
les secteurs féminins qui pour des
raisons diverses on y reviendra pour la
pénibilité
sont structurellement moins rémunérés
que les secteurs dit masculins ça
recoupe l'industrie les services et on y
reviendra pour les critères de
pénibilité qui sont des critères
d'industrie et d'hommes
la troisième chose bah oui mais ça c'est
bref la troisième chose c'est la
discrimination pure et c'est la part la
plus petite elle est importante c'est à
peu près 6% si je crois si 7% j'ai pas
mis mon truc
et donc effectivement c'est celle que
traque l'index et quand l'index sera
traité
à travers quand même des choses comme la
promotion l'augmentation individuelle
qui sont il y a pas par exemple la
formation bref alors pour terminer pour
les seniors c'est pareil les seniors si
vous commencez pas par dire
sans des retraités étaient au chômage
avant si vous traitez pas le travail
l'intensification du travail qui les
exclut si vous ne traitez pas les
contraintes de rythme de travail donc si
vous ne changez pas de travail étonnez
compte par exemple qu'ils ont besoin
d'anticipation qu'ils ont besoin de
transmettre qu'ils ont besoin de se
former vous pouvez mettre n'importe quel
index ça changera rien à la réalité de
la discrimination
bien merci donc nous en avons terminé
avec les présentations des amendements
de suppression que je vais soumettre aux
voies y a-t-il des explications pardon
excusez-moi
excusez-moi avis de la commission
d'abord
si monsieur le Président vous m'avez
fait peur j'ai cru qu'après 48
amendements
identique sur lesquels nos collègues ont
pu s'exprimer le rapporteur n'aurait pas
quelques minutes alors consacré en
réponse donc merci de vous être d'avoir
remarqué cela alors oui j'ai remarqué
qu'il y en avait deux trois différents
mais si vous voulez j'en prends un au
hasard et puis je regarde s'il est pas
indique d'accord
bon voilà il y en a un qui est pas
identiques c'est issus de Monsieur
Jacquin
voilà qui est repris d'ailleurs par
quelqu'un d'autre et je l'ai pris en
main pourquoi parce que il parle de
quelque chose d'intéressant puisqu'il
dit que les salariés plus de 55 ans
sont trop souvent une variable
d'ajustement oui nous le constatons et
quand on va décaler là je ça va paraître
les salariés de plus de 55 ans ça va
être après voyez-vous c'est comme ça que
ça se passe c'est dans tous les pays
étrangers ils ont fait partout ils ont
augmenté l'âge partout il y a un emploi
des seniors qui est beaucoup plus
important que chez nous c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous venons prendre des
mesures pour faire en sorte que on
accompagne cette dimension haute qui
fait qu'on travaille plus longtemps et
d'ailleurs vous êtes tellement impatient
de d'appréhender les mesures quand vous
propose à l'article 9 que je vois bien
que vous traduisez votre impatience par
une répétition des amendements il
n'empêche que c'est une théorie qui ne
vous a pas échappé
[Musique]
que nous devions faire vous parlez d'une
menace d'inconstitutionnalité sur cet
article 2 oui oui ça nous a pas échappé
ça n'avait pas échappé à nos
administrateurs on en a parlé bien avant
de lire la note du Conseil
constitutionnel qui reprend du Conseil
d'État excusez-moi merci de suivre du
Conseil d'État qui reprend exactement ce
que nous nous pensions c'est la raison
pour laquelle cet avis est très clair et
mais il y a aucun problème juste sur ce
point
excusez moi laissez-le
je vous ai pas coupé tranquillement
vous m'interpellez vous cassez mon
raisonnement je vous réponds qu'on en
parle plus je vous réponds qu'on a par
le plus il y a un respect la loi ce sont
une ce sont des notes confident les
présidents de commission savent bien ce
que c'est c'est notre confidentielle moi
j'en suis respectueux elles sont à la
disposition de certaines personnes dont
les membres de La Mecque voilà et quand
je suis interpellé par Cathy
elle est membre de la Mecque qu'est-ce
que j'ai dit il y a je ne sais combien
d'heures que j'étais à disposition pour
rencontrer celles et ceux qui membres de
La Mecque parce que la loi est ainsi
faite il y a une confidentialité j'y
peux rien celles et ceux qui souhaitent
voir avec moi cette note que je ne peux
pas vous confier vous confier vous
pouvez prendre contact avec moi et c'est
avec beaucoup
de convivialité que je vous la montrerai
vous devez savoir si vous êtes membre de
la Mecque ou pas quand même d'accord
merci il vous appartiendra il vous
appartiendra en suite de voir comment
vous en parler à vos collègues c'est
ainsi fait c'est ainsi fait de façon à
ce que si vous en êtes d'accord on en
parle plus
d'accord mais vous serez déçu parce que
tout est écrit dans le monde et vous le
savez très bien que vous verrez qu'il y
a rien neuf mais
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît c'est le
rapporteur continué seul et ensuite on
poursuivra la discussion
et donc j'en reviens j'en reviens à la
position de la Commission une fois qu'on
a dit ça nous avions deux solutions
d'accord soit dire salut ce sera un
constitutionnel hop on supprime comme
vous le proposez cet article là mes
chers collègues aurait pu rien sur
l'emploi des seniors vous venez 48 fois
de 48 fois consécutives nous dire que
vous étiez interpellé par rapport à
l'emploi des seniors qui ne figurerait
pas dans cette loi qui aurait dû figurer
dans une loi travail ce que nous disons
les choses sont mis à l'envers
effectivement mais nous récupérons
cette dimension de l'employabilité des
seniors en le remettant dans la loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pas rejeté cet index et puis nous
écoutons nous avons consulté énormément
ça fait vous savez ça fait 4 ans quand
même qu'un certain nombre d'entre nous
se penchent sur l'affaire donc les
partenaires sociaux on les connaît bien
quand même qu'est-ce qu'ils nous ont dit
les partenaires sociaux notamment ceux
de la CFDT nous sommes attachés à
l'index à quelque part on a écouté nous
avons également des partenaires il y a
Olivier Hainaut qui s'est penché Olivier
Hénault m'a dit ah moi je pense que
l'index c'est pas suffisant mais nous
avons écouté nos partenaires pour faire
en sorte plutôt que de rejeter d'un
revers de main prendre en compte c'est
index et trouver une disposition nous
permettant d'inscrire une avancée dans
la prise en compte de l'employabilité
des seniors à travers le CDI senior
qu'on vous proposera tout à l'heure avec
justement une exonération de cotisation
famille pourquoi
cotisations famille pourquoi parce que
c'est dans la dimension d'un plfsr
qu'une exonération d'une cotisation
chômage qui ont été plus judicieuses et
hors PLFSS vous le savez aussi bien que
moi donc on a raccroché cette
disposition pour faire en sorte que le
gouvernement puisse prendre en compte
cette dimension nouvelle qui sera
monsieur le ministre et on se rejoint
dans ce dispositif là à discuter avec
les partenaires sociaux c'est une
avancée une proposition et ensuite les
partenaires sociaux ils veulent ils
veulent s'inscrire dans cette dimension
ils nous l'ont demandé c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avançons dans ce
domaine là et puis un point également
particulier c'est que vous l'avez bien
dit moi nous trouvons inacceptables
inacceptable ces seniors qui se
retrouvent au chômage ce n'est pas une
variable d'ajustement c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut prendre en compte
un certain nombre de difficulté et on
sait que certains peuvent être usés par
le travail c'est la raison pour laquelle
à travers l'article 9 on a une avancée
considérable je ne peux pas entendre
permettez-moi de dire que on a écarté
tous les facteurs de risque en dehors du
ces deux P non dans le C2P il y a 4
facteurs de risque qui ont été retenus
on peut mieux les identifier qui sont
bien pris en compte dans le cadre de la
prévention dans le cadre derrière d'une
d'un travail à temps partiel ou
éventuellement au titre de la réparation
par un agent anticipé de départ à la
retraite mais dans les autres facteurs
notamment les facteurs
ergonomiques il est important de les
prendre en compte il y a une avancée qui
a été faite dans le dispositif puisqu'on
crée un fond spécial donc ils seront
pris en compte et nous avons encore à
faire avancer le dispositif car certes
les âges d'invalidité d'incertitude
d'inaptitude au travail resteront à 60
ans mais par contre je pense que nous
pouvons
commencer et si vous êtes d'accord pour
aller jusqu'à l'article 9 en évitant un
certain nombre de monologues nous
pourrons avancer pour faire en sorte que
l'incapacité permanente puisse être
prise en compte en considération des 60
ans sans attendre 62 ans vous voyez ces
avancées sociales ou les a annoncé les
seniors les attendent me semble-t-il et
nous voulons des garanties monsieur le
ministre on espère nous donnera pour que
ce soit inscrit dans la prochaine loi
sociale voilà comment nous avons
envisagé les choses et nous avons même
poussé encore plus loin puisque il y
avait pas de prise en compte sur les
expositions aux agents chimiques
dangereux que nous réinscrivons dans les
dispositifs pour qu'il y ait à travers
ce qui est proposé la prévention de ces
agents soient mieux pris en compte voilà
ce que je souhaite et vous dire que
notre ambition s'éclaire et ça a été dit
par certains d'entre vous on a besoin de
pris en compte de façon spécifique
l'emploi des jeunes on a besoin de
prendre en compte de façon spécifique
l'emploi des seniors voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire dans le cadre de
cette suppression d'articles pour lequel
vous l'avez compris je donnerai un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
et la vie de monsieur le ministre sur
ces mêmes amendements
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
vie du gouvernement est évidemment
défavorable incisamment de suppression
j'ai promis le bref tout à l'heure je
vais l'être de points cependant d'abord
à écouter monsieur je ne vous ai pas
interrompu quand vous avez partagé avec
nous votre connaissance de l'entreprise
et de l'économie donc laissez-moi aller
au bout de cette explication de la vie
du gouvernement la première chose c'est
que j'ai parfois entendu un certain
nombre de justifications autour de ces
amendements qui me donnait le sentiment
qu'on cherchait toutes les bonnes
raisons de le supprimer je prends un
seul exemple tout à l'heure monsieur
montoger nous dit
mais vous auriez dû vous devriez plutôt
des plafonner les points que l'on peut
obtenir au titre du C2P ça tombe bien
c'est ce que nous faisons donc vous
voterez l'article 9 avec nous vous avez
cité un centre d'action que nous mettons
en œuvre ou sur lesquels nous sommes
engagés comme la rappeler monsieur le
rapporteur donc assumez de vouloir
supprimer un outil qui va accompagner
l'emploi des seniors sont nécessairement
chercher des raisons qui n'en sont pas
ou qui sont différentes de celles que
nous avons mis dans le texte la deuxième
chose c'est vrai que l'Assemblée
nationale a fait le choix et en
particulier parce que un amendement
portant le dispositif à 2-300 à 50
abaissants pardon le seuil de
déclenchement du dispositif de 350
salariés avait été adopté a fait le
choix de rejeter l'article et c'était
pour moi une déception j'ai vu que
c'était pure était partagée puisque le
lendemain de cette suppression votre
commission des affaires sociales
auditionner les organisations syndicales
et Monsieur ricordo qui est secrétaire
national la CFDT
a dit qu'il regrettait la suppression de
l'index a dit qu'il considérait que
quand les seniors ne progressera qu'avec
le dialogue social et qu'en supprimant
l'index l'Assemblée nationale avait pris
le chemin inverse et ils disent ça
notamment parce qu'on renvoie la
définition des critères et la
possibilité de leur adaptation au
dialogue social interprofessionnel pour
le décret de fixation des critères et au
dialogue social de bronches pour
l'adaptation c'est pour ça que nous
avons un index qui renvoie à ce rôle des
partenaires sociaux pour définir les
bons indicateurs et la bonne mise en
oeuvre donc je m'arrête là mais
évidemment pour ces deux raisons
complémentaires en plus de ce que j'ai
dit la vie est défavorable
bien donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
ministre sur ces amendements de
suppression avant de les soumettre aux
voix j'ai des demandes d'explication de
vote madame Carlotti
et oui
président moi je sais sout
on demande donc et je soutiens le
retrait de cet article et même je
soutiens monsieur le ministre le retrait
de votre réforme car vous voyons voyait
bien qu'au fur et à mesure elle n'est
pas aboutie
monsieur Kerrouche
merci monsieur le Président
juste pour répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur à chaque fois on nous parle
des mesures d'âge et notamment des
mesures d'âge dans les autres pays
européens mais vous le savez très bien
et plusieurs études l'ont montré d'abord
faudrait-il pouvoir comparer exactement
les différents systèmes et ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça Bruno pallier la
bien montré ensuite vous comparez aussi
uniquement des âges je vous rappelle par
exemple que au Danemark certes on part à
la retraite plus tard mais pendant 6 ans
on peut avoir ses études payées pour un
étudiant jusqu'à 840 euros par mois et
donc il faut avoir l'ensemble des
éléments de comparaison par ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez un peu agacé
par la répétition des des arguments qui
qui sont les nôtres mais je ne comprends
pas que vous soyez ennuyé je ne
comprends pas que vous ne puissiez voir
la violence que nous sommes en train que
vous êtes en train de vouloir imposer à
une partie de la population et vous
étonnez que justement vis-à-vis de cette
violence nous ne soit nous ne soyons pas
obligés de répéter les mêmes arguments
parce que nous ne discutons pas dans le
vide parce que ces mesures elles vont
avoir des effets et des effets dans les
vies et dans les chair et bien entendu
il faut continuer à marteler ces
arguments pour peut-être enfin que vous
puissiez les accepter les comprendre
monsieur dos
merci monsieur le Président je vous ai
bien écouté monsieur le ministre mais
j'ai aussi écouté toutes les
interventions qui vous ont précédé et ce
qui remonte c'est quand même que c'est
dans le Seigneur c'est le symptôme du
manque d'anticipation voire
d'improvisation de ce texte puisque si
c'est index est dans ce texte c'est
parce que la question de l'emploi des
seniors en réalité est clé dans la
réforme mais pour y répondre vous nous
proposez vous nous proposez que ce
formulaire un formulaire qui serait le
préalable à une politique ambitieuse que
vous nous annoncerez plus tard et dont
nous n'avons pour l'instant aucune piste
concrète et on devrait commencer par
voter cette index et vous faire
confiance pour la suite et on va se
l'avouer c'est compliqué de vous faire
confiance en ce moment monsieur le
ministre après beaucoup d'enfumage mais
c'est encore plus compliqué de vous
faire confiance quand on connaît votre
pudeur lorsqu'il s'agit d'imposer la
moindre mesure aux entreprises on l'a
encore vu récemment avec le panier
anti-inflation et pourtant il va falloir
agir les probabilités de retour à
l'emploi après 50 ans sont très faibles
les Français considèrent qu'avoir plus
de 55 ans et le premier motif de rejet
lors des embauches à compétences en 2021
les testings réalisés par la Dares
montent une personne ayant entre 48 et
55 ans à trois fois moins de chance
d'être appelé pour un entretien qu'un
d'une personne entre 23 et 30 ans selon
la DG trésor la part des chômeurs de
longue durée plus d'un an chez les
chômeurs de plus de 55 ans en 2018 de 60
% et le report de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à 65 ans va donc aggraver
dramatiquement ce sas de précarité des
catégories populaires et le chômage des
seniors votre réforme est donc brutale
et injuste
madame Vogel
merci monsieur le Président
évidemment je vais voter les articles de
suppression de l'article 2 tout d'abord
parce que je crois que comme beaucoup
d'entre nous dans cette assemblée je
suis attachée au respect de la
Constitution et je ne vois pas bien
l'intérêt de voter une mesure quand nous
savons puisque j'ai lu le monde même si
je suis très triste de ne pas avoir pu
lire la vie mais j'ai lu le monde et il
semble que cette cette disposition de la
loi sera censurée donc je comprends pas
bien à quoi ça sert qu'on la vote
surtout au Sénat nous qui sommes
attachés au respect de la Constitution
ensuite parce que je suis aussi attaché
au parlementarisme et à respecter le
choix de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
retiré cet article alors même que la
droite et la majorité présidentielle se
plaignait que les débats n'aient pas pu
avoir lieu et quand ils ont lieu et bien
ça ne les intéresse pas sur le fond
on a eu l'occasion de le dire et j'ai
bien conscience qu'on l'a dit qu'on l'a
dit de nombreuses fois mais néanmoins
c'est vrai
cet article ne va servir à absolument
rien c'est pour ça qu'il est
anticonstitutionnel s'il était
constitutionnel ce serait parce qu'il
aurait un impact sur les finances
publiques cette année et donc il servait
à amener des cotisations sociales par
exemple donc moi ma question c'est aussi
à tous mes collègues qui vont voter
contre ces amendements et donc ils
veulent garder l'index des seniors dans
le texte de loi est-ce qu'ils vont aussi
voter pour tous nos amendements qui
consistent à faire que cette index
servent à quelque chose qui soit associé
à des sanctions qu'ils permettent de
faire quelque chose en réalité qui va
permettre d'avoir un impact positif sur
les finances publiques parce que sinon à
quoi ça sert de voter en faveur d'un
truc qui ne sert absolument à rien et de
rejeter toutes les propositions que vous
allez voir parce que nous sommes quand
même constructifs vous en avons beaucoup
toutes les propos itions qui consistent
à faire que cet article de est un impact
merci Madame poursaut poli
merci monsieur le Président alors tout
d'abord je voulais vraiment remercier
Monsieur Savary parce que vraiment
pouvoir nous permettre de consulter les
notes du Conseil
constitutionnels c'est une avancée
concis des tags c'est une avancée
considérable monsieur Savary depuis on a
perdu beaucoup de temps autour de ça
depuis jeudi nous aurions pu les
consulter
non non non non non c'était secret il
n'y avait que le président de La Mecque
qui pouvait les avoir nous ne pouvions
pas les avoir nous n'avions pas le droit
de les consulter tout à l'heure quand
j'ai causé la présidente de la
commission madame de roche m'a dit
qu'elles étaient secrètes ces notes et
que je ne pouvais pas en disposer si
donc bon en tous les cas il y a une
avancée cons et nous la prenons et nous
sommes contents monsieur Savary et je
vais venir je vais venir je vais venir
monsieur Savary on va passer une petite
nuit ensemble on va regarder les choses
avec les collègues et puis on va
consulter ses notes secrètes qui de
toute façon ne devrait pas l'être de
toute façon
elle ne devrait pas être secrète mais
bon on va venir monsieur Savary ne vous
inquiétez pas on est content alors
évidemment nous allons aussi voter la
suppression de l'article 2 alors si vous
préférez évidemment pas une nuit une
journée peut-être
d'abord parce que il est à cavalier
social et que nous souhaitons pour notre
part ça a été dit une véritable loi
travail la réalité monsieur le ministre
c'est votre gouvernement a une fois de
plus répandue favorablement au MEDEF en
refusant d'associer l'index seniors à
des sanctions financières
aucun pouvoir de contrainte donc aucun
effet voilà la réalité là et donc nous
voterons pour la suppression de
l'article 2 monsieur Moga
non ah pardon je me suis trompé
excusez-moi monsieur Morand
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
reconnaissons que cet article n'est pas
le cœur de cette réforme par contre elle
renvoie ce qui est essentiel cette
notion de travail des seniors il devrait
un problème que nous avons en France par
rapport aux autres pays c'est
effectivement le taux d'activité des
seniors comme des jeunes donc la
question c'est comment on augmente le
taux d'activité en l'occurrence des
seniors qui effectivement sont plus
touchés par le chômage ils souffrent
d'une attitude bien française qu'il
faudra changer et dans le temps qu'il se
trouve les plus souvent et bien mis à la
porte notamment des grandes entreprises
lorsqu'elle dépense sociaux ça c'est une
réalité ça renvoie aux usages au
coutumes et l'État à travers les
entreprises dont l'État a encore des
participations est loin de montrer
l'exemple donc il y aura des choses à
faire donc j'aurais presque plus
reprendre mot pour mot l'intervention du
président rénal tout à l'heure le
problème c'est qu'on a mis encore une
fois les choses à l'envers et Monsieur
le Ministre et Monsieur du socle tout à
l'heure nous disait qu'il y aurait une
loi sur le travail sur l'insertion la
formation mais pourquoi n'avons pas
commencé par cela et bien je regrette
fortement que cette partie de
l'hémicique n'est pas suffisamment fait
pression sur le gouvernement pour que ça
passe d'abord sur le travail et qu'après
on travaille
tranquillement sereinement sur les
retraites parce que mettez-vous à la
place des nombreux personnes qui
travaillent moins les plus grandes
entreprises que les PME les PMI et vous
voyez tout j'imagine dans les tribunaux
de commerce de vos territoires augmenter
et bien les dossiers qui arrivent car il
nous a pas échappé que nous vivons une
période d'inflation une période de des
punir une période d'augmentation des
prix d'énergie que ça retrouve partout
et que nous avons des entreprises qui
vont faire faillite mettez-vous
simplement à la place des travailleurs
travailleuses pour apprendre une
expression un peu plus
âgée au-delà de 55 ans et bien ils
peuvent être légitimement inquiets par
cette réforme donc il faut pas s'étonner
qui est beaucoup de monde dans la rue la
semaine prochaine donc moi j'aurais
vraiment souhaité parce que la fusée de
cette réforme si on met les étages à
l'envers elle n'est pas prête de
décoller donc moi je voterai cet article
et la réforme on verra
monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est toujours à l'envers
un petit texte rectificatif pour une
grande ambition c'est quand même assez
étonnant ce petit texte qui va quand
même permettre à l'administration
française de faire des exploits puisque
les entreprises d'au moins 1000 salariés
devront publier des indicateurs relatifs
à l'emploi des salariés âgés dès le
premier novembre 2023 en France nous
allons aller vite et ils seront
sanctionnés avant le 31 décembre 2023
c'est à cette condition là qu'il
pourrait y avoir des recettes dont les
annexes nous rappellent que compte tenu
de la compatibilité des régimes sécurité
sociale est enregistré en droit constaté
le produit d'une sanction juridiquement
prononcée notifié avant le 31 décembre
2023 sera rattachée à l'exercice 2023
vraiment on malmène les entreprises dans
ce pays en étant aussi sévère on publie
un index obligatoire au 1er novembre et
on les sanctionnera avant le 31 décembre
sérieusement sur le fond de ce propos
monsieur le rapporteur je voudrais vous
dire une chose moi je souhaite
effectivement que nous améliorons les
conditions de travail les conditions de
maintien dans l'emploi de tous les
salariés pas jusqu'à 64 ans pas on a en
allongeant la durée du travail mais
jusqu'à l'âge légal du travail et à
partir de 55 ans ou le taux d'emploi est
très faible mais je ne veux pas le faire
dans un texte qui est un texte dont
l'objectif est de maintenir et de
prolonger de deux années de plus au
travail je souhaite le faire dans une
loi travail débattue et négocier avec
les partenaires sociaux sur cet aspect
là je sais que nous nous rejoignons sur
la volonté qui est débat
madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président il faut une
véritable loi travail votre gouvernement
monsieur le ministre a supprimé les
CHSCT la transparence est donc
nécessaire une vraie loi travail
pourrait nous permettre de mieux
échanger dans cette émission cette
mesure n'aura aucun impact réel dans les
territoires d'outre-mer je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais je vous le répète
dans un contexte d'inflation et de vie
chère il faut de vrais mesures pour
combattre le chômage et améliorer la
qualité de vie l'index senior ne peut en
aucun cas être une vraie solution il
faut une loi complète bien réfléchie
partagez avec les partenaires sociaux
une loi pertinente et bien pensée cet
article doit être supprimé c'est un
cavalier social limité injuste qui ne
propose que des maltraitances envers les
seniors démunis et déjà précaire merci
merci donc nous en avons terminé avec
les explications
madame poncer mon j'ai excusez-moi je ne
vous avais pointu
je voudrais dire à Alain Milon que je
suis sûr qu'il a tout compris mais que
moi en général je réponds aux rapporteur
et au ministre donc c'est forcément
après donc justement vous avez dit
monsieur le ministre que c'est index
c'est très bien vous avez redécouvert le
dialogue social il sera discuté en
interpro et par branche tant mieux et
que les os sont des propositions il y a
pas que la CFDT tout elles ont toutes
des propositions mais puisque souvent la
CFDT est cité je vous rappelle qu'elle
est contre et qu'elle vous demande leur
retrait de cette loi
moi j'ai si vous voulez ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que cette loi
s'applique dès septembre donc elle va
s'appliquer aux gens qui ont entre 58 59
60 61 ans et de façon brutale et
immédiate c'est là où on va faire les
économies qui va vous permettre d'être à
3% 2027 pour pour maestrich alors aussi
à partir de là si vous voulez il est
bien certain mieux que tout ce qu'on va
dire sur l'index n'a pas de d'effet
c'est sur cette population là c'est déjà
trop tard et c'est pourtant elle qui
sont sollicités d'ici 2027 et donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que ben c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure qu'en fait
il faut changer le travail il y a pas
que le taux d'emploi des seniors qui
pose un problème il y a celui des femmes
il y a celui des jeunes il y a celui des
seigneurs il y a celui des personnes en
situation de handicap donc vous voyez
bien que ça vous nous avez promis une
loi cette année l'index aurait pu en
parler cette année non s'il est là c'est
pour vous servir de caution à ceux qui
ont y compris la CFDT refuse
c'est-à-dire l'ouverture le décalage de
l'ouverture des droits à la retraite
monsieur Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Savary vous nous avez dit
dans votre propos mais écoutez les
syndicats qui sont d'accord pour cette
index et d'ailleurs ils sont pas
unanimes sur le sujet mais vous ne les
écoutez pas sur le retrait de la réforme
alors que là pour le coup ils sont
unanime ils se mobilisent constamment
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
là par contre vous ne les écoutez pas
donc c'est vraiment à deux vitesses et
cet article est il ne résoudra pas le
problème de l'emploi des seniors s'il
est pas assorti de la moindre contrainte
tous ces indicateurs ils sont dénués et
vous le savez très bien de la moindre
obligation ils sont complètement bidon
il permet de seulement aux entreprises
qui attribuent les labels de fer du
profit imposent une couche de
bureaucratie supplémentaire à toutes les
autres la vérité c'est que votre réforme
va créer un sas de pauvreté pour les
seniors à 62 ans 40% de ceux qui ne sont
pas la retraite ne travaillent pas par
généreux parmi eux un tiers vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté votre effort qui
file l'axe de départ justement à la
retraite à 64 ans et violente et cruelle
va accentuer cette cette pauvreté
d'après l'Observatoire français de des
conjectures économiques et un
observatoire sérieux elle se traduira
justement par 277 000 chômeurs
supplémentaires 400 000 nouveaux arrêts
de travail pour maladies
professionnelles et 110 000 personnes de
plus au minima sociaux au bout du compte
si vous voulez réellement faire quelque
chose pour les seniors commencez par
faire en sorte d'empêcher qu'il soit
licencié et ensuite lutter contre la
discrimination à l'embauche qu'il
subisse comment faire me demanderez-vous
et bien en leur donnant des droits ainsi
qu'au syndicats afin qu'ils puissent se
défendre
le président rénal
sur un point monsieur président merci
sur un point quand même qui est rappelé
qui est quand même donc c'est tous qu'il
est faux
c'est le rapport entre ce texte et puis
l'année 2023 du point de vue financier
et budgétaire bon c'est tout ce que
c'est faux et si à la limite on voulait
faire un effort en se disant on y croit
un instant il suffirait de se souvenir
de ce qui nous a été expliqué encore une
fois récemment sur la réforme de la CVAE
ou sur la réforme de la c.ae un des
sujets et de dire que si on veut allouer
aux entreprises pardon collectivités ce
qu'elles recevait avant il faut que les
entreprises puissent conserver le juste
comptage de leur salarié et le donner
l'administration et bien on nous a dit à
l'époque que c'était un faisable que les
entreprises on ne pouvait plus de
l'instant ou en supprimer la CVE leur
demander cet effort de juste
comptabiliser leur poste de travail et
le donner à l'administration fiscale
c'était infaisable un truc basicum
basique et là où nous explique qu'on va
appliquer un texte donc qui va
s'appliquer début septembre où on va
demander
aux entreprises l'air de rien de remplir
des fichiers pour le mois fin octobre et
ensuite qu'on va s'il ne se rende pas
s'ils ne font pas les choses on va les
taxer tout ça dans la même année
ça veut rien dire quoi voilà alors on
peut faire semblant de le croire voilà
mais je crois que franchement ici
personne ne peut croire à une à une
telle une telle chose donc effectivement
je pense que il y a du travail pour le
Conseil constitut
je suis insuline
ce moment du débat ayant écouté aussi le
ministre tout à l'heure je une remarque
m'est venue parce que c'est c'est quand
même incroyable
notre démocratie est assez malade
ce matin encore le JDD nous annonce avec
une nouvelle enquête d'opinion que seul
32% des Français sont favorables à cette
réforme et si l'on regarde les moins de
35 ans c'est-à-dire ce qui vont être
plus concernés
64%, et ceux qui ne sont pas concernés à
50%. je sais pas si on se rend compte du
sujet nous sommes ici en train de
discuter d'une réforme dont on sait que
deux tiers des Français la rejettent que
pourrait faire le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs vous aussi à droite de
discuter avec ceux qui sont opposés à la
réforme nous
qui représentons à peu près l'opinion de
deux tiers des Français pour voir
comment on règle dans cet enceinte ce
problème démocratique c'est-à-dire que
le gouvernement devrait être en train de
voir comment dans ce débat il va amender
regarder écouter les arguments discuter
avec nous or ce n'est pas du tout ce qui
se passe même c'est l'inverse qui est en
train de se passer dans cet enceinte la
seule chose qui va être discuté
réellement
entre le gouvernement et la majorité du
Sénat c'est comment la durcir encore
plus c'est-à-dire comment l'éloigner
encore plus des Français qui la
rejettent comment la rendre encore plus
brutale et vous pensez bien que quand on
offre ce spectacle aux Français et bien
on renforce la crise démocratique et on
ne fait le lit que d'une seule force
politique celle qui est contre la
République
bien donc nous en avons terminé cette
fois-ci avec les explications de vote
et je vais donc soumettre aux voies
les amendements de suppression
identiques que nous venons de débattre
avec un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement donc qui
est pour ces amendements de suppression
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
donc l'article 2 étant du coup maintenu
nous allons entrer dans le débat des
amendements visant à améliorer cet
article il y en a 145
donc le premier est présenté par Madame
ponce c'est le 31 65
oui merci monsieur le Président puisque
nous avons l'index nous allons tout
comme le rapporteur essayez de lui
apporter tout le contenu et puis
peut-être que à la fin comme ça on
révisera notre position on sait jamais
donc écoutez bien tout ce qu'on propose
nous pour que ça soit un outil
réellement ambitieux et opérant capable
d'avoir un impact sur l'emploi et sur la
qualité de l'emploi et le travail de la
formation des seniors alors nous avons
rappelé que 63% des salariés âgés de 44
à 55 ans vous voyez c'est même avant les
seniors en recherche d'emploi n'ont pas
été sollicités par des recruteurs au
cours des six derniers mois contre 26%
chez les 18 24 ans de plus la proportion
des 55 64 ans vous l'avez dit
et pas n'est pas satisfaisante qui
occupe un emploi s'élève à 56% moi
j'aimerais bien les statistiques de 60
et 61 et 62 ans donc afin de pallier
divers contournements du dispositif nous
proposons une définition plus claire et
plus précise non seulement du contenu
des négociations vous avez parlé de
dialogue social monsieur le ministre
tant en interpro que en fait que en
branche et que en entreprise en suivant
la hiérarchie des sources qui est quand
même
très très importante ici donc contenu de
l'urgence pour les seniors d'avoir non
seulement un travail décent mais aussi
une fin de carrière digne et pas finir
dans le chômage dans les minimas sociaux
ou
en maladie dans un contexte de menace de
l'âge de dépassement de l'âge de départ
nous proposons l'implication de l'index
débute à partir du 1er mars 20 24 à
l'exception des entreprises depuis de
500 salariés donc vous avez dit qu'elles
ont tout dans le jeu dans le GPEC et qui
pourront commencer donc l'index en
vigueur dès le 1er novembre 2023
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
oui effectivement cet amendement propose
un calendrier différent selon l'état de
l'entreprise puisque actuellement ce
sont celles plus de plus de 1000 qui
doivent au 1er novembre
publié l'index d'ailleurs sur des
indicateurs qui ne sont pas encore
définies puisque il y a pas eu les
négociations de branches mais qui en
attendant pour faire en sorte que le
produit des pénalités puissent
éventuellement être imputés sur
l'exercice 2023 ces modalités de prise
en compte des indicateurs seraient
proposés par décret en attendant en
attendant effectivement cela alors si on
descend à 500 là on est sûr parce que
c'est encore plus compliqué qui n'est
pas effectivement de pénalité qui rentre
en 2023 et puis également vous proposer
vous proposer quoi
une augmentation des pénalités voilà
excusez moi excusez-moi une augmentation
des pénalités voyez-vous les pénalités
qui sont proposées sont quand même
significatives c'est 1% de la masse
salariale sachant que faut véritablement
pour pour qu'elle soit appliquée
vraiment quand même avoir fait preuve
non seulement une mauvaise volonté mais
véritablement en ayant refusé
complètement d'entrer dans le dispositif
on voit bien que quand il y a des
pénalités par exemple sur l'index
homme-femme elles sont pratiquement
jamais arrivées à 1% vous voyez c'est un
petit 0,5 02 03 alors 2 5% imaginez une
entreprise de mauvaise volonté et il me
semble que vous la mettez vraiment en
situation budgétaire difficile et ça va
conduire à licencier des gens je pense
que ce soit pas forcément la bonne
méthode maintenant il faut fixer le bon
niveau alors le gouvernement nous dit 1%
c'est le en général le taux habituel
je pense que cela relève de la
discussion des partenaires sociaux si on
veut faire en sorte qu'il s'empare de
cette dimension sur l'emploi des seniors
faut pas commencer à la remettre un
cadre trop contraint en tout cas moi je
m'y prendrai pas comme ça voyez-vous je
leur donnerai un peu de souplesse pour
pouvoir en sorte que les réellement leur
volonté et là on peut peut-être arriver
à quelque chose il nous définiront
effectivement les pénalités qui
s'imposent c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons donné un avis défavorable
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
mais ma vie donc un double avis
défavorable
il y a pas d'explication de votre je
peux soumettre l'amendement on voit donc
qui est pour
l'amendement
3165 présenté par Madame ponce
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté alors
maintenant nous entrons dans la
discussion de 139 amendements en
discussion commune
donc nous allons commencer par exposer
ses amendements donc le premier le 2613
est présenté par Madame Ferret
merci monsieur le Président donc par cet
amendement nous voulons insister sur la
notion de seniors ou de personnes
âgées de plus de 50/50 comme la très
bien démontré le rapport de Monique
globin et René Paul Savary sur l'emploi
des seniors la première difficulté
consiste à définir ce terme en effet
dans le monde sportif la catégorie
senior regroupe selon les fédérations
les pratiquants âgés de 19 à 40 ans
environ plus âgé que les juniors mais
moi que les vétérans dans certaines
entreprises un cadre ou un consultant
début de sa carrière en tant que Junior
et devient seniors au bout de quelques
années d'expérience la notion de marché
des seniors ou de Silver économie renvoi
davantage aux retraités voire aux
personnes qui commencent à connaître une
perte de leur autonomie dans certains
secteurs professionnels là je vais
partir duquel les salariés sont souvent
envoyés à l'enseignantité et disent
ressentir leur première difficulté dans
les entreprises peut descendre à 45 ans
on le voit bien la définition de la
catégorie salernarien j'ai ou seniors
est un enjeu enjeux que malheureusement
le gouvernement a consciencieusement
évacué c'est pourquoi il convient pour
la bonne intelligibilité à la clarté de
la loi de définir un âge plancher à
partir duquel un actif peut être
considéré comme senior c'est l'objet de
l'amendement que notre groupe a déposé
en le fixant à 55 ans si vous en êtes
d'accord monsieur le Président
j'évoquerai l'amendement suivant qui est
un amendement d'appel qui l'objet est
exactement le même on va dire mais qui a
fixé le plancher la plancher à 50 ans
donc vous avez deux amendements un qui
fixe le plancher à 50 ans et l'autre à
55 ans c'est bien ça
pour être dans l'ordre le
2613 c'est 50 ans et le 2614 55
donc ensuite le
2751 madame Poumirol
merci monsieur le Président l'article de
tel qu'il est rédigé actuellement est en
place donc un index senior sans
contrepartie financière et qui
n'annulement été négocié avec les
organisations syndicales nous vous avons
entendu monsieur le rapporteur donc nous
faisons d'autres propositions et dans
cet abonnement nous demandons que ces
index actuellement
inefficaces puissent être remplacées par
un index qualitatif qualitatif donc qui
porte sur la formation l'acquisition de
nouvelles compétences l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie au travail
l'aménagement de poste ou le temps de
travail qui sont des facteurs
extrêmement importants sur le plan de la
santé au travail de nos seniors il
faudra que cette index qualitatif soit
négocié paritairement et ils deviendrait
alors il pourrait être alors mis en
place en même temps des sanctions
différenciées en fonction de la taille
des entreprises cela pourrait rendre
ainsi ce dispositif efficient
merci Madame Mirol donc ensuite le
l'amendement 4126 madame gréaume merci
monsieur le Président alors l'amendement
4126 c'est pour remplacer le terme
poursuit par met en oeuvre pour créer
une obligation d'atteinte du maintien
dans l'emploi des seniors je ne peux
vous faire l'économie de la lecture de
l'alinéa que nous souhaitons modifier
l'employeur poursuit un objectif
d'amélioration de l'embauche et du
maintien en activité des seniors mais
sincèrement est-ce que c'est respecté le
travail législatif que de demander aux
entreprises un objectif d'amélioration
est-ce que c'est respecté l'enjeu de
l'emploi des seniors que de leur
promettent un objectif d'amélioration
c'est le sens de toute la philosophie de
cette réforme des retraites et plus
largement de votre politique économique
et sociale on va demander aux
entreprises 2 ce serait bien que les
employeurs fassent et souvent sans
résultat
dans cette réforme l'augmentation de
cotisations employeur sera compensée par
un transfert des cotisations accidents
du travail et maladie professionnelle
par conséquent rien n'est demandé aux
employeurs dans cette réforme c'est du
jamais vu dans chacune des réformes que
notre pays a connu dans votre politique
économique et sociale nous demandons un
total de faire un geste sur les
carburants total est laissé complètement
seul pour fixer la nature et le montant
de ce geste débouche sur des carburants
ou en deçà de 2 euros après
singulièrement plus élevé que les coûts
de production appris qu'il n'est pas
d'actualité dans la politique des gestes
les distributeurs boucs émissaires du
gouvernement peut être trop gourmand
mais quid des fournisseurs dans la
politique des gestes on avait eu des
assureurs pendant le covid alors que
nous concitoyennes et nos concitoyens ne
pouvaient sortir de chez eux ils ne
pouvait causer d'accidents à partir de
ce constat nous disions qu'il fallait
taxer les assureurs ou qu'il diminue
d'autant leur contrat l'année suivante
le gouv ernement leur a demandé de faire
un geste vous avez créé un outil
politique d'un nouveau genre l'aumône
gouvernementale la supplique plutôt que
la loi votre doctrine monsieur les
ministres c'est le principe même de la
philosophie libérale du laisser faire
laisser passer cette doctrine vise à
enjoindre au pouvoir politique de
laisser les agents économiques les plus
libres possible c'est sûr que vous ne
les dérangez pas cette index ne les
dérangera pas
merci
l'amendement
4655 madame Vogel
er cette index d'une autre manière bon
d'abord pour élargir les informations
que qui seraient publiées dans cette
index en ayant pas seulement de taux
d'emploi mais aussi des informations sur
les conditions de travail des seniors
sur l'adaptabilité de leur poste etc
ensuite
en ayant des des notes minimales à
atteindre parce que ça sert à rien
d'avoir simplement des informations
comme ça si on n'a pas des objectifs
donc c'est amendement propose d'avoir
des objectifs et puis des conséquences
au fait que les entreprises n'atteignent
pas les objectifs avec une demande
d'avoir par décret des sanctions
financières appliquées aux entreprises
qui ne respecteraient pas ces objectifs
ce qui est quand même un peu a priori la
raison pour laquelle on met en place un
index n'est-ce pas c'est pas simplement
pour pouvoir observer de loin le monde
des entreprises c'est quand même pour
avoir un impact sur elle je crois que
c'est pour ça qu'on fait la loi et puis
aussi des propos possession pour
améliorer l'implication des partenaires
sociaux dans la conception de l'index
vous avez dit répéter que certains
partenaires sociaux étaient en faveur de
certains ex et bien j'espère que vous
accorderez avec nous sur le fait que il
serait bien de les associer et puis
également ramener la date d'application
au 1er janvier 2024 pour les entreprises
qui ont plus de 299 salariés et pour
cette entre 50 et 299 au 1er juillet
2024 nous aurons d'autres amendements
que nous discuterons dans la suite pour
améliorer cette index mais vous voyez
que nous avons beaucoup de propositions
nous essayons d'aborder la chose de
manière constructive
l'idée n'est pas de rejeter l'index en
soi c'est de rejeter un index qui ne
sert à rien donc j'espère que cette
index à la fin de la discussion pourra
servir à quelque chose et que vous
pourrez nous donner des raisons de le
voter
bien merci ensuite deux amendements
identiques le premier le 2753 est
présenté par Monsieur Assouline
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain visa à
préciser le contenu de l'objectif
d'amélioration de l'embauche et du
maintien en activité des salariés âgés
qui traitera des thèmes suivants
le recrutement des salariés âgé dans
l'entreprise de l'anticipation de
l'évolution des carrières
professionnelles trois l'amélioration
des conditions de travail et prévention
des situations de pénibilité
4 le développement des compétences et
des qualifications et accès à la
formation 5 l'aménagement des fins de
carrière et de la transition entre
activités et retraite et la transmission
des savoirs et des compétences et
développement du tutorat
voilà ce que contient l'amendement
concrètement et
les nouveaux retraités du régime général
avait validé des trimestres dans le
cadre de l'emploi durant les mois
précédents la liquidation de leurs
droits à la retraite selon le corps ils
étaient
ils étaient le chiffre exact étant
excusez-moi
bon je vous donnerai un emploi durant
bon
[Musique]
les 25% selon le corps n'avait validé
aucun trimestre dans l'année précédente
de leur retraite en 2019 un rapport
sénatorial votre rapport monsieur Savary
avec Madame Monique Lubin c'était penché
sur le défi des fins de carrière vous
aviez mis en évidence un marché du
travail
plus pour les personnes les plus âgées
avec une prévalence de chômage de longue
durée plus importante chez les plus de
50 ans que dans la moyenne les
demandeurs d'emploi l'enjeu pour notre
système de retraite
voilà et ben j'arrête il y a pas de
problème
il y en a un autre après je continuerai
il y a un deuxième amendement
identique le 4129 présenté par Monsieur
ouzulias Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mais mes chers
collègues j'ai du mal qu'on a à
comprendre quand même monsieur le
rapporteur mais je peux pas revenir sur
le débat sur la différence
d'appréciation que vous portez sur
l'article 1er bis que vous avez refusé
et sur l'article 2 que vous acceptez or
on aurait pu parfaitement mobiliser
l'argumentaire de l'article premier bis
qui vous a permis de le refuser contre
contre l'article 2 mais puisqu'il faut
en venir à cet article ce qui est très
gênant c'est que cet article ne définit
pas les index alors
l'article en question renvoie tout ça un
décret pris en Conseil d'État et pour
une loi d'urgence ça pose quand même
problème on est dans une loi de finance
rectificative qui renvoie un certain
nombre de dispositions à des décrets
pris en Conseil état je peux prendre ici
le pari que les décrets pris en compte à
nous les aurons pas avant la loi de
finances de de cette année et par
ailleurs votre votre gouvernement avait
pris une toute autre option quand il
s'agissait de définir les critères dont
la loi du 5 septembre 2018 c'est
l'article 104 vous n'aviez pas défini
précisément les critères mais en
revanche que vous aviez fait d'un point
de vue législatif c'est donner par la
loi un cadrage qui permettrait la
définition de de ces index et je pense
que ça aurait été une meilleure solution
je vous proposerai dans dans un
amendement futur un certain nombre de
cadrage pour permettre la définition de
ses index merci monsieur le président
merci ensuite le 3465 madame Poncet
Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors par
cet amendement le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire propose d'établir
un barème d'évaluation des indicateurs
et d'établir oui des sanctions pour
résultat insuffisants mais différencier
selon la taille de l'entreprise alors il
y a trois je crois 3 ou 4 niveaux
d'entreprises qui sont comme d'habitude
définissent soit par le nombre
l'effectif le nombre de personnes
embauchées soit par le chiffre
d'affaires annuel soit par le total de
du bilan bien donc c'est index donc
aurait un impact d'autant plus faible
que l'obligation
si elle l'obligation ne portait pas sur
la pub que sur la publication de l'index
et non sur l'obtention de résultats
satisfaisants de progrès quoi un petit
peu comme pour les femmes où il faut un
plan d'action il suffira ainsi pour une
entreprise mauvaise élève en matière
d'emploi des seigneurs de simplement
publier l'index pour échapper à une
sanction et on a vu que c'était peu
efficace donc il est donc évident que
c'est index sera un impôt un impact nul
c'est un dispositif d'évaluation chiffré
qui inclut un score minimum à atteindre
forcément sous peine de sanction n'est
pas mis en place ces sanctions
financières doivent également être
adaptés à la taille des entreprises je
les dis ces différencier qui ne
disposent pas des mêmes ressources
notamment RH pour mettre en place une
telle mesure
merci ensuite le 4656 madame Vogel
merci cette amendement vise à élargir le
nombre d'entreprises qui seraient
concernées par la l'obligation de
publier cet index
en limitant seulement la non publication
aux entreprises qui ont moins de 10
salariés c'est quand même 96,2% des
entreprises françaises qui sont des
micro-entreprises mais de d'obliger les
entreprises à publier l'index dès
qu'elles ont au moins 11 salariés
on abaissant le seuil de 300 salariés à
50 salariés qui seraient déjà un pas
dans la bonne direction on rajouterait
environ 5000 entreprises à l'obligation
de publication
en effet il y a environ
4520 entreprises qui emploient entre 50
et 249 salariés mais c'est pas assez
parce que ça exclut toujours toutes les
micro-entreprises et les PME et la
majeure partie des entreprises
françaises comme j'ai dit au début 96 %
sont des petites entreprises la moitié
des Françaises et des Français sont
employés par des micro-entreprises ou
des PME
il faut donc dans la mesure du possible
élargir le champ d'application d'index
des seniors pour améliorer la
transparence en espérant que plus
d'entreprises emploie des seigneurs en
effet essentiel pour permettre au
Seigneur qui devrait travailler plus si
cette réforme était mise en oeuvre de
trouver un emploi nous pensons également
qu'un élargissement de l'index à des
entreprises de plus de 11 salariés ne
représenterait pas une charge
insurmontable pour ces entreprises quand
on a 11 salariés on voit vite en fait
combien il y a de seniors voilà si vous
voulez c'est un peu plus facile à
compter c'est pourquoi nous proposons
d'élargir le champ d'application de
l'index aux entreprises de plus de 11
salariés je vous remercie
merci
chers collègues peut-être que il peut y
avoir un peu moins de conversation à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle on peut
toujours en avoir à l'extérieur en plus
je pense que vous avez souhaité
adopter cet article donc il est normal
qu'il y ait un débat sur les amendements
visant à l'enrichir
donc maintenant l'amendement 1970 qui
est présenté par Monsieur Etienne blanc
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur mes
chers collègues l'inverse de ceux qui
vient d'être indiqué c'est un amendement
qui a pour objet de relever le seuil à
300 salariés
imposés
à des entreprises de l'ordre de 50
salariés
ce dispositif qui va évidemment évoluer
sur le plan réglementaire
cela va créer des charges sur des
entreprises qui souvent n'ont pas les
services de ressources humaines et
suffisamment important et on le sait un
des soucis qui pèse aujourd'hui sur ce
type d'entreprise là c'est la masse des
contraintes administratives qui sont
excessives qui plus est un grand nombre
d'entre elles sont assortis de sanctions
voire même parfois de sanctions pénales
donc ce dispositif de l'index seniors ne
devrait s'appliquer qu'à des entreprises
de plus de 300 salariés pour éviter je
le redis de pénaliser ces petites
entreprises qui font la richesse de la
France
et ensuite deux amendements identiques
qui je crois vont dans le même sens
monsieur Hainaut
merci monsieur le ministre il s'agit
effectivement de relever le seuil à 300
salariés dans les entreprises qui
doivent publier un bilan social qui ont
des services de ressources humaines mais
j'en profite pour faire une remarque
voilà mes chers collègues je vous ai
trouvé bien acrimonieux avec ces fameux
index seniors j'ai même entendu tout à
l'heure que c'était une demande du Medef
non le Medef sur l'index senior il est
sur la même ligne que vous figurez-vous
même si je dois être taquin il est
contre l'index senior le le partenaires
sociaux favorables à l'index seniors
c'est la CFDT et donc nous proposons
cette amendement parce que cette index
senior il doit vivre et il doit pas non
plus être encadré au-delà des
contraintes
parce qu'autrement il y aura pas de
paritarisme si on veut faire vivre le
paritarisme il faut laisser les
partenaires sociaux travailler sur
seniors sur cette index senior avant d'y
mettre des contraintes et puis je relève
aussi le paradoxe et l'incohérence de
ceux et celles et ceux qui étaient pour
la suppression de l'index senior et qui
maintenant veulent les temps à toutes
les entreprises pardonnez-moi mais ça me
paraît quand même curieux quand on est
contre quelque chose on veut pas le le
l'étendre à toutes les entreprises me
semble-t-il voilà nous on croit au
paritarisme on croit aussi à la
responsabilité sociale
sociétale et environnementale des
entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle on est favorable à cette
article et à cet amende bonjour Merci
et ensuite donc l'amendement présenté
par la commission monsieur Savary oui
merci effectivement on est parti
exactement de la même philosophie à
savoir que le seuil de 300 c'est le seul
de gestion de discussion au sein de
l'entreprise de la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et en
conséquence véritablement on peut bâtir
dans à partir de 300 salariés une
véritable politique
ambitieuse d'employabilité des seniors
en dessous en dessous c'est un peu
compliqué voyez-vous parce que vous êtes
dans un bassin d'emploi qui est plutôt
dans une population un peu vieillissante
vous pouvez effectivement peut-être plus
facilement trouver des emplois seniors
vous êtes dans un bassin d'emploi plus
jeune la ma foi c'est plus les jeunes
qui vont répondre aux appels que vous
proposez sachant que vous allez pas là
aussi dire je veux un homme une femme je
veux un jeune je veux un senior non il
la discrimination des appels d'offres
sont ouverts les propositions d'offres
d'emploi sont ouvertes à toute la
population et en conséquence en dessous
de 50 c'est difficile il n'y a pas des
ressources humaines qui permettent
effectivement de gérer
de façon prévisionnelle notamment les
emplois c'est pour ça que il faut
trouver d'autres critères mais les
partenaires sociaux vont nous donner
d'autres critères les indicateurs c'est
eux qui vont les établir et d'autre part
il y a pas que les indicateurs qui
comptent c'est bien beau de poser les
indicateurs encore faut-il qu'ils soient
évolutifs parce que deux ou trois ans
après ils correspondent plus forcément
aux emplois que vous avez eu il y a
véritablement on le sait une dynamique
nouvelle dans le domaine de l'emploi les
emplois de demain dans dans 20 ans nous
ne savons pas quelles ils sont donc il
est difficile de former pour les emplois
dans 20 ans
car il y a eu d'évolution technologies
telles que on ne sait pas comment cela
va évoluer c'est la raison pour laquelle
il nous semble que il faut limiter ce
seuil à 300
merci monsieur le rapporteur ensuite le
2754 enfin il y a deux amendements
identiques là aussi le premier présenté
par Monsieur Assouline oui avant je vais
corriger une moment de confusion tout à
l'heure dans mon argumentation parce que
j'avais des chiffres un peu inversés
donc je répète en 2019 55 % des nouveaux
retraités du régime général avait validé
des trimestres dans le cadre d'un emploi
durant les mois précédents la
liquidation de leurs droits à la
retraite selon le corps un quart avait
validé leur trimestre tout en étant soit
au chômage en invalidité ou en maladie
les 25 restants selon le corps n'avait
validé aucun trimestre dans l'année
précédente leur retraite ça vient
corriger ce moment où j'ai un peu bégayé
tout à l'heure l'amendement que je
défends maintenant au nom du groupe
socialiste républicain écologiste etc
cet amendement vise à préciser que les
indicateurs sur les travailleurs seniors
devront être envoyé par l'entreprise au
ministre du travail ainsi qu'à Pôle
Emploi transmettre ces indicateurs est
un préalable pour que Pôle Emploi puisse
œuvrer au changement de culture des
employeurs envers les salariés âgés ou
en fin de carrière et déployés des
actions spécifiques adaptées d'adressage
des candidatures de salariés de plus de
50 ans vers les entreprises qui se
doivent de développer l'embauche de ses
profils et pour conclure une réponse à
notre collègue qui vient de s'exprimer
du groupe centriste
il n'y a pas de paradoxe à nous
critiquer sur le fait qu'on était pour
le rejet
de cet article pour sa suppression et le
fait que maintenant on veut les tendre
le préciser le renforcer c'est justement
on a considéré que cet article n'apporte
rien pas que la question d'emploi des
seigneurs n'était pas un sujet on pense
même que c'est le sujet central qu'on
aurait dû traiter avant cette loi fait à
la va-vite et niché comme cela sauf que
voilà
on vient en parler là où il ne faut pas
et de façon
tellement
tellement insignifiante que ça peut au
contraire faire reculer cette idée
que l'on doit traiter y compris par un
index pour avoir des données pour avoir
une objective des actions de la
situation donc voilà ce que je voulais
dire et on va continuer à essayer de
faire qu'il ait du contenu à travers les
débats qui vont continuer sur cet
article merci et ensuite l'amendement
suivant le
419 madame la Présidente
je voudrais revenir sur la précision du
dispositif de l'intex Senior et en fait
ça continue à nous interroger bien
évidemment et j'ai quelques questions
que deviendront les données publiées par
les employeurs point d'interrogation ces
données seront-elles publiées sur leur
site internet
idem ces données seront-elles transmises
aux URSSAF pour notre part nous estimons
qu'elles doivent être fournies au
ministère du Travail et donc à pôle
emploi afin de coordonner des politiques
nationales et territoriales d'accès à
l'emploi des seniors et bien je voudrais
aussi revenir sur la question des seuils
qui a été évoquée dans l'abonnement
numéro 2015 émanant des bancs de nos
collègues centric et de la Commission et
je l'ai aussi j'ai encore une question
pourquoi donc s'opposer à ce que les
entreprises de 50 salariés et de moins
de 300 soit concernés notre amendement
lui s'inscrit d'une certaine manière
dans l'extension de la base de données
économiques sont sociales et
environnementales ce document donc
transmis par l'employeur au membre du
Comité économique et social pour les
entreprises des 50 salariés je rappelle
que ce document comprend les
conséquences sur l'activité l'emploi
l'évolution des métiers des compétences
la formation professionnelle
l'organisation du travail le recours à
des contrats temporaires et à des stages
je pense pour ma part qu'il suffirait
d'intégrer à ce document les données
relatives à l'index des seniors et comme
le prévoit cet abonnement de le
transmettre donc automatiquement au
ministère du Travail et à Pôle Emploi
donc je vous pose une question monsieur
le rapporteur et Monsieur le Ministre
qu'en pensez-vous
bien merci ensuite le 2945
qu'il présente Madame jasmin allez-y
oui merci Monsieur Président je tiens
bulle que nous ne voulons être ni
sectaire ni faire de l'obstruction nous
sommes là pour débattre même si on était
contre et moi j'étais effectivement
contre mais maintenant que ça a été voté
et bien je respecte les décisions de
notre assemblée alors il s'agit par cet
amendement de mieux encadrer et de fixer
les limites et les objectifs
prioritaires afin de clarifier les
domaines d'application et les étendues
des mesures qui seront prises pour
améliorer concrètement les conditions
d'accueil et des ergonomie pour ces
seniors il s'agit également de mettre en
œuvre des actions de prévention des
risques en matière de sécurité mais
aussi des risques psychosociaux parce
que très souvent les personnes déjà
fragiles des seniors et bien méritent un
encadrement qui serait beaucoup plus
pertinent plus précieux je dirais parce
qu'il s'agit à la fois pour l'entreprise
de gagner en compétence mais aussi de la
personne de gagner en qualité de vie
donc nous ne devons pas faire n'importe
quoi et si la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite vraiment que cet amendement
soit voté je vous remercie merci le 4654
madame Poncet Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors les
cartes salariales entre les femmes et
les hommes est toujours important
et même si cet écart est moins important
qu'il n'était au début du siècle rien ne
justifie qu'une femme gagne bien moins
pour le même travail il faut aller
beaucoup beaucoup plus vite c'est dans
ce contexte que s'inscrit le projet de
réforme dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
d'accord cette réforme des retraites du
gouvernement pénalisera nous en
parlerons largement davantage les femmes
rien que la mesure de repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite touche les
femmes plus que les hommes car elle
travailleront encore plus que ne
travaillerons les hommes en plus pour
avoir droit à la retraite à taux plein
de l'autre côté c'est très forme prévoit
que les seniors continuent à travailler
donc au-delà de leur 62 ans ce qui
repose quand même avec toute avec
beaucoup d'acuités la question de
l'égalité des gens pour les seniors qui
devraient si la réforme passe et n'est
pas retirée travailler plus longtemps
donc il faut à tout prix éviter que les
écarts se creusent encore c'est pourquoi
nous propose notre compléter l'index
senior par des indicateurs évaluant les
écarts entre les hommes et les femmes
les entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
cela serait alors obligés de publier les
quarts des salaires des seniors
ça n'évitera pas tout il est vrai mais
ça se c'est un élément important à
porter à notre connaissance et d'autant
plus important que les fins de carrière
des femmes sont très différentes de
celles des hommes une étude de la DARES
de 2021 avait montré entre autres que
les femmes seniorent sont plus souvent
en temps partiel dit contraint avec les
réductions de salaire cela entraîne
alors suite au débat à l'Assemblée
nationale et aux demandes de la gauche
le gouvernement a élargi ou plutôt
précisé l'index seniors pour le ventilé
selon les sexes ce n'est ce c'est bien
mais ce n'est pas suffisant parce que
cela n'oblige pas les entreprises à
publier les données sur l'écart
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
seniors c'est pourquoi nous proposons
cet ajout
dans dans le dans ce sens merci le 4136
qui est présenté par Monsieur savoldini
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement comme d'autres posent la
question non pas de seulement favoriser
le maintien dans l'emploi des plus de 50
ans mais de le garantir
et là j'ai retrouvé les propos du
président Macron en avril 2019 je le
cite et quand les Français les
Françaises se le rappellent je peux vous
dire que ça élargit la mobilisation par
rapport à la réforme des retraites
président Macron 2019 je le cite quand
aujourd'hui on est peu qualifié quand on
vit dans une région qui est en
difficulté industrielle quand on est
soi-même en difficulté qu'on a une
carrière fracturée bon courage déjà pour
arriver à 62 ans et alors on va dire NON
NON faut aller maintenant à 64 ans vous
savez déjà plus comment faire après 55
ans les gens vous disent les emplois
c'est plus bon pour vous on doit d'abord
gagner ce combat avant d'expliquer aux
gens mais bons amis travailler plus
longtemps ça c'est les propos du
président de la République à son grand
débat
comprenez ce qui se passe pourquoi il y
a une telle unité syndicale une telle
mobilisation citoyenne et politique
contre cette réforme parce que qu'est-ce
qui a changé et c'est là où la politique
ça peut pas être premièrement une valse
hésitation toutes les 5 minutes mais pas
non plus du marketing quand on prend des
engagements il faut les tenir en
politique et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
1,5 points supplémentaires pour le
tournoi des seniors en plus pour le
porter à 56 points en 2021 c'est une
augmentation de 2,7%. qui peut penser
qu'il y a une révolution pour la vie des
femmes des hommes qui ont plus de 50 ans
soit pour leur maintien en activité soit
pour le rembauche c'est rien passé le
taux d'emploi des seniors est si peu
au-dessus de 1980 alors que l'âge de
départ était fixé à 65 ans si bien que
la Sion réfléchit et non pas par un
raisonnement par l'absurde si bien que
dire que l'âge légal est ce qui force au
travail plus longtemps et bien une
hérésie sinon dans notre système de
retraite actuel à 62 ans il devrait
travailler moins
donc le son de l'affaire le montant des
pensions est systématiquement la
variable de justement de la réforme des
retraites qui nous est proposée
merci monsieur le Président donc le
présent amendement du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vise à inclure le
temps partiel parmi les indicateurs de
l'index senior
il y a plus de temps partiel chez les
seniors que dans n'importe quel autre
classe d'âge c'est une partie du recours
au temps partiel s'explique par le cumul
en poireet or à l'exclusion du cumul en
points retraite il reste encore
légèrement supérieur à 10%
. il risque de s'accentuer ce taux
risque de s'accentuer de façon
volontaire ou contrainte par l'état de
santé avec le recul de l'âge de la
retraite afin que ces situations qui
conduisent souvent à une hausse de la
précarité des seniors ne soit pas
invisibilisé le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire demande que
l'examen du recours au temps partiel
soit systématiquement inclus dans les
indicateurs de l'index comme ils
auraient dû être dans l'index d'égalité
professionnelle homme-femme
si le 4145 madame Cohen merci monsieur
le Président effectivement
l'index senior on l'a dit et inférieur
en fait à l'index professionnel entre
les femmes et les hommes qui a été vidé
d'ailleurs de son contenu et qui a vu se
dresser toutes les associations
féministes et beaucoup de syndicalistes
contre lui parce que les pénalités sont
effectivement très faibles donc
normalement il faudrait il faudrait en
tirer des leçons je vais vous donner
quelques exemples par rapport à cette
indicateur professionnel entre les
femmes et et les hommes par exemple si
10 femmes sont augmentées de 10 euros
tandis que 10 hommes sont augmentés de
100 euros l'entreprise obtiendra tous
les points sur cet indicateur ou encore
si tous les salariés sont augmentés à
leur retour de congé maternité ce qui
constitue une obligation légale et ce
d'un euro l'entreprise validera
également l'indicateur bref un
paramétrage qui explique les très bons
scores qui sont obtenus par les
entreprises depuis le lancement de
l'index alors même que les femmes
continuent encore à gagner en moyenne
23% de moins que les hommes et être payé
près de 17% de moins à poste égal donc
on voit bien que les index c'est quand
même important mais alors l'index senior
il est encore inférieur à ses exigences
là
donc en refusant
d'associer l'index seniors à des
sanctions c'est un recul du gouvernement
une fois de plus face au MEDEF pourtant
j'ai l'impression monsieur le rapporteur
René Paul Savary que vous êtes d'accord
avec nous avec notre groupe et que vous
trouvez comme nous inadmissible la
situation qui est faite au seniors face
à l'emploi à 60 ans près d'une personne
sur trois n'est ni en emploi ni à la
retraite la majorité d'entre elles et
eux se retrouvent en invalidité ou en
situation de RSA ou de chômage donc en
grande précarité il faut donc en tirer
des leçons et accepter l'enrichissement
grâce à notre abonnement
merci le 4151 madame gréaum merci
monsieur le Président avec cette index
vous mettez les doigts sur un problème
majeur comme disait ma collègue celui de
l’emploi des seniors connaissez-vous les
réalités de l'emploi que vivent nos
concitoyens pour en être certaine je
vous rappelle quelque chiffres
61,3 % des personnes n'existe déjà plus
d'activités à 61 ans et cela atteint
73,6% à 62 ans on imagine déjà comment
cela évoluera jusqu'à 64 ans il est
difficile d'obtenir un emploi au-delà de
55 ans puisque les employeurs supposent
notamment une moindre productivité ainsi
qu'une moindre adaptabilité cela est
encore plus vrai comme comme toujours
pour celles et ceux qui ont connu durant
leur carrière à certains nombres de
discriminations je pense aux femmes aux
personnes en situation de handicap etc
alors pour votre index nous proposons de
prendre en compte ces critères pour am
éliorer l'égalité professionnelle et
ainsi éviter les meneurs pour contourner
les dispositions prévues et le sens de
cet article merci
le 4142
[Musique]
madame assassin
donc cet amendement a pour but de
rappeler donc
je vais y arriver je vais y arriver
c'est Monsieur savolle Delhi qui me
perturbe donc je recommence pour besoin
appeler que dans certaines de nos
qualités non non on se détend aussi on
est bien là on se détend voilà donc dans
certaines de nos qualités la démographie
la démographie est stable à d'autres
endroits et les croissantes et dans
d'autres elle est même décroissante plus
la population est grande qu'une
entreprise est grande mais lorsque la
population est moindre a un certain
endroit certains nos entreprises ne
peuvent compter 300 salariés au sein de
leurs effectifs il faut donc prendre en
compte un plus grand nombre
d'entreprises pour que la place des
seniors soit réellement une priorité au
sein de ces dernières cet article ne
s'adapte pas à ces différences la
valorisation du travail des personnes
âgées doit s'appliquer à toutes les
échelles même si l'entreprise ne compte
pas 300 salariés ce ne sont pas toujours
les plus grandes qui doivent être
privilégiées afin qu'une telle qu'une Ré
stratégie d'inclusion des personnes
âgées dans le milieu du travail soit
efficient il faut donc prendre en compte
la singularité des territoires même si
j'aime pas le mot territoire l'exposé de
l'article du gouvernement va dans ce
sens pour toutes ces raisons nous
proposons d'abaisser le seuil à 150
salariés cela permettra plus
d'entreprises de prendre en compte la
place de nos aînés au sein de leurs
effectifs et de ce fait prendre en
compte les territoires que je n'aime
toujours pas le mot que je n'aime
toujours pas qui n'ont pas la même
strate de population
madame ponce pour le 3467
merci monsieur le Président alors si on
veut faire vivre l'index Seigneur si on
croit au paritarisme si on croit à la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale on écoute les
organisations syndicales je viens de
citer mon collègue Olivier Hainaut alors
immédiatement presque
j'ai décidé de défendre avec conviction
cet amendement qui est proposé par une
des organisations syndicales d'une ça
vous voyez l'une Saxe
d'été et donc je pense monsieur Hainaut
que vous parliez de toutes les
organisations donc voilà
cette organisation propose que de la
même manière que les entreprises ayant
des résultats insuffisants à
l'indicateur et d'égalité
professionnelle sont sanctionnées
financièrement
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire reprend leur proposition de
sanctionner les entreprises ayant des
résultats insatisfaisants au regard des
critères de l'index senior et pas
uniquement celle ne publions pas
simplement l'indicateur sur l'emploi des
seigneurs donc cette sanction
permettrait de créer une incitation
financière mais aussi réputationnelle
c'est pas très joli afin que les
entreprises mettent en place des
politiques d'emploi réellement efficace
en faveur des salariés
âgés et du taux d'emploi des seniors
merci ensuite le
3177 toujours vous madame pourcement
alors toujours dans cette écoute des
propositions des organisations
syndicales à laquelle on a été invité
nous proposons d'encadrer l'étendue et
les modalités de l'index seniors afin de
s'assurer que cet outil il faut que ça
soit vraiment un outil c'est à dire
qu'il soit opérant et réellement un
impact sur les entreprises en matière
d'emploi des seniors et d'amélioration
de leur condition de travail est ainsi
proposé d'entourer la mise en place des
critères le composant par décret d'un
cadre législatif c'est important un
cadre législatif ça permet de garantir
la prise en compte des politiques
d'emplois publics des conditions de
travail et de rémunération des salariés
proches de la retraite afin que l'index
soit l'outil de mesure le plus efficace
possible au service justement ensuite ou
en parallèle de la négociation de
branches puis en entreprise par ailleurs
l'inégalité entre femmes et hommes quant
au niveau des pensions de retraite et à
l'âge effectif de du départ de
à la retraite nécessite une déclinaison
des indicateurs dans le champ de la mise
en œuvre de l'égalité professionnelle
voilà je vais raccourcir je vous invite
à lire le reste puisque c'est dans
l'objet et c'est un amendement proposé
par une sac le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire soit avec eux
affiner cette index par la clarté la
précision la transparence dans la
définition des indicateurs je vous
remercie merci le 4163 présenté par
Monsieur ouzulias Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre mais mes
chers collègues nous nous continuons
dans dans le cadrage que je vous ai
présenté le cadrage législatif de la
définition des index et vous nous en
proposons quelques-uns notamment que ces
index prennent en compte le recrutement
à les fin de contrat le taux d'emploi la
prévention des effets défavorables et
les risques inhérents aux carrières
longues ensuite la durée des contrats de
travail le temps de travail la mobilité
la pénibilité le maintien des niveaux de
rémunération les cumuls d'emploi
retraite etc et comme nous très sensible
au dialogue social bien évidemment nous
prévoyons par par cet amendement que une
convention de branche puisse enrichir la
laisse la liste des indicateurs
mentionné au premier rangs tel que je
viens de faire et cette liste pourrait
se substituer ensuite au degrés
mentionné merci monsieur le Président
merci ensuite le 2759 présenté par
Madame Monnier madame lewerou pardon
le président alors puisque vous avez
voté l'index senior cet amendement de
notre groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain visent à mieux définir les
indicateurs donc
l'index senior afin de s'assurer de son
efficacité alors nous proposons que
soient précisé dans le décret 5 éléments
à prendre en compte la prévention des
effets défavorables et risque inhérents
carrière longue ou à la pénibilité des
professions notamment en matière de
santé et sécurité des travailleurs
deuxième élément l'organisation des
conditions d'emploi et de travail la
durée des contrats de travail le temps
de travail la mobilité la pénibilité
troisième élément le maintien des
niveaux de rémunération et les
dispositifs d'entreprises de financement
des retraites le quatrième élément les
cumules en poids retraite la
reconversion professionnelle des signaux
ou les retraites progressives dans
l'entreprise nous proposons également
finalement qu'une convention de branche
soit étendue et qu'elle puisse enrichir
la liste des indicateurs
mentionner donc si devant ce cadre
permettra de garantir la prise en compte
des politiques d'emploi des conditions
de travail et de rémunération des
salariés proches de la retraite afin que
l'index soit l'outil de mesure le plus
efficace possible au service de la
négociation en branche et en entreprise
cet amendement a été travaillé avec
l'une ça merci
ensuite deux amendements identiques le
3731 présenté par Monsieur Ferny qui
ensuite y aura le 4171 allez-y monsieur
ferdenic merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc je pense qu'on l'a bien compris
l'index senior proposé repêché par le
gouvernement après que l'Assemblée
nationale ne l'est pas jugé convaincant
c'est index est peu contraignant
puisqu'il ne prévoit qu'une obligation
de publicité pour que l'index senior est
un réel impact sur les pratiques des
entreprises en matière d'emploi des
salariés seniors il faudrait inclure
dans ce dispositif un barème
d'évaluation avec une note minimale à
atteindre c'est ce que vous propose cet
amendement j'ai pas été trop long merci
ensuite le 4171 madame apourci
merci monsieur le Président alors notre
collègue vient de le dire cet amendement
pour notre part vise à intégrer à
l'index senior son évaluation sans quoi
il sera il serait difficile de mesurer
la progression restant à accomplir car
l'employeur doit assumer son objectif
d'amélioration d'embauche et du maintien
en activité des travailleurs seniors
après avoir réclamé à coréacerie que
vous lui livriez encore plus de main
d'oeuvre il les voulait ses deux ans de
plus que vous arrachez au peuple tous
ici puisqu'ils devront travailler demain
les salariés jusqu'à 64 ans voulez-vous
lier évidemment aussi c'est 64 ans nous
vous avons démontré les économistes
l'ont également démontré vous ne vous
engagez pas pour sauver notre système de
retraite c'est autre chose ici qui vous
anime et si elle n'est pas le cas
pourquoi vous obstinez à refuser
d'établir des seuils Satis pour l'emploi
des travailleurs les plus vulnérables
vous promettez des grandes négociations
qui laisseraient la part belle à
l'expression de tout et tous et qui
permettent d'entretenir évidemment le
flou nous ne voulons pas d'inflou sur ce
type de mesure un barème d'évaluation
comprenant une note minimale à atteindre
doit constituer un cadre d'objectifs
nous souhaitons qu'au-delà du fétiche ou
plutôt de cette épouvantail qui ne prend
auprès de personnes nous soyons un peu
sérieux la construction de cette index
et son évaluation permettra de situer
précisément les marges de progression de
chaque entreprise Intel sera en 200
matières de formation qui nous le savons
est un très grand chantier Intel sur
l'aménagement des fins de carrière ainsi
la note sera porteuse de sens nous
introduisons d'ailleurs un délai afin
d'atteindre un seuil minimal acceptable
merci
ensuite le 2758 présenté par Madame le
héros
de notre groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains vise à confier à un accord
national interprofessionnel le soin de
construire les indicateurs de l'index
senior alors un accord national
interprofessionnel est un accord négocié
et signé par les partenaires sociaux et
donc nous donnera des gages d'efficacité
dans la mise en oeuvre le dialogue
social est important primordial même
dans ce domaine précis de la définition
des index la place des partenaires
sociaux doit être respectée la
discussion avec ses partenaires doit
permettre de trouver le bon équilibre et
les indicateurs les plus pertinents pour
assurer l'efficacité de cet index merci
merci ensuite le
4176 monsieur ça vole Delhi merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
amendement vise à ce que la liste des
indicateurs c'est à dire leur mode de
calcul leur évolution soit précisée et
non pas de manière discrétionnaire mais
par un accord national
interprofessionnel
avec notre amendement nous redonnons
donc toute sa place
vous nous dites monsieur le ministre je
pense que vous la voulez aussi
c'est la place que doit avoir la
négociation collective dans la mise en
place de l'index senior donc j'ai pu
retrouver avec mon groupe les dires de
l'ancien membre du Conseil
constitutionnel Olivier dutille et de la
Motte qui résumait dans sa contribution
à la revue Semaine sociale les quatre
atouts possibles d'une norme négociées
collectivement et vraiment son
diagnostic est
utile d'abord elle vient des acteurs
même de l'entreprise
merci ensuite le 2756 madame Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président alors la
ligne A6 de l'article 2 prévoit que la
liste des indicateurs et leurs méthodes
de calcul sont fixées par décret nous
proposons avec cet amendement de
préciser qu'il s'agit d'un décret en
Conseil d'État alors pourquoi un décret
en Conseil d'État parce que le décret en
Conseil d'État est une procédure
différente et il suppose par ailleurs de
passer par le Conseil des ministres or
ce décret nous paraît important dans la
mise en oeuvre de l'index senior nous
sommes beaucoup ici en cité l'index
égalité femme homme or il faut tirer les
leçons de ce qu'on constate sur l'index
égalité femme homme nombreux biais et
des biais qui tiennent à la fois sur la
question des comparaisons sur les
augmentations des femmes des
augmentations sur les nombres de femmes
promues comparé bien entendu aux
augmentations accordées aux hommes aux
augmentations au nombre d'hommes promus
Laurence Cohen tout à l'heure a fait
référence un certain nombre de
d'exemples
qui montre que c'est bien en fait
permette à des entreprises qui ne
respectent que la moitié
de des prescriptions de l'index égalité
d'obtenir le nombre de points suffisants
les 75 points qui leur permettent
d'échapper aux sanctions d'abord et
ensuite au rattrapage de leur politique
donc instruite tout ça il nous faut nous
prévoir le meilleur indicateur et on
pense que le Conseil d'État est une
garantie d'un meilleur indicateur et
surtout de Planète plus
interministérialité et puis enfin
dernière élément un indicateur Conseil
d'État un décret en Conseil d'État c'est
un gros avantage c'est que peut-être il
y aura un avis
et s'il y a un avis en Conseil d'État je
ne doute pas que notre collègue que
notre collègue Daniel brouiller
demandera à ce que la vie en Conseil
d'État soit montré au Parlement après
dans le cadre de notre activité de
contrôle de la du gouvernement
ensuite
2479 monsieur broyé justement merci
monsieur le Président et merci cher
collègue rossignol
l'amendement je défends l'amendement qui
a été présenté par mon collègue Thomas
dossu mais qui a dû rentrer à Lyon c'est
aussi d'ailleurs un amendement proposé
par le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
il vise à prendre le décret qui définira
la liste des indicateurs à l'index
senior après consultation de l'Agence
Nationale pour l'Amélioration des
Conditions de Travail la nacte l'index
senior qui est proposé dans le texte et
la principale et avons le nous l'avons
d'ailleurs tous reconnus ensemble bien
maigre mesure prévu par le gouvernement
pour mettre fin au chômage des seniors
ou en tous les cas pour réduire le
chômage des seniors
cette mesure se base sur l'idée qu'un
index que les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés devraient publier tous les ans
suffirait à résoudre les difficultés
auxquelles font face les seniors en
recherche d'emploi Olivier Mériot
l'ancien directeur technique et
scientifique de la nacte a jugé
hypocrite et dangereuse la proposition
du report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite dans une tribune parue dans Le
Monde fin janvier il précise qu'aucune
mesure ne pourra contrebalancer les
impacts d'un recul de la borne d'âge
pour une large partie du corps social
déjà fragilisée selon lui l'index senior
n'échappe pas ce constat l'index senior
est une mesure plus qu’insuffisante qui
ne comporte de surcroît aucune garantie
renvoyant un décret le soin de fixer la
liste des indicateurs de cet index ainsi
que leur méthode de calcul établir de
telles indicateurs ne peut se faire sans
la consultation des acteurs concernés
par la thématique du travail et de
l'emploi et l'Agence nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et d'emploi l'anacte à plusieurs
domaines de compétences notamment
je m'arrête puisque excusez moi j'ai
dépassé le temps et pour rattraper un
peu de ce temps si vous m'y autorisez
monsieur le Président j'enchaîne avec
l'amendement suivant absolument il y a
trois amendements identiques c'est vous
qui présentez le premier allez-y alors
le présente amendement porté par le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire vise à prendre le décret qui
définira la liste des indicateurs de
l'index senior après consultation cette
fois-ci du Conseil économique social et
environnemental de ces œufs si l'on en
croit l'étude d'impact fourni par le
gouvernement l'index senior prévu à
l'article 2 de ce texte a notamment pour
objectif d'objectiver la place des
seniors en entreprise d'assurer la
transparence en matière de gestion des
âges et de mettre en oeuvre une logique
d'amélioration continue des pratiques
des entreprises en mobilisant le
dialogue social dans l'entreprise
l'emploi des seniors est un sujet qui
mérite d'être traité avec sérieux
d'après l'OCDE le taux d'emploi des 55
64 ans atteint 56, 100% en France contre
62,6% dans la zone euro les salariés de
plus 50 ans sont souvent victimes de
pratiques délétères de la part d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui
préfèrent les placardiser ou les
licenciers les discriminations la vie
dure ces salariés en fin de carrière
sont nombreux à être jugés trop coûteux
ou encore trop susceptibles de tomber
malade il subisse une double peine une
fois licenciée il aurait très difficile
de retrouver du travail si le
gouvernement veut prendre un bras le
corps le problème du chômage comme il
l'affirme l'index senior est une
solution bien maigre et ce ne sont pas
les résultats de l'index de l'égalité
professionnelle homme-femme comme vient
de le démontrer ma collègue qui
contredit ce constat c'est pourquoi face
à la détermination de tes indicateurs
comme la détermination de ces
indicateurs ne peut se faire à la légère
nous proposons par cet amendement de
repli d'obliger le gouvernement à
consulter de ses œufs pour établir par
décret la liste des indicateurs de
l'index senior
merci ensuite donc deux amendes moyen
identiques à celui-là le premier la
présidente rossignol
merci monsieur le Président
qu'on se fasse bien comprendre d'abord
moi je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je suis
pas hostile à la technique des index je
pense qu'elle a une utilité dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'identifier des
discriminations de mieux en comprendre
les mécanismes et les raisons et aussi
les vis et ainsi dire médié et nous
amendements
ne visent pas à alourdir
inutilement la procédure elle vise au
point vis au contraire à garantir pour
cette index le plus grand succès la
meilleure performance de l'index dans un
premier temps et peut-être j'aurai une
toute petite nuance avec mon collègue
Daniel brouiller s'il s'agit pas
d'obliger le gouvernement à conçu des
saisons il s'agit de mobiliser le ses
œufs pour qu'il soit consultés pour
apporter au gouvernement son expérience
voyez-vous c'est pas une contrainte
c'est un apport qui est que nous
proposons pour le gouvernement il y a au
CESU beaucoup de ressources beaucoup de
richesses et en particulier lorsqu'il
s'agit de comprendre à la fois la
manière dont les salariés vivent leur
réduction du monde du travail la manière
dont les entreprises
évitent rejettent les salariés les plus
âgés et puis aussi de ces un autre
avantage c'est qu'on y trouve l'ensemble
des types d'activités vous avez tout
aussi bien les grandes entreprises
l'agriculture l'artisanat et cela ont
des questions différentes et je pense
que cette affaire de
d'emploi des seniors c'est pas
simplement qu'une affaire de texte c'est
une affaire de mobilisation de toute la
société de toutes les entreprises bien
sûr les artisans bien sûr les PME ne
sont pas incluses dans le champ parce
que je ne doute pas que l'amendement sur
les 300 va probablement trouver une
majorité pour autant les petites
entreprises peuvent avoir envie de
contribuer à cette effort national pour
l'emploi des seniors et consulter le
CESU l'associer à la création de l'index
c'est se garantir la plus grande
communauté autour de cette ambition et
de cette objective commun
et le 4179 Laurence Cohen oui
effectivement monsieur le Président un
amendement de repli qui
identique qui a été très bien présenté
par mes deux collègues mais je pense que
c'est important monsieur le ministre que
effectivement vous puissiez vous nourrir
de l'expérience du Conseil économique
social et environnemental ce sont des
représentants de salariés le secteur
associatif et même le patronat qui sont
présents au 16e s'élève tous contre
cette réforme des retraites et pour des
raisons différentes donc ça se fait
intéressant d'avoir leur point de vue
leur expérience leur analyse et je vais
m'attacher à présenter des faits
objectifs que nous pouvons partager me
semble-t-il sur tous les bancs de notre
hémicycle le taux d'emploi des plus de
60 ans en France est beaucoup plus
faible que la moyenne de l'Union
européenne ça a été souligné mais je le
redis c'est extrêmement important de
l'avoir en tête le taux d'emploi des
personnes de 60 à 64 ans discrimine
particulièrement les moins diplômés 25%
des 100 diplômes sont sans emploi
à cet âge contre 53% des diplômés de
l'enseignement supérieur plus on avance
en âge mais on a de chance d'avoir un
emploi prétendre faire travailler deux
ans de plus celles et ceux qui ne
travaillent déjà plus n'aura qu'un effet
renforcer la trappe après karité en 2019
939000 personnes
âgées de 50 à 64 ans déjà en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté un seuil de pauvreté
fixé à 50% du revenu médian concrètement
000 personnes vivent en France avec
moins de 919 euros par mois en réponse à
cette réalité sociale qui doit tout et
tous nous préoccuper franchement se
contenter de la publication d'un index
tel que prévu sans obligation de
résultats et quelque chose de totalement
dérisoire d'où le sens de notre
amendement
merci ensuite le 46 rectifier madame
Guillotin
oui monsieur le Président donc l'index
Seigneur doit effectivement être un
outil au service de l'amélioration et de
l'employabilité et le maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors il doit être en
fait plus qu'un simple index quantitatif
et doit prendre en compte
le bien-être et la qualité de vie au
travail car on le sait tous ici au-delà
du salaire et des avantages que peut
qu'on ferait un emploi les salariés
aujourd'hui sont en quête à la fois de
sens et d'une qualité de vie qui leur
permet effectivement de sentir bien et
de poursuivre l'emploi auquel ils sont
ou peut-être rentrer dans un nouvel
emploi je vais juste prendre un exemple
Danemark qui a une prévention de l'usure
professionnelle et le développement
d'une culture d'entreprise qui est
importante qui mise sur un management
bienveillant à l'écoute et qui sont et
dans ce pays en fait dans les
entreprises c'est imposée cette
bien-être bien-être au travail avec un
véritable enjeu réputationnel qui fait
que l'entreprise entre guillemets met en
avant cette qualité de vie au travail et
ce bien-être au travail c'est pourquoi
nous proposons donc dans cet index au
travers de cet amendement que l'index
senior soit mis en place et prenne en
compte ces indicateurs relatifs à la
fois au bien-être et à la qualité de vie
merci le 3423 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors ce
projet de loi se caractérise par un
silence absolu sur la question des
licenciements pour inaptitude des
salariés vieillissants
usé évaluer pourtant à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers par an c'est une
véritable épidémie silencieuse monsieur
le ministre il n'y a pas que des
ruptures conventionnelles il y a
beaucoup de ruptures pour inaptitude cet
amendement a donc pour objet qu'à mimima
l'index senior permet de disposer d'une
information fiable et transparente sur
ce fait social majeur
par ailleurs il faut absolument
différencier les PME et les grandes
entreprises vous voyez nous sommes aussi
très sensibles à ça en ce que ces
dernières disposent des moyens
conséquents pour mettre en oeuvre
l'index seniors c'est pourquoi la
sanction doit être différenciée
notamment plus dissuasif pour les
entreprises de 300 salariés au moins à
des faux rien ne sera installés par des
temps dans des temps raisonnables alors
je reprécise que nous avons souvent dans
les statistiques les licenciements
économiques d'un côté et les
licenciements non économiques de l'autre
et dans les licenciements non
économiques il y a effectivement les
licenciements pour inaptitude et il y a
aussi les licenciements pour rupture
conventionnelle donc dont on va beaucoup
parler là effectivement prochainement
pour leur taxation donc il est vraiment
indispensable de pas simplement mettre
dans cette catégorie
confusionnante des licenciements non
économiques des licenciements qui ont
vraiment
dénatures très différentes car le
licenciement pour inaptitude lui est
vraiment subi et à quelquefois des
conséquences on en reparlera dramatique
pour le salarié merci ensuite deux
amendements identiques le 178 monsieur
Milon
oui merci monsieur le Président en fait
mon amendement qui qui vient lui aussi
de la Fnac ne concerne en ce qui en ce
qui me concerne que l'alinéa 6
contrairement à l'amendement de Madame
brancier Monge qui a le même texte que
moi pour l'anniversaire mais qui
complète par rien neuf donc moi je
maintiens simplement l'année à 6 en
disant que celui-ci doit être complété
par cette phrase parmi ces indicateurs
figurent le nombre de licenciements pour
inaptitude et le nombre de reclassements
pour une aptitude des salariés de plus
de 45 ans
merci et un amendement identique madame
Monnier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre les nombreuses limites que
présente l'index senior est instaurée
par cette réforme ont été précédemment
pointés par mes collègues le présent
amendement vise à renforcer sa portée en
précisant dès à présent sans entendre
les laboration du décret sur lequel nous
n'aurons plus de prises que cette Intex
senior doit prendre en compte le nombre
de licenciement pour inaptitude et le
nombre de reclassements pour une
attitude des salariés de plus de 45 ans
la première ministre Elisabeth borne a
elle-même admis lors de la présentation
du projet de réforme le 10 janvier
dernier que de nombreuses entreprises
avaient recours à une pratique abusive
voire discriminatoire qui consiste à
faire partir les salariés quelques
années avant la retraite il est
essentiel de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
disposer d'une information fiable et
transparente sur ce phénomène d'ampleur
qui concernerait plusieurs Dizier de
milliers de personnes par an et seraient
probablement amené à s'accélérer avec le
recul de l'âge légal de à la retraite
merci ensuite le 3184 madame ponce mais
je pense que en fait c'est la suite de
ce que vous aviez présenté précédemment
oui mais alors c'est pas la différence
que j'ai avec Alain Milon sur ce cet
amendement je vais regarder
mais effectivement il s'agit de ne pas
passer sous silence sais licenciement
pour inaptitude mais tout à l'heure
c'était juste qu'on est les
licenciements pour inaptitude et là je
souhaite qu'il y ait aussi les
reclassements pour inaptitude je crois
que la Milo c'est aussi cela alors moi
je veux quand même réinsister pour avoir
été consultante en entreprise quand même
sur le fait que vous avez des salariés
qui redoutent plus que tout la visite
médicale il redoute plus que tout la vie
d'inaptitude pour eux c'est une
catastrophe ils savent très bien les les
possibilités de de reclassement alors
vous allez me dire avant on avait une
visite médicale tous les deux ans et ben
ils sont au moins maintenant c'est tous
les 5 ans donc ça leur donne un répit
pour le préjudice d'anxiété ceci cette
plaisanterie mise à part je voudrais
quand même rappeler quand même qu'à ces
âge-là les avis d'inaptitude et vous
avez des branches que je connais bien du
soin de l'aide et du soin à domicile qui
ne sortent plus par retraite c'est fini
plus personne au fait plus les départs
en retraite dans cette branche on a que
des sorties par inaptitude et les
courbes entre la sortie par retraite et
la sortie par inaptitude se sont croisés
après la loi 2010 il faut bien le savoir
donc voilà c'est une inquiétude de
justifier ils sont pas anxieux pour rien
95% des salariés déclarés inapte sont
licenciés donc et c'est un rapport de
2019 de la Haute Autorité de Santé sur
la désinsertion professionnelle qui est
le signal et ce malgré mais c'est pas
toujours possible l'obligation de
reclassement à la charge de l'employeur
ils s'en suit alors pour le une perte
durable d'emploi qui est d'autant plus
grande pour les seniors donc voilà je
sais pas bien merci ensuite le 258 et le
259 tombes puisque aucun des signataires
n'est présent
le
3732 monsieur ferrique oui merci
monsieur le Président
les femmes sont particulièrement
victimes on l'a dit des inégalités
salariales qui se creusent au fil du
temps les inégalités liées aux genres
s'ajoutant aux problèmes liés à l'âge le
montant moyen des pensions de retraite
on est d'ailleurs le reflet donc
l'introduction d'un indicateur sur le
genre dans l'index senior permettrait
ainsi de contribuer à ce que les
entreprises publient une manière
distincte les chiffres relatifs à
l'emploi des femmes seniors de ceux des
hommes seniors afin de constater plus
nettement les inégalités de genre en fin
de carrière constater plus nettement
pour permettre d'y mieux remédier telle
est l'objet de cette amendement
merci ensuite le 2480 monsieur Breuillet
oui monsieur le Président toujours au
nom de mon collègue Thomas dessus c'est
amendement vise en fait à garantir le
fait que dans l'index senior il y est
bien des indicateurs spécifiques aux
travailleuses et aux travailleurs
seniors qui occupent des emplois
d'employés si la situation des seniors
sur le marché du travail est déplorable
ce n'est peut-être pas la peine de le
répéter puisque ça a beaucoup été dit
qu'elle soit s'entend près d'une
personne sur trois n'était ni en emploi
ni à la retraite la majorité d'entre
elles en situation de l'invalidité de
RSE ou de chômage et donc de précarité
mais il y a des difficultés
particulières qui concernent les
personnes qui sont dans la situation
d'employés et notamment les conditions
de travail qui peuvent aussi être
désastreuses ce à quoi on pense moins
souvent que pour d'autres métiers durée
dans l'emploi est plus difficile pour
les personnes les plus précaires qui
exercent des emplois à forte pénibilité
à titre d'exemple 20% des infirmières
finissent en invalidité à la fin de leur
carrière
à cause de la pression psychologique
notamment et surtout du rythme imposé
par le travail qui les empêche d'avoir
une carrière complète l'index senior tel
qu'il est présenté dans ce texte ne peut
évidemment pas résoudre les problèmes
inhérents à l'emploi des seniors et à
leurs conditions de travail c'est il
pourrait rester un pansement sur une
jambe de bois si nous ne le nourrissons
pas à défaut d'un dispositif ambitieux
nous proposons de l'améliorer notamment
en ce qui concerne ces indicateurs et de
préciser dans le texte que la liste des
indicateurs de l'index seniors ainsi que
leur métier de leur méthode de calcul
seront fixées par des craies ce qui
offre peu de garantie mais qui les
fondamental que ça examine les
conditions de travail des seniors avec
des indicateurs spécifiques pour les
seniors occupants un emploi d'employés
ensuite le 2755 madame Poumirol oui
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
monde du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain visent à garantir que ces
index seniors contiennent au moins des
indicateurs spécifiques aux travailleurs
occupant en emploi d'ouvriers bien sûr
ce sont des indicateurs portant
essentiellement sur la qualité de vie au
travail les aménagements de poste les
aménagements d'horaires tout cela pour
éviter les maladies professionnelles ou
les accidents de travail qui sont plus
importants bien sûr au-delà de 60 ans et
les ouvriers sont aussi ceux qui ont les
facteurs de pénibilité les plus
importants et dont il faut tenir compte
merci ensuite le 32
3200 5 pardon madame Poncet Monge
nous souhaitons alors on a parlé des
employés mais que la liste effectivement
contiennent des indicateurs spécifiques
au travailleur senior
occupants un emploi d'ouvriers je
voudrais dire en préalable que tous les
travailleurs sont touchés de façon
brutale par cette par cette réforme mais
effectivement de façon différenciée plus
pour les femmes plus pour les ouvriers
plus pour les employés donc il est
important effectivement de d'avoir cet
indicateur spécifique aux travailleurs
seniors occupants un emploi d'ouvriers
les ouvriers seront les premiers touchés
par cette réforme brutale inégalitaire
il est nécessaire de rappeler que selon
l'Insee 10 à 11 ans selon les
statistiques d'écart d'espérance de vie
sans incapacité dites en bonne santé
c'est part pour les hommes les ouvriers
et les hommes les ouvriers et les cadres
comme dans une moindre mesure
effectivement pour les femmes alors
selon la dernière étude de la DARES le
service les statistiques du travail tout
le monde connaît le taux d'emploi des
seniors après 60 ans s'effondre
seulement 35% bon ça a été dit je peux
sauter
mais les ouvriers quand même par rapport
à ça 61 ans ce n'est pas par hasard si
il n'y en a plus que 28 % en emploi
alors que pour les cadres à 61 ans il y
a 61% des cadres mais je tiens à dire
quand même que les cadres à 13% sont
aussi touchés par le phénomène à ces
âges là 61 ans des personnes nées en
emploi ni en retraite donc 13% des cases
sont dans ce sas de précarité c'est pour
ça que vous avez toutes les
organisations syndicales y compris
celles qui représente les catégories
cadres
bon ben si je n'ai plus de temps donc je
vais m'arrêter là et je vous invite à
lire les autres points qui sont dans
l'objet
bien merci
le 3109 présenté par le Marie-Pierre de
la Gontrie
ou alors qui le qui le défend là
monsieur a souligne
mais moi j'étais là alors monsieur
j'étais dans l'hémicycle mais pas à ma
place classique
et bien de toute façon ça va ça va pas
être une défense très longue comme j'en
ai l'habitude cet amendement vise à
garantir que l'index senior contiennent
au moins des indicateurs spécifiques aux
travailleurs en situation de handicap je
vais y revenir à travers plusieurs
amendements mais cette indicateur
spécifique et très important si l'on
veut parler
de ces personnes en situation
particulière y compris par rapport à la
retraite
merci le 4183 qu'il présente dans le
groupe communiste madame gréaume
alors merci monsieur le Président les
seniors ne sont pas égaux devant la
précarité selon le rapport du corps à
l'âge de 62 ans près de 16,7% des
personnes se sont assis ni en emploi ni
à la retraite entre la cessation
définitive d'activités et la retraite
les quarts est en moyenne de deux années
parmi ces grands oubliés 3% sont au
chômage et 13,7% en inactivité si bien
qu'il ne dépendent que du RSA ou d'une
pension d'invalidité ou du revenu
d'accroix l'un des grands arguments de
notre arpo rapporteur doit nous dans son
rapport c'est que le taux d'emploi
connaît une hausse rapide autour des
années 2010 en passant de 40,5% fin 2010
à
47,1%, fin 2013 les réformes de retraite
successives ont contribué à augmenter le
taux d'emploi des 55 ans oui nous vous
accordons que le taux d'emploi augmenté
de devoir va point pour les 60 et 61 ans
mais je cite aux prix social élevé d'un
allongement du sas de précarité et on en
revient précisément à notre amendement
sur les conséquences d'une réforme des
retraites sur leur poids des seniors les
ouvriers ont payé un lourd tribu si bien
que le taux de ceux ni en emploi ni en
retraite a augmenté de 16 points par
conséquent 2019 les ouvriers à 61 ans
sont plus souvent ni en emploi ni en
retraites cette situation concerne 35%
d'entre eux les conséquences sont
lourdes selon l'adresse le taux de
pauvreté de ces personnes et de 32%
contre 7% pour ceux en emploi ou à la
retraite toutes les données statistiques
le démontre vos arguments ne sont pas
recevables je vous le dis tranquillement
nous vous appelons solennellement
retirer ce projet de loi en posant au
préalable la question du travail plutôt
que de vous acharner sur les droits à la
retraite merci
merci ensuite madame ponce le 3123 et
ensuite vous en avez plusieurs
d'ailleurs donc vous pouvez peut-être
les présenter
en prenant le temps nécessaire
merci alors il s'agit là on revient un
petit peu au licenciement pour
inaptitude mais de les préciser pour les
salariés de plus de 50 ans et sur les
cinq dernières années en effet on y
reviendra beaucoup les contraintes et
des risques physiques se sont fortement
accrues depuis 30 ans l'adresse a mesuré
ainsi l'évolution sur 30 ans en partant
de 1984 et les dernières statistiques
c'est 2016
l'adresse dit que l'exposition à un
moins trois contraintes physiques ou
éventuellement je pourrais vous le dire
lesquels concerne 34% des salariés dans
la dernière date il n'était que 12 pour
cent en fait tous les indicateurs vont
être multipliés sur cette période par
trois voir par 4 pour les ouvriers et
les employés c'est pas 34% on en parlait
à l'instant c'est c'est 63% qui sont
concernés par cette exposition à trois
risques pour les ouvriers qualifiés ont
un peu moins mais guère vous voyez
60,8%. 13% des employés étaient exposés
à au moins trois contraintes ils sont
46,9 ça a été multiplié par presque 4
l'intensification du travail touche donc
particulièrement les salariés les plus
âgés et d'ailleurs
l'Observatoire Everest avait posé une
question à savoir demander aux ouvriers
à 60 ans comment ils envisageaient
la possibilité de travailler deux ans
supplémentaires et bien la moitié des
ouvriers des employés doutent que leur
état de santé leur permettent à
l'horizon de deux ans de poursuivre leur
travail actuel alors on nous parle de
reconversion à 60 ans pour être on va
arrêter peut-être le cynisme et je
propose qu'on refasse cette évaluation
et qu'on leur demande maintenant à 60
ans s'il se voit travailler 4 ans de
plus alors là c'est pas la moitié que
vous allez avoir bon j'en ai fini pour
le premier amendement je passe au second
monsieur le Président si vous permettez
c'est un peu la même chose mais il y a
il n'y a pas que les contraintes
physiques qui effectivement touche
massivement je l'ai dit des ouvriers les
employés il y a aussi les contraintes de
rythme et dans les contraintes de rythme
vous allez trouver la flambée en France
mais aussi en Europe il est vrai des
risques psychosociaux et là être exposé
à trois contraintes de rythme ça
concerne des hormones un tiers des
salariés ils étaient quasi inexistants
30 ans avant ils étaient à 6% vous voyez
et ça concerne pas seulement les cadres
là encore ça concerne massivement les
cartes par rapport à l'évolution mais
aussi 53% des ouvriers qualifiés soient
six fois plus que 30 ans auparavant
ces rythmes c'est effectivement ces
contraintes temporelles ou ces
contraintes d'orives c'est de ne pas
pouvoir quitter son emploi des yeux
aujourd'hui 43% des salariés sont sous
cette contrainte avoir un rythme de
travail imposé par un contrôle ou un
contrôle humain ou un suivi informatisé
concerne un tiers des personnes et tous
ces indicateurs d'intensité soit
physique soit de contraintes par le
rythme et bien effectivement explose il
y en a une autre qui est intéressante
c'est l'imposition de normes de
production à satisfaire en une journée
là et là les cadres aussi sont touchés
21% des salariés effectivement ont une
contrainte temporaire sur la journée et
plus grave quand même vous en avez quand
même
non maintenant c'est 48% excusez moi
c'était 21% donc ils ont été multipliés
et ce qui a été multiplié aussi c'est
l'imposition de normes de production
insatisfaire en une heure qui est passée
de 5% à 29%. voilà toute cette
intensification du travail des
contraintes d'origine ce qui nous
conduit à dire qu'avant de prolonger de
60 à 62 et à 64 il faut changer le
travail bien évidemment
donc je continue donc j'en suis sur le
troisième le troisième
alors c'est là c'est la publication des
indicateurs relatifs à l'emploi des
seigneurs en distinguant alors là par
genre leur sexe ainsi que les actions
mises en oeuvre pour favoriser l'emploi
au sein des entreprises
bon là c'est voilà je peux pas encore
vous assommer peut-être de enfin mais je
pourrais et nous y reviendrons parce que
quand même vous voyez ça fait le lien
avec les régimes spéciaux quand on nous
dit mais ils vont passer dans le C2P
c'est pas gênant je le répète le C2P
c'est deux ans maximum de départ
anticipé et quand on passe à 64 ans
c'est 62 donc les fameux ouvriers les
50% qui disaient à 60 ans qui pourront
pas aller à 62 vous voyez
là si on leur donne deux ans ça sera 62
hein en toute état de cause dans le
meilleur des cas
madame poncer vous en avez encore un
ensuite parce qu'il y a deux amendements
identiques qui suivent
dont l'un est présenté
à 7 dans ce cas non c'est ça que vous
vous dit 3178
supprimer la possibilité laisser un
accord de branche de déroger aux
indicateurs et méthodes de calcul
déterminées par décret et relatifs à
l'emploi des seniors
bah oui moi je suis assez pour la
hiérarchie des sources donc
effectivement je pense qu'il faut les
branches c'est bien mais elles doivent
être plus favorables je rappelle plus
favorable que le niveau supérieur qui
est le cadre légal qui lui-même doit
respecter des règles européennes donc
des indicateurs
définis clair comme des méthodes de
calcul permettent des analyses
intéressantes et y compris de façon
comparative et
je pense qu'il n'est pas normal de
risquer de les faire disparaître lors de
discussions de branches parce que ces
données sont précieuses
elles sont comme elles doivent être
comme une à toutes les branches qui
permettent une analyse globale pour les
politiques publiques et pour changer le
travail pour la prochaine loi ça aidera
ça éclairera le gouvernement il faut des
critères communs à l'échelle d'une
société tout entière par contre bien sûr
la branche peut ajouter des indicateurs
pour tenir compte de sa spécificité mais
je pense qu'il faut pas qu'elle en
retire voilà je vous remercie
merci Madame ponce donc maintenant
amendement identique au dernier que vous
avez présenté le 4186
groupe communiste
4100 non non on va les exposer
tranquillement
allez-y madame poursu Pauline merci
monsieur le Président cette amendement
de bon sens a reçu un avis défavorable
la commission alors qu'il souhaite
simplement
assurer une clause de non régression sur
les indicateurs mesurés par l'emploi des
seniors cet amendement est l'occasion de
revenir sur l'anthologie de cet article
qui prévoyait comme pour faire croire
que les marges de négociation étaient
possibles que l'index senior ne
s'applique qu'aux entreprises de plus de
1000 salariés cette obligation de
publication n'aurait concerné que 0,15
des entreprises 6040 au total seulement
un peu plus de la moitié des salariés du
pays auraient été couvertes par cette
disposition les autres leur sort
n'intéressaient pas a priori le
Gouvernement l'Assemblée nationale avait
justement avant de rejeter l'article
abaisser le seuil de publication à 50
salariés je vous remercie
ensuite madame Ferré le 2784
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement donc concerne la Linéa 7 où
nous proposons de remplacer le mot
déterminé par le mot enrichir dans la
phrase une convention en accord de
branche étendue peut déterminer la liste
des indicateurs cet amendement vise
effectivement de ne pas laisser la
possibilité à la branche d'établir des
indicateurs sur l'emploi des seniors
moins 10 ans que le décret qui sera pris
à cet effet
merci ensuite le 4189 madame a ponceau
poli
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de repli du groupe CRCE en
temps s'assurer que par convention ou
lors d'un accord de branche étendu les
indicateurs retenus ne puissent être
inférieurs à ceux de la norme nationale
le cas échéant et même si nous le
regrettons définis par la loi
réglementaire je vous remercie merci
ensuite le 2483 monsieur Breuillet merci
monsieur le Président c'est toujours moi
pour mon mon collègue Thomas dessus la
réforme proposée par le gouvernement va
grandement affecter les seniors c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils seront avec les
salariés des millions dans la rue le 7
mars prochain le gouvernement fait un
pari qu'un recul de l'âge légal
augmentera mécaniquement le taux
d'emploi des seniors et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure dans la discussion que
cette se fait était avéré dans les
réformes précédentes mais si ce fait est
partiellement avéré ce qui est également
intégrer c'est que les seniors les plus
éloignés de l'emploi ne sont pas
miraculeusement embauché après la
réforme et à chaque réforme de décalage
de l'âge légal du départ en retraite
nous avons constaté un pic de rupture de
contrat de travailleuses et de
travailleurs seniors des seniors sont
ainsi licenciés ou placardisés sans
raison basculant le plus souvent dans la
précarité on a évoqué 100.000 pour la
réforme de 2010
le texte je fais cours le texte de
l'article 2 renvoie un décret le soin de
fixé la liste des indicateurs de cet
index ainsi que leur méthode de calcul
or cet article laisse également la
possibilité à la négociation collective
ce qui est une bonne chose mais deux
branches d'adapter ces indicateurs si
l'adaptation de l'index peut permettre
une meilleure prise en compte de chaque
milieu professionnel la rédaction
actuelle de l'article pourrait être
dommageable il y a un risque de
dégradation excusez-moi
des mesures de l'emploi des seniors
qu'il convient d'encadrer c'est pourquoi
par cette amendement nous demandons à ce
que toute nouvelle modification des
indicateurs par accord de branche ou
conventions n'entraîne pas une
dévalorisation des indicateurs
déterminés par décret
merci ensuite le 3734 et vous en avez
plusieurs monsieur Ferney qui se suivent
mais commencez par le 3734 allez-y
3000 734 donc l'index senior en l'état
risque fort de ne pas permettre de réel
changement de comportement des
entreprises faisant preuve d'une
discrimination dans l'emploi des seniors
pour le rendre plus ambitieux le présent
amendement
propose que pour les entreprises qui ont
conclu un accord de branche ou une
convention relative à la définition des
indicateurs mentionnés le bénéfice des
dispositifs généraux de réduction ou
d'exonération de cotisation sociale soit
conditionnée à une mise en place
effective et au respect des indicateurs
de l'index seniors le suivant le tableau
ne montre pas c'est le
3735 c'est un amende repli par rapport
aux précédents puisque il s'agit d'un
moment presque identique sauf qu'il ne
concernerait que les entreprises de plus
de 300 salariés
et je passe au suivant si vous le
permettez donc c'est le 736 c'est 3736
mais le tableau est en panne c'est pas
grave c'est le 3736 donc l'amélioration
de l'emploi du seniors ne passe pas
seulement par la mise en place d'un
index senior ambitieux en parallèle des
procédures devraient être instaurées
dans une entreprise pour permettre de
garantie les bonnes conditions d'emploi
du seniors nous proposons donc de
conditionner les exonérations fiscales
des entreprises à la réalisation
d'entretien avec les salariés de plus de
55 ans qui travaillent dans l'entreprise
depuis plus de trois ans ces entretiens
pourraient aborder la question de la
pénibilité du travail de la formation de
la qualité de vie au travail et de
l'aménagement du poste de travail
c'était le
3736 et le suivant c'est le 3737 voilà
donc pour faciliter la mise en place de
l'index senior et le rendre effectif il
est important il est nécessaire est lié
une échéance claire et réalisable qui
soit fixée nous proposons donc la
fixation d'un délai précis de
publication et de transmission pour les
entreprises concernées à savoir le
premier février pour l'année civile
précédente et donc par dérogation
présente disposition les indicateurs
portant sur l'année 2022 devrait être
publié au plus tard le premier janvier
2024 merci Monsieur Ferney conçu nous
avons trois amendements
identiques le premier présenté par
Monsieur brouiller au nom de Monsieur
dozu j'imagine c'est exact monsieur le
Président c'est bien non de mon collègue
dessus je propose enfin nous proposons
en fait avec les collègues du groupe de
compléter l'article 2 à la Linéa 8 par
une phrase ainsi rédigée l'inspection du
travail se voit immédiatement communiqué
sur sa demande les données ayant permis
la construction des indicateurs lors de
ces contrôles sur pièces et sur place
c'est pas que nous pensons que
l'inspection du travail a des moyens
démesurés pour aussi suivre avec
vigilance ce fut index senior mais ça
nous semble absolument nécessaire
que de prévoir un accès aux indicateurs
de l'index senior à l'inspection du
travail lors des contrôles sur pièces et
sur place parce qu'il y a des défaut
d'une mesure réellement ambitieuse nous
proposons pour notre part de revaloriser
aussi les outils de contrôle de l'index
senior nous proposons bien sûr de
revaloriser l'implication des
partenaires sociaux et c'est je voudrais
le redire la mesure essentielle qu'il y
a sur ce sujet de l'index senior mais il
nous semble nécessaire que l'inspection
du travail puisse également jouer un
rôle de contrôle dès lors que l'index
senior tel qu'il est prévu actuel m'en
n'ai en rien contraignant ou en presque
rien contraignant excusez-moi de
dénaturer un peu la réalité de l'index
merci l'amendement suivant
identique présenté par Madame Ferré
identique juste trois mots à ajouter
puisque cet amendement vise à ce que
l'inspection du travail a un droit de
regard sur la construction des
indicateurs par les entreprises qui sont
soumises à publication d'un texte dit
senior
merci et l'amendement
4198 présenté par Madame Cohen oui
effectivement c'est le même amendement
avec l'index tel qu'il est conçu les
entreprises de moins 1000 salariés
seront tenus de faire état d'en faire
état pardon à partir de novembre 2023
les entreprises d'au moins 300 salariés
auront jusqu'en juillet 2024 et celle
qui en compte moins de 50 en juillet
2025 vous l'aurez compris en écoutant
toutes nos interventions nous souhaitons
cette index plus contraignant qu'il ne
soit pas un gadget ou un badge de bonne
conduite pour les entreprises mais une
mesure permettant aux salariés au
syndicats aux représentants du personnel
d'objectiver ce qui se passe réellement
derrière les portes closes des
entreprises aussi nous avons à coeur que
sa publication soit un impératif l'index
montrera en creux en réalité les
pratiques des sociétés envers leur
salaire leur salarié seniors et
finalement leur bien-être au travail ça
non publication de la de contrevenir aux
dispositions légales peut révéler en
effet une politique d'emploi et de
gestion des seniors problématiques plus
exposées au maltrait